hey everyone welcome to simply learn's
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning the w expert full course
let's have a look at the agenda for
today's session first we will learn what
exactly is w followed by that we will
understand the data connections provided
by w then we will learn how to create
data extracts using table u moving ahead
we will understand the tableau
calculations aggregations in tableau
creating quick table calculations box
and viscous plots etc next we will learn
each and every single type of charts
available in tableau then we will move
ahead into formatting and annotations in
tableau then we will understand how to
filter data entirely followed by that we
have organizing and simplifying data in
tableau next we will understand how to
run mapping in tableau then we have the
data blending data sorting special field
types providing data paths parameters in
tableau then we will understand the
level of detail expressions in w
finally we will enter the most important
segment of the tableau course that is
the tableau dashboard after
understanding all the fundamentals we
will put our skills to test using the
tabular projects
and finally we will go through some of
the most frequently asked interview
questions based on traveling i hope i
made myself clear with the agenda but
before we begin make sure that you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
don't forget to hit that bell icon to
never miss an update from simply learn
this has been
ben started a store that sells
automobile parts like brakes exhausts
tires lubricants and car interiors he
made a good start with his business and
achieved profits
however as days passed by along with his
growing business he faced some business
challenges he received orders from a
variety of customers with different
needs and requirements
for example
the northern states had higher demand
for performance parts than others and
the eastern states demanded farm truck
parts and lubricants more and apart from
this a few products weren't performing
well in the market and remained unsold
with the unbalanced requirements and
economy variations ben had a tough time
helping his customers with products on
demand
he slowly realized he needed something
new that can help him tackle the store's
problems
what if ben had a tool that could keep
track of his store's inventory in sales
a geographical map that can recognize
the demand for various types of products
from different regions
a forecast feature that could predict
the economic fluctuations in the market
and help then visualize every single
detail visually on one single dashboard
this software could practically solve
many business problems and also could
identify new opportunities to improvise
and grow the business
such types of software tools are called
business intelligence tools and one such
tool is tableau
tableau was capable of learning the
store's business patterns and running
queries against the data to help
visualize the flaws and resolve them
quickly
now let us understand how ben used
tableau and solved the issues related to
his business
ben collected his store's entire sales
data from the previous quarter and
ingested it into tableau now using
tableau ben was able to categorize the
data based on monthly cells
it took the daily cells and considered
it as the x-axis
and then tableau computed the sales in
the store
now ben clearly understood the products
that outperformed the sales charts and
the products that did not have much
demand
let us elaborate a little
ben found that the performance parts
like sports exhaust turbochargers and
engine management systems were selling
well with the tableau forecast feature
ben identified the demand for
performance products in the next quarter
so he raised the prices on a few
products that had the peak demand and
earned higher profits
in the second forecast report bin found
no significant elevation nor drop in the
demand for the tractor parts and
lubricants
apart from this bin saw the sales graphs
of electronics encountered a drop in the
current quarter compared to the previous
quarter in the cells of electronics like
the music and infotainment systems were
low to improvise and stabilize the
fluctuating sales of electronics ben
came up with some exciting clearance
cell offers on electronic products
using tablet's geographic map feature
then understood the product demand at a
regional level he found the northern
regions were interested in performance
kits for their imported sports cars the
eastern regions had good demand for
truck parts and lubricants
using tableau ben could generate various
visualizations based on his data and
come up with business oriented decisions
last but not least ben could also
monitor his decisions and was able to
make some necessary modifications to his
business model on the go
ben is now delighted as working with
tableau is a smooth and efficient
process
today tableau is being recognized as one
of the best in class business
intelligence tools because of its
powerful and dependable features tableau
can support and connect to a wide
variety of data sources like the cloud
dbms excel sheets and even get connected
to real-time data from websites
and bin keeps his customers happy using
tableau to solve his business problems
today more and more leading business
organizations are leaning towards
business intelligence tools intending to
improve their business
upon quite a success in this business
ben decided to get a detailed
understanding of tableau by enrolling in
simplylearn's tableau training program
which is led by industry experts who can
train him according to the current
business and i.t standards to make his
business even more successful so what is
w
so before we understand what exactly is
w let us imagine a simple situation
imagine that you are an office worker
and you get some loads of data
maybe like millions of rows or billions
of rows and you are supposed to extract
the insights of that particular data
so what do you do you basically load
that data into a database and try to
write the sql commands and then try to
extract the
insights of that particular data
so this kind of approach is basically
time consuming and you get exhausted
now
what if you had a tool
which could write all the sql commands
for you in the background and all you
had to do is just to drag and drop the
data
sounds interesting right
so tableau is just the same all you have
to do is just drag and drop the data and
it will automatically write all the sql
commands you ever wanted to write on
that particular data and it will give
you
live data interactions and advices for
the future
now with this let us understand the
definition of w so basically tableau is
a business an analytical software tool
developed in america w helps people to
understand visualize and make data
driven decisions in real time with
extreme agility and accuracy
now with this let us continue with the
next topic which will be about the
various versions of w
so at first we have the tableau desktop
so tableau desktop is a data
visualization application to facilitate
you to examine virtually any kind of
structured data and generate highly
interactive beautiful graphs dashboards
and reports within minutes once a quick
installation you can tie to virtually
any data source from spreadsheets to
data warehouses and display information
in several graphic perspectives designed
to be easy to utilize you'll be working
more rapidly than ever before
next we have the w server it is a
business intelligence application that
offers browser-based analytics anyone
can utilize it is a rapid fire
alternative to the slow pace of
traditional business intelligence
software it is an online solution meant
for sharing distributing and
collaborating on content created in w
what makes w different it is proposed to
everyone there is no scripting required
so everyone can grow to be an analytics
expert you can grow your deployment as
you require it
train online for free find answers in
minutes and not in months that's the
speciality of w
now followed by the w server we have w
online
so w online is a business intelligence
application that offers browser-based
analytics anyone can utilize as
discussed before it is a rapid fire
alternative to slow paced additional
business intelligence software so
tableau online is a secure cloud-based
solution for sharing and collaborating
on tableau views and dashboards next up
we have the table you public
so now i want to give you guys a serious
heads up if you're a beginner in w w
public is like an open source whatever
the data you choose to work on using
tableau public it goes to public so kind
of like wpublic is not preferable if you
want to work on your company's sensitive
and confidential data w public is a free
software to facilitate anyone to get
connected to a spreadsheet or a file and
create interactive data visualizations
for the web
it is delivered as a service that
permits the user to be up to and running
overnight with tableau public users can
construct amazing interactive visuals
and publish them quickly without the
help of programmers or id
it is designed for organizations to
facilitate their websites with
interactive data visualizations
there are higher limits on the size of
data you can work with and among other
features you can keep your underlying
data hidden and lastly we have w reader
w reader is a free desktop application
that you can use to open and interact
with data visualizations built in
tableau desktop with tableau reader you
can filter drill down and discover
humongous loads of data now moving ahead
we have the features of w
so these are the few important features
that you might want to consider
those are the first one robust security
tableau takes special care of data and
user security it has a foolproof
security-based authentication and
permission systems for data connections
and users access
w also gives you the freedom to
integrate with other security protocols
such as active directory kerberos etc an
important point to note here is that the
w practices
low level filtering which helps in
keeping the data secure followed by that
we have the collaboration and sharing
feature tableau provides convenient
options to collaborate with other users
and instantly share data in the form of
visualizations sheets dashboards etc in
real time it allows you to securely
share data from various data sources
such as on-premise on cloud hybrid etc
instant and easy collaboration and data
sharing helps in
getting quick reviews or feedback on
data leading to a better overall
analysis of it another extremely useful
feature of tableau is the use of time
series and forecasting
easy creation of trend lines and
forecasting is possible due to tableau's
powerful backend and dynamic front-end
you can easily get data predictions such
as a forecast or a trendline by simply
selecting some options and drag and drop
operations using your concern fields
next up we have live and in memory data
tableau ensures connectivity with both
live data sources and data extraction
from external sources as in memory data
this gives the user the flexibility to
use the data from more than one type of
data source without any restrictions
you can use data directly from data
source by establishing live data
connections or keep that data in memory
by extracting data from a data source as
per their requirement
tableau provides additional features to
support data connectivity such as an
automatic extract refreshes notifying
the user upon live connection fail etc
next we have informative view and even
the mobile view one of the key features
of w and the one that got its popularity
is its wide range of visualizations
in w you can make visualizations such as
bar chart pie chart gantt chart billet
chart motion chart tree map box plot and
many more
like you name it w got it you can select
and create any kind of visualizations
easily by selecting the visualization
type from the xiaomi tab apart from that
it is capable to represent data in
mobile view as well tableau acknowledges
the importance of mobile phones in
today's world and provides the mobile
versions of tableau app
the next and the last feature is that
being capable of accessing data from
various kinds of data sources
tableau offers a wide range of data
source options where you can get
connected and fetch data from data
sources ranging from on-premise files
spreadsheets relational databases
non-relational databases online cloud
data for data warehouses and many more
so followed by the features now we will
discuss about the advantages of w
so following are the advantages of using
w first one it has remarkable
visualization capabilities
of course the unparalleled capabilities
of visualizing information is on top of
the list of w's software benefits
followed by that we have the ease of use
the tool's intuitive manner of creating
graphics and a user-friendly interface
allows non-developers to utilize the
basic apps functionalities to the
fullest users arrange raw data into
catchy diagrams in a drag-and-drop way
which facilitates information analyzing
and eliminates the need for the help of
it department and patent building
next high performance apart from its
high visualization functionality uses
rates its overall performance as robust
and reliable the tool also operates fast
on big data which makes it powerful
performance on an important point on the
list of the advantages of w
and next is the mobile friendliness one
of our best advantages out of the
tableau benefits is its efficient mobile
application which is available for both
ios and android it adds mobility to
tableau users and allows them to keep
statistics at their fingertips as well
as supports their functionality that
desktop and online versions have
and finally we have the thriving
community and forum
w has a rich community the number of w
fans who invest their expertise and
skills in the community is increasing
rapidly business users can beef up their
knowledge on data passing and reporting
and get many useful insights in this
community also forum visitors are ready
to help settle any user issues and
also share their experience next up we
have the disadvantages of w
the first major disadvantage is the high
cost
the tableau is not the most expensive
visualization software especially
compared to such business intelligent
giants such as oracles and ibm solutions
all the same the license is quite costly
for small and medium companies which
makes it one of the considerable tables
disadvantages
next is the inflexible pricing tableau
sales team is not flexible enough to
provide case-by-case approach for their
customers ignoring the fact that each
company has its own unique requirements
for visualization tool package the
tableau sales model requires clients to
purchase an extends license from the
start
as a result a lot of companies that use
w arrive at the conclusion that they
don't need all their license features
they would prefer to buying a set of
requirements and scale them if necessary
followed by that the next disadvantage
is poor after sales support on multiple
message boards users complain that
tableau software lacks proper after
sales maintenance if customer has
software performance problem the support
team does not settle the matter by
investigating the problems root and
eliminating it
next we have the power bi capability or
the poor business intelligence
capability as previously mentioned the
tool provides best-in-class information
visual interpretation however it lacks
the functionality required for a fully
fledged business intelligence tool such
as large-scale reporting the building of
data tables and statistics layouts
and lastly the poor versioning only the
recent tableau versions support revision
history while for the older ones
software rolling back is impossible now
with the advantages and disadvantages
discussed let's move into the top
companies hiring the companies which are
desperately looking for tableau experts
are accenture ey pepsico deloitte
wells fargo cab gemini and many more
now let's discuss the
humongous and handsome salaries offered
by this tech giants
so according to glassdoor the average
salary of a tableau expert in america is
82 000 grand and for a beginner it is
somewhere around sixty thousand dollars
per annum and at the highest rate it is
one lakh ten thousand dollars per annum
similarly the average salary of a
tableau expert in india is five lakh six
thousand per annum and for a beginner it
is somewhere around three lakh sixty
thousand and
and for a highly skilled experienced w
expert the salaries range from 8 lakh 75
000 per annum
so let me now begin with connecting to
data now in this particular topic
we are at the end of this lesson you
will be able to
understand how you can connect to
tableau data server you will be able to
differentiate between a join and blend
how can you perform a join on a data how
can you blend our data we will discuss
the various connection options available
we will understand how tablet server
works in terms of the kerberos
authentication all right we will
understand various performance
optimization techniques as well shadow
extra extracts
as well as different methods that we can
prepare in terms of the data that we
want to analyze all right so
let me begin
now the very first topic which is uh
connecting to taboo servers i'm going to
first take you through a couple of
vegetation flights here and then quickly
move on to the environment where we will
actually then start exploring the
topic so
now when you want to connect to a data
source in tableau server it's pretty
simple you can connect to a flat file in
your local machine so one is you will
click on to the server in the start
screen and or you can specify the server
name you can specify and uh show your uh
uh login your credentials the username
and password and based on that you can
perform the you can have your connection
to the database all right so that's how
you can connect to the table server as
well all right so
that's the very first basic so the
tableau administrator is the one who
assigns the roles and creates these data
sources all right and you have tableau
has the facility in order to import
different forms of data for the analysis
for your ease
and once you're connected to the tableau
server then you need to select the table
server data source on the data menu you
will need to select a data source to
download a local file a local copy you
can select and create a local copy and
then you can also duplicate a duplicate
of that data source will be added up
into your data window so that's how you
can connect to tableau server as well
all right and uh it basically promotes
various features wherein uh you can then
connect to the tablet server for your
data so you are in this example you can
see that you're able to connect to the
table server as an admin and connect to
the sample superstore and it downloads
it creates a local copy and duplicates
all the data in that particular data
window
that's how we can see the sample triple
stores and you can connect to the server
uh next we are going to also understand
what is joining and blending so before i
move on to the presentation slides here
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
move on to the environment directly let
us start exploring these blending and
joining features uh right there in all
right i'm going to simply just clear the
sheet that we have
and um
let's go back to the connect to data
source window all right now in terms of
uh
this is where you're able to connect you
can see the tabloon server so it's
through the server that you can connect
where then you can specify
your server credentials and you can
click on connect and uh based on that
that's how then you can provide the
credentials and uh login all right now i
do not have a server or connection there
and i can show that example but this is
how you can click on any of these
servers you would have to type in the
url click on connect and then provide
the usernames and login provided and
that's how you can connect to your data
source using a server option all right
i'm going to show you the file option
wherein you can connect to an excel and
let us discuss the join and the blending
part here all right so let me click on
itself we have the sample super uh data
store here and in this
when i pulled in order all right i
pulled in the first sheet so there are
three sheets in that particular excel
file
when we pull an order this is how you
can identify that whatever are uh these
are the header names these are the
dimensions and measures that's how it's
getting identified you can notice all
the dimensions are first place you have
all your measures then you're able to
identify the data type and the role an
abc which is a contextual value or
numeric value that means it's a
dimension with a pound sign what kind of
a data role is it tablets automatically
identifying each of these rules as well
all right even in the metadata that's
how you can see the field names the
field uh name that you're going to see
onto your tape onto your view and the
table from which it's going to be
getting pulled in from in this you can
rename in case you want to change the
particular name hide it or alias it or
describe it
all right so this is how you connect now
connections is where you have the option
to connect between knives and extract
now if you connect to live that means
you're connected to this particular
sheet live that means any update
happening on to your uh sheets any kind
of updates on the sheet there is a nice
connection it will automatically update
your views as well onto your sheets that
you're creating and in case if you
select on an extract all right this is
what it means that it allows uh what it
does is it imports that data into the
tableau data engine first in the data
engine where it's going to perform these
queries it will create an extract and
based on these we can then start using
the connection all right so what it does
is it disconnects it's more like a small
extract more like a cube if you
understand it in that manner tableau
creates an extract of that file
providing you uh a disconnected uh
whether it allows you to give you a
better performance a better query
uh that's how you can then uh work on
and start creating uh and working on
these extracts now you can refresh these
extracts at a timely manner as well so
that is what a tableau extracts are
where it extracts it as a copy of the
data uh and saves it in the engine and
that's how then the performance as well
gets better in terms of using where you
can connect to your particular data all
right so you can work with uh multiple
data sources data sources can be of any
type all right wherein you can edit from
the number of lists that you can see it
can be a flag file a server file as we
saw or the saved one
and we can also then
join multiple tables within the data or
we can also blend when it's coming in
from different data sources then we can
also perform a blending so let me first
show you an option for join now you can
see we have the order table now when i
drag and drop the people uh sheet as
well here you can see that tableau has
automatically created a join
all right it has automatically created a
join when we have pulled in two tables
coming in from the sheet and by default
all right we have the inner join that
tableau creates so it creates a inner
join here wherein again you can then
click on the join option here and you
can specify and modify the join based on
whether you want it as an inner join
which is a default you want a left join
now if you see the right join has been
disabled here okay i will show these
options here by default the right join
is uh disabled by uh tableau by default
by default and to enable that you will
have to uh connect to your uh excel
sheet in a different manner i will show
that your shortly so that's how you can
change and you can perform your joins
this is where you can explore and show
the join clause and here again then you
can specify that you can see a join
that's being created amongst the data
source which is region and region people
among these two data all right it's also
showing you the join and whether it is
uh equal to or not equal to all right so
you can connect to multiple tables and
uh based on that you can add in our
tables you can specify the different
joints and based on that then when you
click on sheet uh you will then be able
to see that there is a join being
performed there are two tables now the
people's table also that has been added
in and it has now performed an inner
join on our data and you can start
using this particular option so let's
say i'm going to pull in the region on
my columns and i'm going to have my
sales on to my rows it's now providing
me uh details of my sales at a regional
basis now let's say i also want to
analyze the
people belonging to these regions
depending on the color so it's going to
change the colors based on the central
east south and west
all right that's how these are uh the
people the number of people belonging to
each region that it has identified so
that's how it has taken up the region
people as you saw there was a joint that
was created and it's given us that
particular option and based on that you
can see here we just have uh this
particular data source here and that's
how you can see now i used it earlier as
well if you remember we had pulled in
one particular table hence the blue tick
mark sign here enables and shows us that
this is the primary data that they use
now this comes in picture when you're
using a particular join so let me right
now just um
uh use this particular uh
detail here and we're not going to
require this all right so let's just
close this
we just need one right now because we're
discussing on blending i'm going to show
you the blending part later right now
we're discussing on joints so
uh that's how you can join in your data
sources and you can combine multiple
fields using these joints so when you
have when you have multiple tables you
can simply connect to the data let me go
back to the data source pane uh this is
the startup page the data source page
and you can see the joints has been
performed now let's say you want to
create a join where you want to force
due to certain situations and scenarios
where you want to force
a right outer join all right or right
join or for that matter you want to
write a custom sequence now you're not
able to write a sequel right here in the
in the drag area pane where you can drag
and drop your sheets from the excel file
or any kind of a file that you're
connected to for that uh and to enable
the right join you will need to uh
connect to your data in a specific
manner so let me open up a new instance
of tableau here
and let me show that to you as to how we
can enable the right choice and how we
can have our custom sequels as well so
in case if we want to write in a custom
sql on our view then how can we perform
that initial custom sql all right
okay so let us connect to our data here
and i'm going to take you on to the
excel file
now when i click on the sample super
store here okay uh what we had done is
we clicked on open and that's how we
opened up the uh file all right and
that's how we could see the sheets now
instead of using the open option
directly what i'm going to do is in the
drop down all right here instead of open
we have an option that says open with a
legacy connection all right this is what
is going to enable us to write a custom
sql where we can specify a query rather
than using the entire data source or
pulling in the entire table so we're
clicking on the second option in the
drop down in the open tab here you will
be able to see the open with legacy
connection i'm going to uh so ensure
that you've selected that and that's how
you will then connect to the data source
and with that you now have a new custom
sql option that's opened up for you all
this is where you can once you've
connected you can double click on the
new custom sql
and you can write in your query you can
write in the sql where you want to
perform the query and pull in your data
all right you can have your
select
from
and let's say
orders
all right so that's how you can perform
and you can write in a custom sql and
you can pull in the required data you
can or have your required table that you
can pull in in terms of or creating a
sequel that you want to pull it or and
have your data all right so you can have
your select from
the
orders
and
review the results
so here you can see the order table has
940 we have a preview of the data
available in that particular uh sheet
that we pulled in all right and we can
now parameters is what i'm going to
cover when we come on to that particular
topic so i'm going to leave this for now
so that's how you can write your custom
sql and you can click on ok and that's
going to pull in your entire data and as
you can see now instead in the earlier
view i'm going to just switch to the
earlier instance of tableau you could
see that you could see the name of the
table that i dragged and pulled in you
could see the name order but in case
when we write a custom sql then it gives
us the name which is written as custom
sql query all right and this is where
you can get the information you can edit
the query in case you want to change the
results and requirements so that's how
instead of clicking on open you click on
open legacy connection and you can have
your own custom sql defined
now along with this
all right when you open and when you
click on a legacy connection when i drag
in the people's table here you can see
that even the options for right joints
have now been enabled so by default
tableau disables the option for right
join and in case in certain situations
and circumstances you want the right
join to be enabled you will in the same
manner have to import and connect to
your data using a legacy connection and
you will have the right join which is
going to be enabled there for you all so
you can have your custom sequence or the
right join
in that case which gets enabled and you
can use a custom sql or a right join
right so that was custom sql then
joining is where you can as i mentioned
identify and choose between the clauses
and the clause that you want to add in
right now let me show you an example of
blending as well so i'm again going to
open a new instance of tableau
all right and uh with that i'm going to
show you the example of blending so
let's say you have uh you want to join
in and when it's the best time where is
the best way that you should use now
joining is when you have all your
multiple tables that you want to join
coming in from one data source blending
would be required when you want to join
in
multiple tables coming in from different
data sources
or for that matter you can also blend
even though the tables are coming in
from a single data source there might be
instances that you might want to have
still perform a blend instead of a join
so let me show that option to you
all right so let me connect to the data
let's connect to excel
pull in our sample superstore file that
we have
we have the order table all right and
i'm going to go on to the sheets here
all right so we have
one order we have one data which is the
order table now i am going to again
click on
add a new data source coming in from the
same excel file and this time i'm going
to have the people's table
and
move to the sheet so now if you notice
we can see two
data sets here which is one for the
orders and one for
people here and uh in here now this is
where the blending will will take place
this is where you will have a blend
automatically when you pull in a view if
there is a common view that comes into
picture now let's say i'm going to first
pull in the order date onto the columns
all right
and as soon as i pull in you can see
that my order table has now got a blue
check mark which has become a primary
data force all right and now let me pull
in sales onto my rows
and from people let me have
from the people's table let's have
region pulled in and added to the colors
so region has become a secondary data
set and now you can see a blend sign
right a linking or data blending that
has automatically been performed on both
these two data sets all right that we
have the order table and the people's
table blue being primary and people uh
which is being or secondary in this case
all right so that's how you can mention
now in terms of blending what happens is
you cannot specify the joint during this
case there is a primary and secondary
data and it is automatically blending in
the data for you it is automatically
pulling in uh the data you will not be
able to your select on the kind of join
you will not be able to manipulate the
join so that's how even though at times
you have the same tables that are coming
in as i mentioned there are times where
you might want to perform and change the
join so that's when you can use the
joining table option that comes into
picture so that's the difference between
your blending and between joining the
tables
right
so uh you can see this available link
and you can see how it was simple to
drag a particular view and pull in data
and your as well region has been added
to the color pill because of which the
legends have been created identifying
all four regions present in the data and
it's also letting us know here in the
marks that region is coming in from the
secondary table you can see the orange
amber tick mark here and that's how you
can identify that region is coming in
from the secondary table that's been
created all right
in
terms of uh connecting as well wherein
you can combine
and uh have the joint enabled now
depending on the kind of data all right
going back to the data source depending
on the kind of tables and the kind of
data that we have that's when we can
enable and have the joints that we can
decide on all right so one is you would
require and need to have
a multiple uh legacy connection with
which you can then define the right
outer joints all right and that's how
you can proceed and have additional
joints that you can work on
we also discussed how we could create
and connect to a custom sql query all
right and uh that is how we could using
the legacy connection uh also enable the
right outer join where we could then
perform a right join on our tables as
well all right and in case if it's a
query then it gives them a name of
the query uh as a custom query
which is what we saw onto the preview
and the extract there all right
now in terms of extract all right now
extracts are basically your saved
subsets of the data source which will
help you in improving the performance so
instead of as i mentioned instead of
being connected to a live connection it
is better that we select an extract
which creates a subset and stores it in
the
uh tableau engine wherein it performs
the queries and it takes advantage of
this functionality where it is not
connected to the original data source
and with this it can actually reduce the
total amount of data in terms of
defining and limiting it so that's how
you can create an extract and let's say
uh once you've created an extract you
can then perform like i said you have
the edit option where you can edit the
additional detailing you can allow an
incremental fetch happening where then
you can refresh the data each time or
your data is updated you can provide an
incremental fetch so this can help you
in improving your performance you can
take advantage of the functionality in
terms of the data source for uh
using the discount uh the distinct
accounts as well and moreover it's more
like an offline mode you're actually
accessing your data as an offline access
where it's not directly connected and
you're able to use it like a data local
data
all right so that is the difference
between a live and an extract so that's
how you can make use of the legacy
connections as well so let's go back to
the presentation slides and have a recap
now uh
these are the joining tables that's what
we discussed that in terms of the tables
that we have we can join our table and
we have various joints available where
it makes it easy for us to uh analyze
the data that we want to view we can
join two or multiple tables and based on
that we can customize the inner the left
the right over the full outer join now
the full outer join also depends on the
kind of data source that you're
connected to all right so in case of an
excel file we still do not have the
right outer joint
option which is enabled so this possible
option again when you open with a legacy
depending on the data type is how you
would have the right outer join that you
can pause and have it enabled so this
would be depending on the kind of data
source file also that you have and you
have these four join types that you can
use in terms of joining tables in
tableau
now when would you want to use a join
all right so
a scenario is that you have a sales
manager of an online shopping website
and he wants to analyze the customers
who have returned at least half the
number of orders that they have placed
now to fulfill this requirement he will
require a worksheet wherein he can join
the orders and the return table on a
particular common dimension all right so
that's how then he can create a join he
can change this between uh the inner
default to a left join between the order
tables and the return tables and based
on that he can then get to know the
customers who have returned at least
half the number of orders that were
placed all right
now in terms of enabling on the right
outer join uh this is taken care of by
the microsoft jet data engine driver so
in case if you all are facing a trouble
where you're not able to connect and see
that particular option it's throwing an
error this legacy connection options
comes in only when you're using a
microsoft uh jet data engine driver this
is easily available in case if you do
not have it you can install this driver
and with this it will enable the right
outer join and the custom sequel for us
all right to enable the uh
right outer join here that's how you
open it with a particular
uh legacy connection
now in terms of a right outer join we
saw an example we can force and use the
right outer join we can select on a new
custom sql where we can type in and have
our custom
sql generated
and that's how we can work on with the
sql where we can provide the sql syntax
and based on that the data source will
then be generated
now in terms of blending this is what
happens when you have multiple data
sources in your view or when you want to
establish a link between there or you
want to
blend your data uh it does not create a
row level join so in case uh
like the example that we did also which
is coming in from the same sheet from
the same excel file but we did not want
to create a row level join then that's
when data blending would come in handy
you can use it with a related data
across multiple sources that you want to
analyze in one particular view so that's
how you can blend your data which
creates a primary and a secondary data
so we saw that in this example uh you
can see that you know the customer
segment department and sum of sales
wherein the bars are being created which
are coming in from the time from the
primary connection but in terms of the
sales plan all right these sales plan
are coming in from a secondary data you
can see the amber connection you're the
amber liner that is allowing you to
understand and segregate and
differentiate that it is a secondary
connection
so in tableau uh that's how you can
identify as you saw that your primary
source and you have your secondary
source wherein you can identify and
distinguish you can distinguish between
the common fields that are present in
your data and you can establish a
connection in case if it has not
established a link you saw that there
was an automatic link then you can
provide a link
by explicitly defining a link as well
let me take you back to
the environment
all right so this was the custom sequel
now in this case in case if there is uh
no link provided then you can provide a
particular link onto your view you can
have the option if it has not enabled
then you can select your particular you
can see that uh it has not uh implicitly
defined but it's giving you an option
that there is possibility of linking so
you can explicitly define you can click
on this link and use person as a linking
field and this has also linked in your
data with the previous data that you
have all right so that's how you can
define and explicitly mention uh the
way that you can blend your data and you
can identify another way can also be
very you can edit uh the connection in
the mapping and that's where you can
perform so you can go back to your data
sources and you can explicitly define
you can identify uh whether the first
rows are the names whether uh the rows
here are automatically generating a
field or not all right so that's how you
can have these two tables and you can
define the blending whether you want it
or not you can disable the linking as
well in case you don't want to perform a
particular link
so uh with uh coming to that now let us
understand i've already discussed the
difference between the joints and blends
and where you can use it so let's uh
have a recap again in terms of joining
uh joining is a sequel term where it is
combining two data sources coming in
from a single data source while in terms
of blending it's more about combining
two different data sources into one
single sheet all right uh joining is
done once as a data source and this can
be used for every worksheet while
blending will be done individually for
every worksheet okay and both the tables
that are joined must must exist in the
sql database while in blending it helps
us combine the database which is coming
in from different sources different
locations and in case if it's a
multi-dimensional source if it's a cube
then you cannot perform a join and in
terms of blending you have a primary
source and but in terms of a primary
source it cannot be a cube but your
secondary source can definitely be a
cube that you can use in terms of
performing a blend all right
so that's how you can optimize your
connections you can select whether you
want to have uh perform a blend on your
connections you want to perform a join
depending on the kind of connections
that you have and that's how you can
work with them with the different data
sources that you have available we're
going to proceed further in
understanding how we can create data
extracts all right so as i mentioned the
extracts are where you create a subset
of your data source you can extract a
particular data you can save it as a
subset which will help you in performing
and improving your query so instead of
the live you can simply click on the
extract which will create a tableau
extract for you all right
so uh let me just show you let me take
you to the
uh repository and in that you will be
able to identify in my tableau
repository data sources
you can see that
we have a tableau extractor for world
indicators so what it's done is it has
created a subset of the world indicator
data source and it's created it's
disconnected it's an offline mode which
can allow us to improve the performance
it can be accessed offline as well when
you're away when you're probably
traveling and we can then create an
extract where we can keep refreshing it
with the original data and
we can then replace it with the content
or we can provide a complete incremental
refresh with these all right now extract
can also be created from uh within our
data sets as well once you've performed
so let's say let me go back to
our view here and
let's have
category in our columns let's have
quantity on our rows now even here you
have the option of going under the data
menu where you can uh click on the
extract data so whatever you've selected
any kind of performances and any kind of
the aggregations that you perform now
this is your uh data that you perform
now instead of even though it's a live
connection you can still go to the data
menu here and you can click on create
and extract the data which will create a
subset all right which will create a
subset for you where you can create this
data and you can provide the different
fields wherein you can select what you
want to filter whether you want to add a
specific
filter to your field whether you want to
specify the aggregation data for the
visible dimensions this is where you can
select the option for the measures to be
aggregated uh the default instead of
using the default uh what is the kind of
aggregation that you want to use so this
can allow you to minimize the size of
your file as well and increase your
performance you can click on aggregation
and you want to roll up the dates to
your to quarter to month you can select
on the aggregation
the number of rows that you want to
allow in terms of the incremental fetch
or you want to
provide
the incremental sets for all rows or
just the top particular selected rows so
you can select on that particular option
once you've specified all these
detailings you can then click on extract
and that's going to uh save the
subsequent uh file in the location that
you have saved in terms of the extract
and it will save up an extract for you
all right so when you click on extract
it will ask you for a subsequent
location of where you want to save it
there is a custom query that we have
used and let's say if we save it on the
desktop itself you can see the save type
which is a dot pde which is a tableau
data extract and the next time you can
start working using these data extracts
and you can start performing where you
do not need to then have your custom
sequels uh written in or any other
details you can simply use the extract
and start working on it all right you
can actually
restrict the size and improve the
performance and you can perform data
extracts from these as well all right
and then again in the data menu option
here you have the option to replace your
particular data so let's say you have
your uh option where you want to uh
perform off or incremental set then you
can replace the data you can upgrade it
or for that matter you can go to this
particular uh table you can refresh your
data with the uh connection where you
have the uh additional refresh data you
can view your data you can duplicate it
rename it we just discussed how we can
create the
extract data options as well so that's
how you can perform and see uh and and
have an extract
of your data
so that was uh using your data extracts
now
uh you can also write custom sequence so
we've discussed that let me take you
back to the presentation slide and have
a recap so here this is the window that
we saw in terms of the extract where you
can add in the qualifications where you
can narrow down your data even more
further you can select an incremental
fetch whether you want it for all the
rows or limit the number of rows to be
included in that particular extract uh
then we also saw that how we could write
a custom sql we could open it in a
legacy collection that helped us to open
up a custom sql window where we can
write down the sql with the exact data
that we want to analyze this can again
help us in improving the query
performances where we can write down and
provide uh an optimized query against
our data that we want to use
all right
uh in terms of these supported data
sources a lot of you all have questions
what kind of data sources are supported
now tab new desktop is uh supporting the
uh it determines uh the support
depending on the kind of license that
you have purchased all right so only
when you have the required license it
will support the different data source
types and you have a personal edition
which provides you and allows you to uh
use the support for a lot of databases
uh but it is the professional edition
that provides you additional database
options that you can connect to so data
such as text files access files excel
sheets
and so on these can be connected through
the personal editions while in terms of
a professional edition the professional
license this is where you can connect
other than the other than the personal
editions you can connect to the personal
uh additional databases like your oracle
sql and you can connect to
certain more additional connections here
which is supported 40 plus data
connections which is supported in the
professional edition all right so that's
how you can connect to these different
connections now
also along with that once you have your
server that comes into picture uh what a
server does is it provides you a
cordross authentication which is a
supported trusted authentication uh that
it uses in terms of your single sign-on
all right so what it does is in this
case
is that
uh as you can see it is a protocol that
is provided to trust the authentication
between your machine
and
that's how uh
it uses a third-party network service
called as the kdc the key distribution
center which provides a secure
connection between your desktop and the
server machines and this is supported
based on the kerberos authentication all
right and that's where you can it
handles in it uses only one user
authentication the permissions and the
access control uh in such cases like the
workbooks uh is is going to be now these
the workbooks and extracts will not be
handled by for draw but uh the
permissions and access control those are
the things those are the detailing that
third rush would be handling in terms of
your uh data condition
all right so basically if your tablet
server has a code box enabled
on your machine with a balance active
directory credentials then what tableau
does is it connects to your server and
it completely skips the step of
authenticating so in case let me take
you to the environment
you're in the environment you can see
the server option and in this you have
the publish workbook now let's see when
you want to you've created your workbook
and you want to publish it onto your
server now this is where it asks you to
connect to the server here it asks you
to provide the credentials and then
based on that it then asks you once
you've connected to let's say you've
connected to your server it is then
going to ask you or sign on for that
particular configuration now if you have
a foreground environment which is
activated then it's going to skip these
basic steps here and it will directly
allow you to connect and skip these
connection uh that comes in in between
so that is what is called authentication
all right so it's a single sign-on
method
and once you have that enabled then you
can make use of these you can you need
to configure your tableau server with
these kerberos configurations all right
so it's a three-way authentication
protocol
now how this works is a mechanism of a
mutual authentication between the client
and the server is provided with the
kerberos authentication so when the yoga
user logs into the directory it directly
asks for the credentials which are
authenticated by phone rot and once this
is authenticated a ticket is generated
and sent to the user's computer and then
when the user tries to connect to the
tableau server from the desktop or the
web browser the server or the tablet
server authenticates the user and it
directly allows us to perform now this
mechanism is provided before the network
connection is opened up between the
client and the server right
so how does it work in terms of a single
sign-on how does it support it if it
supports a single sign-on option wherein
uh you have the server configuration and
in this you have a core browse tab where
you can
define enabling the single sign-on
option in terms of the environment where
you can connect
individually you can connect with a
single sign-on to connect to the server
from your desktop or the web browser
all right in terms of trying to
optimizing your query
now how can you optimize your query
tableau adopts various query
optimization techniques to improve the
query performance all right so what it
does is it provides parallel query where
it improves the performance speed of the
dashboard by performing and providing a
capability of executing a parallel query
so in this case what happens is it
executes more queries at the same time
it is independent uh queries that start
at the same time and hence we are faster
and improve the performance so this is
what tableau does it provides the
parallel query next is it has the query
fusion in this what it does is tableau
has the ability to reduce any kind of
complex or large number of queries into
a fewer simple ones so that's how it
again optimizes your performance right
and then it also has external query
caching
in this it quickens up the process of
optimizing your data by processing it
into a cache all right so that uh it
does not need to go and hit in the
warehouse every time that you require a
particular data so this is possible with
the external query flashing so tableau
adopts these various uh methods it also
has a data engine vectorization wherein
it has a in memory analytics volume and
it's a faster query which helps in
reducing the extract size and creation
time
so based on these that's how it can
improve the performance and uh that's
how it optimizes these techniques and
tableau handles and takes care of each
of these so it performs a parallel query
by phone it uses a particular query
faction which is short it does not uh it
shortens up all the queries the external
query caching that it uses and also
provides a data engine vectorization
where it makes it even more quicker and
faster
now
in order to quicken the process of your
loading of data what tableau does is it
creates a safe or shadow extract file on
its own all right what it does is uh in
the repository for you to load your data
faster other than you creating an
extract it takes up the content of a
shadow extract in your repository file
and it saves it up as a shadow while
you're working on the workbook all right
and that's where then when you're
creating and working uh based on the
legacy non-legacy excels or text files
or statistical file it creates a shadow
extract file automatically wherever you
have your repository so in case when
you're working on something what it does
is in your repository folder all right
where you have your repository which is
in my document in the data sources you
can you will be able to see that it
provides you a particular
uh extract that is a shadow extract
that's been created and you can see that
uh it it creates a shadow extract right
there where that you can make use of all
right or in the background so this is
done automatically by tableau to quicken
up the process this is something that
you do not need to handle uh by default
is this uh the folder there is a folder
that gets created uh when you have a
proper license version then you will see
that in the repository folder you will
have a shadow extract folder
and uh based on that that is how
you will see that at least the first
five at least the top five shadow
extracts will be safe with the dot dtde
extension and that's how it uses and
replaces it replaces the oldest one so
when you have a licensed version in that
case then that's when you will be able
to see this extract folder and this is
when it quickens up the entire process
let me begin with the next topic which
is calculations all right
now in terms of calculations uh these
are pretty much uh these help us in
terms of understanding in terms of
creating an extractful meaningful result
of our data all right so sometimes it's
pretty much necessary that we make use
of calculated fields now you've already
seen that i've been making use of we
created the script to date and i created
various uh calculations and i've been
mentioning that uh you know i'm going to
discuss these in detail in the next
topic when we have like we created the
primary table the secondary table
i showed you the quick table
calculations so you're already pretty
much aware of how i was using them but
let us understand these in detail now
all right so let me begin for the end of
this session in terms of when we
complete this topic you are going to
understand how you can make use of
string dates logical as well as
arithmetic uh calculations how you can
work with different aggregation options
how you can make use of the grand totals
and subtotals the
quick table calculations which are
inbuilt by tableau how you can create
automatic and custom splits
discovering the ad hoc analytics which
is offered by tableau and how you can
perform the lod that is level of details
calculation all right so let's begin
with the very first topic how you can
work with strings paid logical and
arithmetic calculations wherein you can
create a completely new field which is
not present as part of your underlying
data you can actually create that using
a specific formula there are functions
and operators provided so you can use a
string right you can use a date you can
use logical operators or arithmetic
calculations and based on that you can
then apply certain functions and
operators and finally create a
calculation so you can create these four
kinds of calculations the arithmetic
state string and logical ones all right
so
let us understand and explore how we can
use how tableau provides us various
built-in functions wherein we can use a
calculated field and create an
arithmetic calculation so we've seen an
example where i created a profit margin
or a profit ratio in our earlier
exercises in our earlier demonstrations
wherein you can use let's say when you
want to create the profit ratio we use
the sum of profit divided by sum of
sales so that's how we created an
arithmetic calculation similarly we can
create a new string calculations all
right so i'm going to show you an
example of each of these uh and then we
can also we saw right now i created the
dates to ship in the earlier example for
one of our views wherein i use the date
calculation where we created the day and
we will also make use of one of these
logical calculations to
see and understand how we can make use
of the
if
the logical calculation operators and
functions and make use of these
calculations so
uh we have a scenario here so before
that let me move on to our tableau
environment here all right and uh
let me start showing you one of the
examples of each that we can use in
terms of creating them
all right
and in here let me quickly create one
simple view so i'm going to add in so
i'm going to add in my states to rows
and i'm going to add sales to my columns
and quickly create one bar chart here
all right
now i want to have my uh let's say i
want to analyze the
uh sales across each space here all
right but i also want to know the count
of distinct items all right so in this
case what i'm going to do is let me have
my product name
all right because i want to know the
count of distinct distinct items i'm
going to right click on the product name
here and i'm going to then drag and drop
this to the columns over here or right
onto the column section now because i've
selected the right click option and then
dragged in dragged and dropped in the
product name or dimension onto the
columns it opens up the drop field as to
how i want to use it whether i want to
use since i want to use a distinct field
in analyzing all right it opened up this
particular window of whether i want to
use account product name or account
distinct product name all right so i'm
going to select the count distinct
because we want to distinctly analyze
the counts of the items all right and
click on ok
all right uh what are aggregation
functions aggregation functions picture
the sum the average these are the
different aggregation functions so right
now the basic default is sum all right
it's summing up the measure whatever
measure we've selected that's the
aggregation function so whether you want
to sum it up you want to average it out
you want to use median count minimum
maximum these are all the inbuilt
aggregation functions provided by
tableau
or then you can also use the aggregation
functions when you're using calculated
fields beyond the ones provided so those
are aggregation
functions oh yes we have a bar chart i'm
going to still analyze and show these
details to you further in terms of
aggregation so what i did was instead of
just using the product name as it is
i've used your account distinct all
right uh could you please drag and drop
the product name or you want me to show
that to you once again siva yes i'm
gonna take this off my
uh columns here now when i want to add
my product name if i directly drag and
drop it onto the columns it's just going
to add up the details asking me how i
want to use it as a dimension now that's
not what i want to do because as for the
analysis i want to i want the count of
distinct items right so for that i'm
going to simply right click on product
name and then i'm going to drag and drop
the product name onto the columns so in
that it's going to then ask me what is
the aggregation i want to use on my
dimension
and i want to use the count this
distinct you can see count product name
and count distinct product name so i'm
selecting the second option and clicking
on ok
now i want to see the sales for items
sold and this particular field is not
available in my data set so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to create uh
one using my calculated field because i
want to see the sales per item all right
so
let me uh right click on my sales here
all right in the database one way of
doing it is you can right click or in
the drop down you have the option of
clicking on create a calculated field
all right for that specific field or in
the data pane in the drop down here it
is create calculated field okay you can
select either option when you select the
drop down for from here it's blank and
you have to input the formula when you
select a particular field and do it then
in that case it opens up and adds in the
field by default when then you can
specify the functions and operators so
let me specify the arithmetic
calculation here so uh the first type
that i'm showing you the very first
option in terms of calculator field the
arithmetic calculation all right
so let's have our
sum of sales
and
i'm going to divide this because i want
to know sales for items sold now that is
the reason i've created the count
distinct product name here so dexter
when you mentioned you think two bars
the only reason i did that was right now
i'm just trying to create account
product name and once i add in the
details i'm then going to replace the
particular view from it all right so i'm
going to divide this with
the
count
product
name
all right so that's how we are creating
our sales for item calculation using the
arithmetic calculation method sales for
item so i'm dividing the sales based on
the count distance of the product name
all right
and let me click on ok
and with that
in the measure we have a new measure
that's added up which is the sales for
item this is this particular calculated
field i'm going to place it it's getting
placed in the measures directly because
it's returning a particular number right
the numerical value and hence it's
placed in measures now let me add my
salesforce item into the columns so i'm
going to replace my uh account product
name here all right
so here i can now see uh you can see
notice and uh
this this shows aggregated all right
this shows it's an aggregated means it's
a calculated field that's been used now
all right so i'm able to see the sales
for items from comparing the sales
versus the sales for items on a distinct
basis all right and i cannot change the
aggregation function here so notice
earlier when i specify the default
function is some we can change these
aggregation functions for a particular
measure from the inbuilt ones or we
could specify it as a calculated field
now in this case it does not give us any
option to change the aggregation
function it shows it's aggregated
already because it's a calculated field
it's taking in the aggregation as we
specified in the in the arithmetic
calculation
all right so that was your example of
having your calculated arithmetic
calculated field
so here we can see the sales for item
for each state
right this kind of an example is an
arithmetic calculation
great so let's move on now we've already
seen we've covered up the first type
which was arithmetic calculations now
let me show you an example of how we can
use calculated fields and create a
string calculation all right so let's
say we want to analyze the customers
beginning with the name x all right the
one that's illustrated in the
in the slide here which says that we
will be analyzing the customers
beginning with
s
okay so
in this case let me add up my
customer uh name into the rows
right
and let's have profits in the columns
all right so we have customer names in
rows and columns
all right
now what i'm going to do is let's
consider that at this point of time we
have a range we have a scrolling and we
have a range of customer names here and
i only let's say want to at this point
of time let's say i want to develop and
come up with a scheme that all the
customer names beginning with the word s
all right they are
entitled to getting uh or a discount all
right we're coming up with a particular
offer now it would be pretty difficult
if i add up the customer name in the
filters here and then manually select
the one with
s right or i can also use the wildcard
wherein i'm using the option to select
one with an s similarly i can also make
use of the calculated field to achieve
the same scenario
so let's click on create calculated
field let's name this as
customer
with
x all right customer beginning with s
and now we're going to provide now if i
expand this arrow here you can see there
are a lot of functions provided by
tableau in terms of number string date
type conversion logical aggregate user
and table calculation and that's where
uh based on that you can make use in
selection and it also specifies the kind
of requirement of any a small definition
an example preview of it all right so in
case it's difficult to remember all the
aggregations it's difficult to
understand how it's created you can
simply click on the uh type and that's
how you can come up with uh the
definitions of these as well
right
so let's have
the function start with because we want
all the customer names starting with
and
we wanted for customer name
beginning with
s
now in terms of the calculation it's
telling us there is a particular error
so let's find out does that
all right and now my calculation is
valid i have my
uh customers beginning with s all right
i'm creating a calculated field and
click on ok now this is going to bring
in a string function so when i click on
ok it adds up a boolean logic a two and
false uh data type and it adds it up to
the dimensions because it is related it
is based on the string functions here
for the customers all right so uh this
is how we have a calculated field
selected and let me this time add up the
customers with s into the filter
all right and now it gives me the option
of true and false all right whether i
want to include it whether it's true or
false and let's say i'm going to say
that i want to include that particular
option with the customer name beginning
with
all right and we do not see data here
let's just check what is the problem
here
this is excluding our data let's just
give me a moment
we have our customers let me quickly
edit
start with customer name as
this is absolutely okay
all right
so we have the true and fault option and
we want it true as the customer name
beginning with s and click on ok and we
now see a list of customers name that is
beginning only with the letter n
all right
uh jaclyn starts with
customer name
so this is how we can make use of the
string as uh calculations all right
next now let us see how we can make use
of the date calculation now we've
already performed this kind of a
calculation so i'm going to explain uh
in terms of the date calculation when we
wrote in the dates to ship what what
each of it uh meant all right when we
wanted to analyze the difference
uh yes it's going to be case sensitive
in that case today you're absolutely
right so uh in case if it's not a lower
case it's not going to take in the
function tableau so now has a case
sensitivity and it only takes in a lower
case
uh i'll show that example to you so when
you're saying that uh
no in in terms of the letter s it's not
going to be case sensitive for the uh
alphabet because you basing customer
names beginning with the alphabet s in
this case it's not but overall it's case
sensitive i'll just show you that
example in terms of the date
calculations right away
so going back on our tableau sheet here
we have the dates to ship that we've
already created so i'm just going to
click on edit now in this case uh if you
notice the date difference uh what needs
to be specified for a date difference is
there are three parts to this all right
so let's say now we wanted to analyze
the number of days it took from for the
order to get shipped all right so in our
data set we already have the order date
we have the ship date
all right and we want to calculate how
uh the number of days uh is required in
terms of shipping the product so uh i'm
using the date difference function and
in this case then we need to use there
are three input that comes into picture
all right there are three cases here so
the first one is wherein you want to
specify what part what role is it going
to play all right it's going to play the
role of a day because i'm finding out on
the basis of day you can add it as week
month depending on the role that you
want to play and then the difference
between those two values that you want
to subtract the difference that you want
to have between these two so we have the
order date and ship date now if the same
day you can see the calculation is valid
now
let me change this to a
and you can see that it shows an error
in the calculation so in this case it
needs to be a lowercase that's when the
case sensitivity is uh it takes an
effect and it's going to throw in an
error in case if you're going to write
that right in terms of the first
parameter all right uh it's not going to
be case sensitive because you're only
specifying the customer name here so
you're picking up that from the customer
name what is the letter alphabet that it
should take up all right
in terms of the date shift-to-date
calculation fees you need to it's case
sensitive that it only works with lower
cases because here you're specifying
what part is it going to play the date
to shift uh what part will it play in
terms of the difference it's going to
play the part of day
all right so that's how you can create
the days to shift and you can make use
of the date functions and you can create
a date calculation all right that's how
we have the base to ship option and we
can make use of it although it was not
present in our data and we can analyze
our entire data here in terms of
creating the dates to ship
so that was your days to shift date
calculation similarly then you have the
logical calculation all right so i'm
going to show you an example of or how
you can use a condition or a logical
calculation and uh use them in terms of
analysis so let me go back to
our environment here let me create a new
sheet
now let's say let me give you a scenario
here that we want to highlight all these
subcategories that have sales of more
than 100 000 all right so for that we're
going to create a calculated field that
will only specify the sales of sub
categories of 100 000 and above so let's
create a calculated field let's give it
a name as sales kpi
and now this is where we're going to
provide logical functions and operators
and let me enter the syntax so i'm
saying if my
sum of
sales
so the bracket is my sum of sales
is
greater than
100 000
then
hi
is
low
and let's end
the
injection
is my calculation valid yes it is and
i'm going to now create a sales kpi so
that i can highlight these sub
categories having sales more than 100
000 x high and low all right let me
click on ok
and now we have the sales kpi that's
added up to the measure but we've used
you can see uh although it's a measure
it's showing the abc icon here in terms
of the data type because we have it as
high and low measure your all right so
in terms of the expected let's see the
expected output here and see how we can
make use of it so i'm going to add in
my
subcategory
into the columns
and let me add my
sales
into
my sales kpi into the row
right
and
or rather i can add up or let me add
sales to my rows all right and this is
where now when i want to highlight uh
that's how i can create the calculated
field and add it up in the colors so
that it can distinguish between high and
low so i'm adding up the sales kpi into
the colors and now we can distinguish
that the kpi's one which is about 100
000 it's high or then low so these are
the ones we can identify between high
and low the alerts that we can make use
of
uh early if you have a question and date
difference is it considering the order
date minus ship date or ship date minus
order date uh minus referring to minus
uh one second let me just open up the
ship date uh when you're saying
uh it is order date minus the ship date
right
so that is what it's going to refer to
because whatever is the order date minus
the ship date that's how we're going to
get the date difference right the date
took to ship
excellent all right
uh yes i am at sales kpi
let me open that up in terms of editing
if you want to edit that particular
yes
uh delete or you asked me to open up the
sales kpi
there you are
can we use a multiple conditions uh in
terms of multiple condition if you're
saying that uh high average and moderate
is that what you're saying
like let's say you want to say that if
our sales is thousand then it should be
high our airship phase is uh it's 80 000
then it should be moderate or low then
you can use the elsif operator
that's how you can add up the else if
operator
and make use of or the detailing that
else if sales is uh greater than or less
than 80 000 then create it as
you can use that multiple options only
thing is you need to use the l zip
option then in this case
yeah you can use multiple conditions
like or let's say let me quickly show
that example to you
so if you create a calculated field here
uh you can use a case in which you can
mention the east west or low right you
can use different kinds of examples and
cases and scenarios where you can
mention uh the different sales and
budget that if my sales is so much then
it should be you know that particular
date or else you can use multiple uh
functions that's not going to be a
problem
all right
so this is going to be an example of
your
logical
operator
we have our next topic which is working
with aggregation options all right now
this again you've noticed a couple of
times that by default we have our
calculation wherein tableau takes in a
default calculation all right being the
sum
but uh you can change these aggregation
functions you can see an entire list
that tableau provides to us all right
and that's how you can make use of these
aggregated functions that is your uh
whether you want to have a summation
whether you want to have an average all
right so there are different
mathematical functions your that you can
see and these each will produce a
particular aggregated data all right so
these are what are called your
aggregation functions all right and
these will help you perform the kind of
aggregation the kind of calculation that
you want to perform on that particular
field
so you can make use of these functions
all right and
so now understand one thing you can use
uh tableau to set up your aggregations
only for measures in your relational
data sources all right in terms of a
multi-dimensional data source it
contains the aggregated data already all
right so it provides you these lists of
predefined aggregations or as you can
see so let's understand each of these
functions now when it comes to an
attribute all right in this case this is
going to be returning the value of your
expression which has a single value for
that goal all right so let's say let me
move to the environment here to
understand and explain what these
particular functions are all right i'm
going to pick up and discuss a few of
them now let's say we have sales all
right sales by default when we talk
about
the aggregation function so you need to
right click and go to default properties
and you have the aggregation option
where you can see sum is set to default
you can change these default properties
to the aggregations that you wish to
which are present here all right you can
have an average you can have a median
account account distinct and then
various other options present here right
so when it comes to using an attribute
all right or the attribute aggregation
function as specified then in that case
it's going to return the value all right
of the expression as one particular
value of the row okay so uh in this case
it shows the field then changes to a
text i can attribute where it ignores
any kind of null value if it's present
okay so you can basically make use of
these when you want to only pull in
let's say values of all the rows uh
which is otherwise displayed as a
different uh different values in it okay
so that's when you can make use of it
now that is not present here in this
case as you can see as an attribute that
comes in handy when you're using
calculated fields all right so let's say
when you open up a calculated field you
will see you have the attribute which is
termed as attr the attribute expression
let's say we're saying the attribute of
sales so you can notice it gives you the
entire definition it returns the value
of the expression or if it only has a
single value for all the rows in that
group and in case if not then in that
case it will displayed as an asterisk
sign
so that's what it does it it's useful
basically this aggregation is useful
when you want to aggregate a particular
dimension all right let's say we have
customer name we want to aggregate and
come on to the number the names are the
total number of customers that you have
so in that case it will only return
single values of that row if not then it
will otherwise just clear an asterisk so
that's when this kind of a function
comes in handy for us uh not that you
cannot use it with uh measures but just
an example of the best use when you want
to aggregate a particular dimension and
you want null values to be ignored you
want to know the single values of all
the rows then this particular uh
aggregation function is going to be
helpful all right then in terms of your
uh next one you have then you have
dimensions now these again will return
all the unique values all right in your
measures or dimensions both so it's
going to only bring in all the unique
values more in this case
and in terms of sum you're already aware
in terms of average then you have median
now this is again to do with it's going
to return the median of the numbers in
the measure then you have count and
count distinct all right so count is
going to uh ideally return the number of
rows in your measure or dimension and uh
in that case the null values are again
going to be ignored but in terms of
count distinct it's going to return the
number of unique values so count will
return all the values the number of
values which are present but in terms of
count distinct it will return the unique
values in a measure or dimension all
right so that's how you have various
aggregation functions and to know
details of each of these you can make
use of the uh
tableau provides the details about each
of these because your various as you can
see your various inbuilt functions
there's an entire list of functions that
you can make use of and uh anywhere you
need to know additional details now
these are the basic ones that you can
see the inbuilt ones
so if you want additional aggregation
functions as well you can make use of
these functions from the calculated
field and each of these has its
explanation provided but in terms of the
basic usage one the ones that you can
change it to default yours a basic list
that tableau provides so it has
additional functions as well but that's
when you have to then open up the
calculated field and make use of those
functions
so that was your aggregation function
all right
then comes in your grand totals and
subtotals we've again we're already
aware we've seen this in our earlier
examples that we're able to make use of
our totaling option we're able to add in
the grand totals as well as subtotals of
the data wherein we can see the grid
that is displaying the subtotals and the
grand totals here for us right you can
see the grand total right here and you
can see the subtotals for each category
level as well and the grand total across
every uh sub category for this
particular category towards its
particular year all right now to enable
your
grand total you can simply go to the
analysis menu so you've seen that in our
earlier examples as well and uh that's
where you can go to the analysis totals
and you can make use of and have your
totals enabled so that's how you can
have your total
now coming on to quick stable
calculations let me now discuss on this
because uh uh the other topics for
recaps that we've been performing now
you've also seen that there were
instances when i performed quick table
calculations all right so these are
basically calculated fields when we
apply a particular calculation at a data
set level all right so tableau provides
certain functionalities it provides
certain uh
functionality you're in terms of
applying the calculation at your table
level so as the name suggests table
calculations it allows us to provide
that kind of functionality whereas it
computes
the uh
applied uh values all right in your
entire table
and this is basically dependent on the
structure the table structure that you
have in your view okay so that's how you
can make use of table calculations and
what tableau does is it provides some
inbuilt functions which are usually uh
in use it provides it as an in-built
quick function where you do not have to
input any kind of formulas in those
functions you can simply click on those
options and it's going to immediately
compute the entire range specified that
you're selecting all right
so let's see one of the examples so i'm
going to take you to the environment
here
and
let's have our order date in columns
let's have our sales in rows
and let me just enable the labels as
well
all right so that's created a line view
since it's a series over time uh so if
you remember in the chart type the best
uh example is to make use the best
references to make use of the line graph
and hence tableau automatically creates
a line charted over us right now we have
the yearly sales as we can see all right
now
let me add sales again to the rows so
what i'm going to do is we can see two
uh sales calculations here so what i'm
going to do is with the second
calculation i'm going to in the drop
down you have a quick table calculation
consisting of all your detailed
calculations here as you can see so you
have the running total so this is going
to show you a cumulative total all right
then you have the difference so this is
in terms of showing you the entire
difference about uh some absolute change
between the measures that you have all
right then you have the percent
difference so this will give you
difference in terms of a percent value
all right it shows you the uh difference
in terms of those options as a percent
then you have percent of total so this
is going to give you the values as a
percent to the entire total so what is
the contribution of each year in this
case to the entire total uh that you
have in terms of the contribution all
right the sales then you have rank so
this is going to rank our values
numerically we have percentile which is
going to compute our values in a
percentile or manner we have moving
average
so this is going to calculate the
fluctuations in terms of identifying uh
any long-term trend all right then your
today titles are then you have compound
growth rates you're over here all right
so there are various such functions that
you can see here which are provided by
tableau all right now i'm going to
change and
uh use the percent of total all right so
this is going to give us the values of
the percent for every year that it is
contributing towards the entire total
what each year is contributing so let's
click on percent to total
and now we can see here the second sales
pill there is a
calculation icon here in terms of the
triangle icon that you can see which
says that we performed a table
calculation on the second sales bill all
right
uh so in that case we can now see the
percent to sales for all the years what
is the contribution
all right so that was a quick table
calculation where it allows us to apply
based on our uh requirement the defined
functions we can simply click and view
those calculations instantly in our view
all right now in a lot of cases we might
want to customize these calculations so
that's when then you can have your
additional table calculations that you
can manually perform all right
uh there is a question put up placed by
shibani shibani in terms of moving now
uh when we're talking of moving average
or any kind of moving function all right
here it says moving average but this is
one of the calculations it can be a
moving average or any other calculation
wherein moving calculations will ideally
show us a
fluctuation or fluctuation that we can
identify in terms of long trends all
right so that is moving calculations on
so we will see an example of this of
what are moving calculations and uh
that's how you'll be able to understand
the difference of uh what these are
right
and again like i said to understand
these in details we can also make use of
the
aggregation functions the calculator
field where it can give us the entire
detailing right
so this was a quick example let me add
this as a quick table
calculation
now next as i mentioned these are
inbuilt ones that we made use of but
there are times where we might want to
customize these tables all right so in
this case let's have our order date back
in columns let's have our sales in rows
right we've again created a view let's
have uh now in this case i'm not going
to add in another fill i'm going to uh
perform the calculation on the sales
pill itself that we have here all right
so you're on the sales pill now instead
of quick table i'm going to select on
add table calculation because we want to
provide a customized one so if you've
seen an example earlier when we wanted
to build in a pareto chart or other kind
of charts where we made use of stable
calculations right it calculated our
data in terms of calculations across at
the table level
so let us understand how these
calculations come into picture how they
compute the values of the table level
all right so these are the drop downs
again provided in terms of the functions
the computations that we want to make
use of and apply to the rows in our
database to calculate our values all
right so let's say i'm going to select
running total this time all right
and instead of the uh how do i want to
summarize so i want these running totals
and your again whether i want it as a
sum as an average or minimum or a
maximum let's say i'm going to pick up
average so what we're doing is we're
going to be seeing our sales as an
average running total here all right and
in terms of running along whether you
want it across the table a particular
cell all right or a particular field in
this case so we can uh specify now since
we have order date and our view is
giving us the option to select from the
available view so let's have it running
uh across and let's have it across the
order date all right so that's how we
can select each of these different uh
requirements and compute the value that
we want to perform
right so that's how we can have these
computing that are taking place
right
so
when you talk of table across then in
this case it computes the entire table
it will compute the entire table across
here that they can see in terms of uh
the the tables here which are present in
our view all right when we talk about uh
calculating in terms of the cell all
right then in that case it's going to
pick up uh the individual cells present
in our row all right
so in this we are addressing to the
individual cells which are present now
uh had i changed this to a table view
then that's when we would specifically
talk about let's say we were at a your
level and we had aggregated this as a
quarter level or let me just change that
option and show it to you all so that
you'll get a better idea let's have this
at a quarter level all right and let's
say let me add in region as well
now in this case we would be talking
about individual when we talk of table
calculations happening at cell level
we're talking of an individual level all
right so we're talking of 4 2011
for the central region for quarter one
all right so i wanted to address
individual cells and perform the
calculations right so that is what would
be the cell level our then i can select
an individual field so that's when we
were selecting the order date and in
that case we could select a particular
field and mention that it needs to
compute at that particular field that
i'm specifying all right so i'm just
going to undo and go back to our
previous view where we were performing
our table calculation and we selected
the running total
we had our summation summarizing at
average and we selected a particular
field all right and let's click on ok
let me enable the data labels so here
now we can see a calculation that it's
performing or running average of sales
here for us now all right now in the
same case let's say we want to also have
a secondary now that was a basic
calculation now let's say i want to
perform another calculation i want to
apply to this particular table so then
we can also apply a secondary
calculation in that case wherein we can
combine two calculations and uh we can
perform one or one of these calculations
so let me on the drop down you have the
option of edit table calculation or
clear it so let's click on edit and this
is where you can see the check box that
says perform a secondary calculation on
the result so what tab you will do is it
is first calculate this particular uh
primary calculation that you have all
right the basic calculation basic table
calculation that you're providing once
it computes this particular calculation
it will then perform a secondary
calculation or second calculation on
this particular result all right
so that's how it's going to then compute
and combine two calculations in this
case so in the second example let's say
let me specify
um
let's have the difference from let's
keep it to basic so the first we wanted
as the running total once it's given us
the average running total i then wanted
to perform a secondary calculation on
the running average of sales where i
want to know the difference from in
terms of what is the calculation that i
want it to provide all right so let's
again keep it at the level of um
let's select order date again all right
so again i wanted to perform at a
particular field
and
what is the level that i want to specify
so you're in this case since you're
mentioning the order date do i want it
at the deepest level all right the
granular level or do i want to specify
it at a particular yearly quarterly
monthly or daily level or the entire
aggregate of the order date so let's say
i'm going to specify at a yearly level
that i wanted to select all right and
let's click on ok
so it's now performed a secondary
calculation based on the previous one
and that's how we can make use this is
useful when we want to perform our
calculations to our data in the table
and instead of a single calculation
there might be times there are instances
where we might want to combine two
calculations so that's how you can make
use of the basic and the
uh calculations in terms of having a
secondary one as well so let's say uh
you want to calculate the year-to-date
growth all right and once you have the
year-to-date growth then based on that
you might want to then compute that once
i have that calculation i should get the
percent difference for each total in the
previous year so then that's how you can
apply and make use of your secondary
calculations all right
now you can also customize these
calculations all right so we have the
option as i mentioned you can go to the
edit selection and that's where you can
edit your tables and have the editing
provided
and we have a scenario here now a
company and they want to increase their
market share right and
uh in this case they want to uh ensure
that they're of having higher profit
margins all right so
what uh
what jennifer needs to do is she needs
to ensure her company's sustainability
and again she needs to identify the
opportunity for business and how she can
make the most of it right so for this
she needs to determine these sales brian
for your over your growth based on a
quarterly breakdown so let us achieve
this particular scenario now to achieve
these as jennifer what is jennifer going
to require to do all right so let's
first quickly on our notepad add in our
requirements so for us to achieve this
particular scenario for jennifer here
what we're going to be doing is firstly
we will create now since we are going to
talk about uh year over year we are
talking about time based analysis we
will create a line chart right so we
will have a line chart in terms of our
sales based on orders
at our yearly level
next thing to further proceed with the
scenario now we need it at a quarterly
breakdown so we're going to drill
and we're going to drill at a quarterly
level
finally then we are going to create a
table calculation because we want to
know the sales variants for your over
your growth all right so hence we will
create
a table calculation
and
this is going to be in case of
difference because we want to know the
the difference the variance for your
over your growth for our sales
all right so let's achieve this
particular scenario going to the
environment and
let's begin with our analysis here all
right
let me have my order date as mentioned
at a yearly level let's have our sales
all right and that is
or we that creates our line chart we are
done next we need to drill at a
quarterly level all right so let's drill
our data and have a quarter day level
right and finally then
let us now have now we need to perform
we can see the phase and now we need to
know the variance the difference all
right we want to know uh we want to
create a table calculation with
difference so i'm going to add in
another instance of sales here to our
rows on which we perform our
calculations all right
and
and now i'm going to make use of the
quick table calculation because we want
to know the variance the difference for
your over yours right so in this case uh
i've dragged my second pill and let's
have it at
our
uh the different level here all right so
we can see the difference now that is
one way but if you notice it's still a
little difficult in case of
judging the entire view here all right
so what i'm going to do is uh to make
our view better let's have our sales
fill all right from the drawer shelf
let's add it up to the color shell so
what it's going to do is on the existing
sales view it's going to identify and
distinguish between the colors for the
difference that we have and that's how
we'll be able to identify the difference
so let me just drag and drop it and we
can now see our view where we can
identify our sales and the difference
which is based on its color the red the
darker the side the difference of sales
is our analysis here says that it's in
minus all right and in terms of a
greener the difference is on a higher
side with green right so that's how when
you hover as well then at a quarterly
level you can see that for 2007
we have a particular sales and its
difference that we can see
right
in terms of the previous table
so that's how you can make use of your
calculations and achieve our scenario so
let's name this as sales analysis
all right
right so that's how we are able to
achieve and have
the sales variance of year over year
that we can notice the growth and based
on that we saw the quarterly breakdown
as well where she can now identify the
growth opportunities for business right
so that's how we can make use of table
calculations
i'm going to move ahead with
understanding what are box plots
all right so
in terms of block plots now these are
used when we want to compare a set of
data all right and when we want to
ideally analyze a distribution of data
which is highlighted up to five key
values all right within our data so
that's a box plot what it usually it's
also known as a box and whisker plot all
right and it helps us in seeing the
distribution of the values along the
axis all right so the boxes here that
you can see
these indicate the
middle 50 percent of our data all right
and uh
then we can also configure you can see
these this curves or lines as you can
see these these call these lines
and these display all the points within
a
1.5 percent of the range so let me show
that to you on each of these in
the slides here so there are five key
values that is represented in the box
plot the first it shows us the minimum
value all right
second it shows us the 25
quartile all right
then it shows us the median
the 75
quartile
as the maximum value all right so that's
how it highlights up to five key values
within the data all right
so we have the shaded box all right in
the example that uh
denote these five values let me go back
on the previous slide here
so the boxes here is what is
representing over here you can see these
are representing the fifty percent of
our data all right so these shaded boxes
the the light and dark gray here these
are called quartiles all right so namely
we have the upper quartile and lower
quartile so the lower quartile this
starts at 25 of the data set and the
upper quartile it starts at 75 percent
of our data set all right so these two
boxes these contain the middle 50 of our
data all right and the lines here these
are called your whiskers this can be
configured to stretch to your uh maximum
extent of data
or within a 1.5 times of the inter
quartile range that is
all the points within a
1.5 percent is what you can make use of
all right so this is where or we
understood so we have the minimum values
all right we have the 25 percent
that is 25 of the data set the median
the 75
quartile of our data set
and then the maximum value so let's see
how we can create a box plot i'm
switching to the tableau environment
here adding in a new sheet
and
so let me have my
segments added in to the columns
let me have my profits added up to
the rules
and
let me have my
order date
into the details section
right
let me ensure that
this is a discrete
date value
now let me if i click on the axis here
and say let me add a reference line
and this is where when i right click on
my axis i have the options now we will
be discussing all these uh lines in
terms of the topic statistics when we
try and understand reference lines bands
and distribution but to create a box
plot we can click right click on the
axis
and uh go on to the reference line and
choose the box plot option now this is
where you can specify the whisker
extending to your within the data within
the 1.5 percent or the maximum extent of
the data right the minimum and maximum
that we were talking about the style of
how you want it to look like these fill
colored let's uh pick up a red color all
right the borders and how you want your
whispers the thickness the lines that
you want it to be
and click on okay so with that it's
created a desktop box plot here for us
it's providing us with the whispers and
the lines
in terms of the segments here
all right
let's say you can also do this in terms
of having your particular analysis
uh creating these box plots by adding
some more additional data and detailing
as well all right let me show you uh one
more example of a box plot all right
this is a very simple one so it's pretty
much where we're only trying to analyze
based on the uh segments here in the
profits where it's created a box plot
and giving us uh each of these segments
and the profits for its particular year
now let me show you one more example of
a box plot to understand the five values
that it picks up all right so let's have
our
segment added up to the columns
and let's have let's use discounts this
time so what we're going to do is i'm
going to create a box plot view that's
going to show us the discounts based on
our segments and regions all right so
let's add in the discount onto the rules
all right
let me have my
region as well
so
let's have region
and let me have this added up to the
columns
right here next to the segment so it
created a nested level again based on
every segment for its own region what is
the discount here all right so we have
two levels of hierarchies of our
dimension right from our left to right
within every region that you can see
you're listed
now let me go to the show me option and
let's change this now another way of
changing that was we can also go to the
show me option and click on the box and
discover plot or view here all right so
one way was i right click and i selected
the reference lines and i selected the
box plot option or another way of doing
it is click on the xiaomi option and
click on the biscor and box plot or
chart that you have here
right so you're now this has given us
the entire view displaying a box plot
where we can see uh all the marks here
in each box that has been plotted up so
it's assigned the regions here as you
can see in terms we can see the region
and uh in the columns from
the mark shell right remember that there
was these regions which is placed in the
column as soon as we selected on box
plot it automatically assigned region on
the columns shelf here in the market
card it reassigned it let me just undo
this option so this is how we had a
nested bar graph created when i go to
the show me option and click on box plot
notice that region from the columns will
get added up to the mark section here
all right
there you go you can see that it got
added up here so basically when we
change it from a bar or from any chart
type to a box plot and tableau is
determining uh the individual marks in
the plot that it should represent so
it's determining that the marks here
that we have should be represented based
on region all right so well uh you can
change that as well so let's have our
region dragged back onto our columns all
right so we want it at a regional level
here and uh based on uh for every
segments in every region now we can see
a horizontal line that is created a
flattened box plot here in this case all
right which is or the reason leak that
it's right now giving us a value based
on a single mark all right
now box plot as the description as the
definition says it is intended to show
us the distribution of our data right
now what's happening here is it is
aggregating the entire data in the
currently and we can see a flattened
view of flattened look of our data here
so we want to disaggregate our measures
in that matter we'd want we want to uh
we want to have our aggregation
level changed and disaggregate our data
where it can give us an entire
distribution of our data so you're in
the analysis menu click on the analysis
menu you can see aggregated measures
that's been enabled i'm going to uncheck
this option and by this i'm going to
turn off the aggregation all right so
i'm going to disaggregate the measure
here so that we can now see that the
data which has
uh is at a disaggregated level wherein
we can now understand each of these uh
marks instead of a single mark we are
able to view each of the marks for every
column in a range of the data source
that we have all right now to uh see and
view and understand some additional
information here to make this more
readable make this more appealing what
i'm going to do is i'm going to swap our
axis here and i'm going to make this
into a horizontal view all right so that
it's going to be easier see it's going
to be easier for us to compare every
segment the region for every segment uh
what are
the discounts that have been offered all
right
now let me let's add some additional
analysis to this as well so at the
bottom axis we have the discount here
i'm going to simply go on to the edit
access that we have we have the option
to edit the reference lines you can see
the reference lines and automatically
there's a box plot that has been
selected so we can edit these reference
lines and change the entire uh banding
and the colors as or you remember so
let's select something more interesting
from a library let's select a red one or
you can also select on the transparency
level so let's add up the transparency
level to let's say 80. all right
let's stick to the borders as it is and
the viscose as
the default and click on ok all right
now with that we can see that
the discount is pretty much the same all
right the discount is pretty much the
same with uh for all the segments here
if you notice in terms of whenever we're
seeing all the best all right the
discounts are pretty much the same for
all the segments
right
so that is one analysis that we can see
also we can see that the interquartile
range that is the 25
to the 75 of the discount we have the
central region and that is showing us
the highest range all right so uh this
is how they're able to identify and uh
see the highest ranges here so each of
it is representing the entire detailing
that you can see here so the boxes here
all right these boxes are representing
the 50
of our data then again these are divided
as the
2.25 quartile and 75 percent quartile
and then we have the visco values which
are configured based on the maximum and
minimum the reference lines that we have
the maximum
are the maximum and the minimum or
values in terms of the interquartile
range
all right so that is your box plot
so the box here the one in the center
these are indicating the 50 of the data
and again you can see two quartiles two
distributions of the data
all right and then the whiskers
which is showing us the quartiles in
terms of the minimum maximum of 1.5
so let me take you back to the
presentation slide
so we have the maximum value
we have
the 75 percent quartile that we saw
the median the 25
and the minimum value
so that was an example of
box plots
now formatting as we already know as we
are there is a very important part of
both our analysis as well as our
presentation all right everything that
you see that you view in your sheet you
want to ensure that there is a proper
formatting applied that are shading
spawns lines and borders all of this
makes a lot of difference when it comes
to how you want to present and view your
data all right so it is pretty important
and hence in this particular chapter
we're going to be discussing on
different formatting options that are
available how we can format our
visualizations how we can make use of
the colors the
worksheet themes in terms of resizing in
terms of working with labels the mark
types all right and we're also going to
discuss on annotations on how we can
make use of annotations and annotate a
particular value all right
so let us explore what i'm going to do
is in this particular topic as i have
already mentioned we will describe and
understand what is spatial analysis
someone had also raised a concern on day
one as to what facial analysis was so
i'm going to discuss that topic right
away and that's going to resolve and
fall out on your question then we are
also going to understand how we can make
use of titles captions and tooltips and
how we can format access as well as how
we can format our views and results as
well as use mark labels and annotations
all right so let me directly move on uh
before i
proceed here
uh let me now move to the tableau
environment here and click on a new
sheet now talking about spatial analysis
facial analysis is what is related to
your geographic data all right so
tableau works now how it works with
fields in a special manner tableau also
works with the geographic fields in a
special manner it gives spatial data
some special importance it automatically
assigns geographic roles to any data
that you have in your data source so if
you notice i had discussed this
yesterday right in your data source it
can identify if there is any kind of
data related to geography it
automatically assigns it with a
geographic goal all right so that is the
specialty of tableau in case it is not
able to identify in terms of the uh
analysis whether it is a geographic role
or not then you also still have the
option wherein you can click on the data
source and describe the kind of
geographic role that you want to assign
all right you can customize the role as
well whether this particular country and
option is or area forward as a city is
the county is the state province all
right so you have the options or you can
keep it a default and the data type as
well so you can customize on the spatial
data and something very interesting
about tableau for that matter with the
related to spatial data geographic data
is let me take you onto the sheet and
regarding mappings all right we're going
to have a detailed discussion on
uh maps and how we can create maps but
uh let me since we're talking about
facial analysis and since i mentioned it
automatically identifies geographic data
let me show you how it treats the
geographic data so you're in you can see
we have the country all right and we can
see it has already identified it as a
geographic data provided a globe sign
when i double click on country
all right
what tableau does it it automatically as
you saw adds in the longitude and the
latitude for the country it
automatically generates the latitude and
longitude all right and that's how you
can see the map now these are different
layers and wms maps that you can make
use of so
we are going to discuss this pretty much
in detail when we come on to the maps
chapter
but as you saw the moment i double
clicked on country it automatically
added in the longitude and the latitude
into the columns and roads so that's how
tableau treats uh spatial data that's
how it works with geographic data
all right
so coming on to discussing with the
formatting
i'm gonna take a new sheet here now
formatting as i mentioned there are
various ways various kinds of formatting
that you can perform all right so uh
let's let's talk on the most uh common
ones in terms of how you can open the
formatting pane in the very first place
uh the formatting option that you have
all right so for that let me quickly
create one view for you all let's have
category
and let's have sale
right and now you can see that you have
the
format menu wherein when you click on
the format menu it gives you all the
options whether you want to format the
fonts you want to format the alignments
the shadings the borders the lines you
want to format a reference line if it's
in your view drop lines annotations
titles and captions scale labels so
these are all the options in terms of
how you want to format so this is the
entire uh window these are the entire
options that i'm going to be discussing
about so in terms of how to enable the
format in the very first place is that
the moment you click on uh format your
all right and you select a particular
option
let's say i'm gonna say i want to format
the font in the view all right
because of that notice what happened did
you see attention the data pane here got
replaced with the format pane
so that's how it opens up the format
page and then you can see all these same
options in the drop down here that you
could see in terms of fonts alignment
shading borders and lines you can format
your fonts your alignment shadings your
borders and lines so in your view you
can select whether you want to format
the font whether you want to format the
lines you want to provide a shading you
want to provide a border or you want to
provide any line formatting and again in
that there are three tabs for every
option that you will choose all right so
this means tableau allows you
to either format your particular font or
shading or bordering or coloring for the
entire sheet
or you can also do it for a particular
row or a column
all right so it gives you that option or
you can select a particular field as
well whether you want to format a
particular field
now in terms of the font here you can
see you can choose whether on the
worksheet what is the font you want the
pane the header the totals how you want
your totals to resemble the grand totals
now these are visible and worked when
you have text tables
and highlight tables or a grid kind of a
view
similarly you can format your rows so
that grays out the worksheet option and
allows you options in terms of
formatting your roles and the same
option for columns
for your fonts all right so let's say
i'm going to have my
worksheet where i'm going to have my
header
increase to the size of 16
and let's have
a greenish shade added to it we need a
little more darker color to it there we
go so we formatted the headers and the
values in our view all right
so that's how you can format the font
then comes in
the
alignment in terms of how you want again
based on sheet rows and columns all
right whether you want to align the pane
as horizontal all right whether you want
to align it as left right or central
aligned all right in terms of the
direction of your text so in case let's
say you have a lot of data you can
change the direction of your text
uh whether you want it vertical or
whether you want to wrap up your text
all right so those are to do with the
alignments that you have
and that's how you can align the row
with the column or the entire sheet so
in terms of horizontal you can control
whether the text aligns to the left
right or the center
all right in terms of the vertical
option you will control whether your
text aligns on top all right in the
middle or at the bottom
so top middle or bottom in terms of the
text alignment
then coming on to direction how you want
the direction of your text whether you
want it to run automatic uh so it will
take in based on the kind of data is
there on your view or you want to keep
it to normal up or down all right that
is top to bottom or bottom to down
and then based on the wrap
whether you want to use when you have
long headers then whether you want to
have a
text wrap uh that needs to be taken
place or take care of so whether it's
offer on you can select on the options
and
each of these effects and options will
take place on your sheet depending on
the kind of view and
visualization all right
so
that was to do with your uh alignment
coming on to formatting the shading this
is to do with you can format using the
shading command
you can control the background color of
your pane and header all right so again
you can decide whether you want to apply
it on the entire sheet
the rows or the columns so you can let's
say in the sheet select that in terms of
the background i need it to be a little
lightish in terms of a lightest pink so
it's put in the shading so that's how
based on the worksheet the total row
banding all right uh so you can actually
have a banding in terms of when you have
a text kind of a table
uh you can then perform a row banding so
let's say let's choose the text table
you can see that
you can take off the shading keep it to
none and then you can provide the kind
of banding size that you want this is
the size of two you can change it using
the slider so now it's banding based on
every three values let's add
subcategories so that it makes your view
a little more easier to understand
so let us just use the
hierarchy drill down
go back to formatting
and
now this is happening after every
thought value in terms of the band size
the levels as well we can decide on the
levels and in terms of the column
banding as well how do we want it all
right so we can change the levels of the
banding
then you have
the in terms of formatting in terms of
border so you can format the borders
in your view wherein you can decide on
uh formatting the cell
the pain the header the totals you want
to divide the particular row or divide
the particular column all right so you
can make use of these as well in
wanting to have a clear or better view
all right
as you can see we've divided it you want
a thicker line
all right in terms of column dividers as
well
how do you want it
the view that you want to select
all right
so that's how you can format
your borders as well
and finally comes in the option in terms
of
your lines how do you want your line for
math setting all right you can control
the lines that appear in a graph now in
that case you will have to change the
view to
a different kind of graph and then
that's where you can decide using every
toolbar whether you want to see grid
lines
right
you want to see the dotted lines is
there a particular color that we want to
add in
right
or thickness
needed not needed trend lines now when
you enable so when we come on to trend
line topics is where we'll discuss but
once you've added a trend line to your
view as well you can format how you want
your trend line the color that you want
to choose if you've added in a reference
line or drop price you can make these
options available in terms of formatting
in terms of the access ruler as well how
do you want it to be you want it
as none
or you want to provide a particular
dotted line to it
all right so that's how the view will
keep changing depending on
the kind of view that you have all right
so that's how you can format the lines
as well in your view
you can also format a particular part
all right now instead of just formatting
uh we saw we could format the entire
sheet or the row of columns in terms of
fonts in terms of alignments in terms of
shadings in terms of borders and lines
we can also format a particular field as
i mentioned you can format the fields in
terms of
how you want your fields to look like in
terms of let's say you can click here
and you have the option of format which
will directly open up the field as what
you want to do in terms of the header or
the pane all right we have the size
let's reduce it this time to 14
and or let us change the color of it
let's have a bluish color so we are
seeing the headers now are changing in
terms of the headers for our category
all right so that's how we can choose
the formatting options here whether we
want to do it for the pane or write the
font whether you want to change that and
change the color
so that's how you can perform it on a
particular field as well
all right
now in terms of
formatting
numbers we had a question whether can we
format and specify a particular option
in terms of numbers as well yes you can
so you can directly have uh
this option where you can right click
again and click on format which will
give you the options in how you want the
fonts again for this particular field
which is sales it's giving you that
you're formatting it for sales the scale
the number format where you want to use
it as automatic or standard number or
custom number a currency so there was a
question put up where
we were asked uh can we format the
currency so you have your answer uh your
questions been answered right here in
terms of formatting all right so uh
there we go we can also format in terms
of the numbering options as to
how we want to format it based on
the options here for number formats i
will let you know each of these options
so automatic is our tableau will
automatically format the number based on
the
format specified in the data source or
the data contained in that particular
field all right in terms of number
standard it will take in the format
which is based on your locale that is
selected the kind of location that you
have selected are the geographic
location that you have it will format it
based on that standard setting
in terms of custom here you can
customize it as for your liking so let's
say instead of writing let me use a
notepad here to show you all so let's
say instead of writing 20 000 we want to
show it as 20k
uh you can use the custom formatting and
that's how instead of 20 000 you can use
and write it as 20k so you can use the
custom option in that or for that manual
in terms of numbers
coming onto currency again it will take
in the currency symbol based on the
location that you have selected the
geographic location
and in terms of custom then you can
provide a custom unit you can provide a
custom
currency option in case uh how do you
want these separators whether you want
to have
commerce between every thousands or
every hundred so that's how you can
again select it at a customized level
scientific is the numbers will be
displayed in a scientific notion that is
the decimal
uh where do you want to place your
decimal values all right percentage as
the name provides is going to show you
the numbers in a percentage format and
custom is where you want to provide and
type in a format
completely using a specified custom all
right so that's where you can completely
format and you can specify based on the
number coding or the styling that you
want
so moving further
so what is filter so your filter helps
you in narrowing down your data it can
be applied to a dimension that is your
contextual value to measures which is
your numerical value or to a date field
as well where you want to narrow it down
to a specific value or a range of values
all right in tableau so what are the
ways that you can uh possibly filter now
what are the different conditions that
you can possibly filter is one you can
select the data to filter in the view
all right you can add it up to the
filter shelf directly and choose whether
you want to include or exclude the
option the other way is you can have it
added up to the filter shelf as well or
you can turn on the quick filters which
opens up a new card where you can
quickly add in or alter your data in
terms of
filtering so let me uh take you to the
window therein and let's start exploring
these options of how we can use filters
and how we can manipulate our data in
terms of narrowing it down all right so
let us start beginning with the very
first one
and i'm moving on to the interface here
all right
now first i'm going to show you how we
can filter on the dimensions okay so let
me take in a new sheet all right and
let's say i'm going to have the customer
name filter so i'm going to use my
customer name dimension and add it up to
the photo shares here this opens up the
filter window all right and in this
particular window uh you have
four tabs as you can see one thing the
general one being wildcard one being
condition and top now let me first
explain each of these steps and then
we'll proceed further in understanding
how we can filter on the dimension here
all right
so in the general option you can select
the list that you want in terms of
filtering and whether you want to
include it or you want to exclude that
particular selection all right so in
clicking on exclude will exclude
whatever selections you've made
unchecking this option by default needs
whatever we've selected i need to only
include those customer names onto my
view all right the next is you can have
a custom value list or you can also have
a use all feature where i'm saying i
want to use all the options and i want
to include these so that is the first
general option the second option is in
terms of
having a wildcard so a while card is
where you can specify a particular match
value whether you want to that value
contains that particular alphabet or
starts with that alphabet ends with that
alphabet or exactly matches that
alphabet so let's say let's use the
wildcard option and say i want the names
starting with all right the alphabet let
me choose the alphabet
s
all right so i'm saying that all my
customer names should start with the
alphabet s so when i click on this and
then i use the customer names onto my
view i will only be viewing customers
with the name starting with s all right
so uh conditions is where you can apply
a condition based on a particular field
or by a formula and top is where we can
apply the field to be the top 10
customers based on a particular
dimension or a measure or by a
particular formula so we'll understand
these tabs with different options of
fizzing let's use the wildcard
all right now in terms of the white card
options we mentioned it starts with or
the letter s and i click on ok
all right now i'm going to add in the
customer name onto the rows so you can
see that we only will have the names
beginning with s it's filtered down
because we said that we need the name
starting with s and we have all the
customers or names starting with an s
here let's add sales to our columns and
we have
all the names of the customers beginning
with s that's how you can filter on a
particular dimension
all right
uh
all right uh slikhaar uh in terms of the
rc car has put up a question in terms of
can we explain the custom value list in
terms of the custom values regards what
happens is let me just open up the
filter here so that i can explain that
to you quickly when you talk of select
list you can select from the particular
option that you want all right and in
terms of a custom value now let's say
you want to randomly have uh different
names one beginning with a now this is a
huge long list all right so in terms of
a custom value i can simply enter the
names or keep adding in the names that i
already know so let's see if i take it
and al is there an allen in our name oh
let's say we already know there's a
sally in her name
so do we have a sally i'm gonna say add
the name sally up add the name
so i can use a custom list because i
already know the list instead of uh
avoiding the pain of scrolling through
this huge list i know my values i'm
going to simply add and enter the text
and keep adding it so that's a custom
value list
i'm going to cancel the option because i
want to right now uh
uh stick on to customers name beginning
with s all right so that was an example
where we can filter on a field all right
where i can filter on a
dimension field
in terms of case sensitive yes we have
to check on that because in most cases
tableau is usually very case sensitive
when it comes to name so let's say we
already know that
we have a sally in our list let us check
if i have sally added in as so then in
that case you can see it's giving me a
drop down option to select from in terms
of the case sensitivity and then all the
possible names that are available for
sally is giving me the options to choose
from
so that was uh filtering on a dimension
now let me show you how you can filter
on
the
measure all right so
before that let me show you one more
option and using the conditions tab okay
so from the wi-fi let me take a new
sheet this time and
uh let's have a condition specified or
in terms of the filter so this time
again let's have our customer names
added into the filter
in the condition now this is where you
can specify whether you want it by feed
or how do you want to select it whether
you want to use a particular
card whether you want to specify a
particular condition now before i move
in here to the conditions there is one
important thing that i need to perform
that's your not your there is no y card
that's been used all right but let's see
if it was the same filter on the
previous one then you will need to go
back to the wirecard option and clear
and uncheck the option because it will
not then be able to take in all these
tabs and detailing so here i'm creating
a new sheet hence no worry but if we do
it in the previous sheet it says where
we had the wildcard then it's going to
consider that it needs to be beginning
with it as well as these conditions but
only if you want the conditions to be
applied then you need to clear the wild
card all right
so
the wildcard yawn and let's say i want
to know the field and in terms of i want
to know the customer name
wherein my sales all right is
uh let's keep the aggregation now these
are the aggregations that you can choose
from let's keep it default at some and
my sales should be
greater
than
10 000 all right
let's click on ok now you can also
provide a minimum and a maximum range
value or you can then apply a particular
formula you can apply a condition click
on ok and now when we add in the
customer name now you can drag and drop
it in the fields as well specified here
and now we get to see only those
customers which are having the sales as
we specified which is about 10 000 let's
add sales and we'll be able to see let's
enable our data labels all the sale
values are about 10 000 for these
customers
all right
you can add in a condition
similarly we can also change these and
apply so now i'm going to this time go
to the conditions tab and i'm going to
click on the none option because we're
now going to have the top customers by
sale where we now want to filter our
data based on our top customers all
right so let's keep it to default you
have the option of you want to see the
top customers or the bottom customers
how many by numbers 10 or a particular
parameter
those parameters is where we will be
discussing when we proceed ahead and
discuss the parameters topic
uh so yes you will be able to filter on
the dimensions and measures as well so
you can have the top 10 uh customer
names based on my sales here all right
or let's say you can have it on the on
the basis of profit also you can change
it to profit this time we're using a lot
of sales and let me click on ok
all right so now what happened is notice
in our view we are able to see the
customer names the sales by each of
these customers that have been generated
for the top 10 customers giving us the
top 10 profit so although profit is not
in my view these are my top 10 customers
based on profit all right and what is
the sale generated by each of these top
10 customers and who these top 10
customers are all right so that's
another way that we could use it the top
tab option in the filter when we are
filtering on a particular dimension
all right now there's another way that
you can filter so you can click on a
particular option and keep only or
excluded so that is one way of filtering
right onto your data the other one as we
saw was filtering adding it up to the
filter shelf all right right in the drop
down it also shows quick filter so when
you click on the quick filter option
here it gives you a special mascot that
opens up where you can quickly keep
analyzing instead of going and editing
the option it gives you the general
option where you can keep analyzing a
particular customer name that you want
to see and these are limited by the top
ten all right
so that's your quick filter option you
can remove it you can apply to the sheet
you can even customize you can uh
display how you want it to be viewed in
terms of the filter option that is
displayed whether you want it as a
multiple list or slider or drop down
a multiple value drop down a custom list
or a wide card match all right and based
on that then you can
also mention whether you want to include
these values or exclude these values and
finally you can hide the cards as well
all right
so that was your
quick filter now you can also as i
mentioned filter on dimensions so let me
add in a new sheet here and show you how
you can filter on your measures now so
uh this time let's have our customer
names on two rows
all right let's have sales onto
uh the filter shells this time so we're
going to be filtering now this time if
you notice the filter shell because it's
a measure it opens up as to how you want
to filter what is the aggregation that
you want to use whether you want to use
all the values whether you want to use a
particular aggregation or some
additional uh analysis in terms of
deviation or variance all right i'm
going to stick to the sum the basic one
and click on next this opens up the
option now whether you want to filter
based on
the range of values all right whether
you want to filter based on
the
uh least values all right so these are
the different options let me explain
each of these options as well to yours
so in the range of values you can
specify
a particular range as minimum and
maximum that you want to
explore so you can use the uh slider
here as well and specify let's say we
want a value of approximately 5000 and
narrow down this particular data all
right from 5000 now you can see at times
when you just want to use an approximate
value then it's fair enough to use these
sliders or another way of doing it in a
simpler manner would be you can simply
type in the details all right so you
want it at ten thousand and five
thousand so you can also use the slider
or use the particular titan box where
you can type in the range of values
next you have at least now this includes
all the values which are greater than or
equal to the specified minimum value so
it needs to be greater than or equal to
5000 is what we're specifying so any
value that we add in our value should be
about 5000 that is at least and at most
is obviously then the opposite that we
are mentioning it should include all the
values that are less than or equal to
this maximum value that we specify so if
you're saying it should not be above
5000 we are only wanting to see the
sales of 5000 and below
so that's the minimum and maximum value
of at least and at most and in terms of
special this is to do with handling your
filter your null values in in your view
so this is a filter that helps you
narrow down on the null values whether
you want to include the null values
whether you want to have the non null
values or you want all the values added
up in your view all right so based on
that you can have your selections and
finally click on ok all right so
let me click on
range here in this case and you can
select on a range as i mentioned you can
click
and have the option of let's say 5000
on to 15 000
and click on ok so now you're going to
be able to see your sales which is going
to be in the range of 5000 under 15 000
ob
all right
similarly you can also filter on dates
now when it comes to date as well the
filter window opens up in a different
fashion so we saw in dimensions it opens
up in terms of four tabs in terms of the
measure it opens up the aggregation we
want to use and then the values that we
want to specify now when it comes to
filtering on dates then in this case
what happens is that tableau opens up a
different kind of window when you're
wanting to filter on dates so let's uh
have a look at that as well
so let me open up the filter dates
option for you all
so let's have the order date added in
onto my filter here so this opens up the
filter window wherein it is specifying
uh the page here or eight field in
tableau is created in a special nano a
special dimension and it uh often
handles it in a different way as you saw
even when it comes to hierarchies it
automatically creates a hierarchy for
you in terms of dates so even with
filters it handles it in a different
manner here it specifies one whether you
want to use the relative date filter or
the range of dates now when you use the
first option which is the relevant uh
relative dates filters then you're
you're going to be defining a range of
dates that is going to get updated based
on the date and time that you open the
view all right so it's more like
whatever view you select let's say you
want to see the year-to-date sales uh
for the records of the last 40 days all
right so in that case you can actually
specify selecting on the relative date
and uh that's where you can mention the
detailing of i want to see today's date
and the last 30 days of whatever is
today's date so that's hard to use in
the relative days the next option that
you have in terms of the range of dates
is where you can provide
these range of a particular date where
you can given uh the kind of date that
you want to choose all right so in terms
of range of dates you will be specifying
a particular range and once you've
decided and selected between these two
options then you need to select on
whether which kind of a filter that on
the trailing that you have whether you
want to do it on a year on the quarter
or on the month all right so that's how
you can specify that particular date and
uh let us uh
let me click on the relative days option
here and click on next
so when we open the relative date then
in this case you can see again it's
giving us special for tab job so the
relative date in this case is we can
specify uh let's see the sales in the
last couple of days so we can specify
whether we want to see the sales
yesterday and last how many number of
days today with the next how many days
or we want to see the days the sales for
tomorrow similarly then you have
range of dates where you can specify a
particular range all right whether let's
say you have the data you're coming in
from 1st of april or 2014 going up to
31st december you can make use of the
calendar and choose your specific date
range you can also use the slider you're
to specify
the starting date again it's more like
the minimum and maximum so starting is
all the days starting from this date and
above and ending is that we want to have
and see our data wherein the ending date
should be 31st of december and sales
achieved until this specific date
nothing beyond that particular in case
even if it's present any data present
about 2014 31st december we're still
limiting it that it should be until 31st
of december and then the special tag
which again gives us the flexibility in
terms of filtering whether there are
null dates non-nail dates or you want
all the dates to be included
all right
the option we have in terms of filtering
on our dates all right
so as you saw we can filter right in the
view where i mentioned you can have the
exclude or include option you can drag a
particular field right into the filter
shell you can also turn on the quick
filter and make use of it so that is the
filter shell we saw depending on the
size we can filter on a dimension or we
can filter on a measure or a date as
well
for complex analytical projects
organizing and simplifying data is one
of the crucial tasks
it is important to be able to simplify
data for proper analysis
organizing and simplifying data is a
critical part of tableau mission to
facilitate you to see and understand
data
tableau can help you with all stages of
an analytics project by using these
advanced capabilities
in this lesson we will discuss advanced
capabilities to complete sophisticated
analytics projects
after completing this lesson you will be
able to
perform filtering and sorting on data
create combined fields to merge data
from different dimensions
create groups and define aliases
create and work with sets and combined
sets
drill to other levels of data in your
hierarchies
add grand totals and subtotals in a view
change aggregation functions for a
measure
split a measure value into bins
the first topic that you will study in
this lesson is filtering data
jenny the sales manager of a chain of
departmental stores is planning to
launch a new branding policy for a line
of furniture that sells well
for this she needs to analyze the
subcategories under furniture with sales
over thirty thousand dollars in the year
two thousand thirteen
to discuss the matter she calls one of
the sales executive alex
hi alex we are in the process of
launching a new branding policy for a
line of furniture with good sale
but to decide on the categories i need
to analyze which furniture sales crossed
over thirty thousand dollars in two
thousand thirteen
can you recommend a way to complete this
task
sure jenny i think what you need is a
bar chart where you can filter the
results as per your analysis
that's right how can we do this in the
most efficient manner
we can use tableau application that
provides a number of features to create
bar charts and filter large amounts of
data as per your desired analysis
great you can start working on this task
and present the analysis to me when
you're done
so before we proceed further let's
discuss what is a filter
yes you guessed it filters let you
filter data a filter is a condition
which can be applied to dimensions
measures or date fields to narrow down
the data displayed in a view
in tableau they can be either static or
interactive
being able to filter data is essential
to any analysis with tableau data can be
filtered in different ways
you can apply filter using one of these
methods
select data to filter in the view
drag fields to the filters shelf
activate quick filters
when you select data to filter in the
view the filtered fields are added to
the filters shelf and the unwanted
fields are removed
when you drag fields to the filters
shelf a filter dialog box opens when you
activate quick filters the filter dialog
box opens as a new card where data can
be quickly added and altered
so how can the dimensions be filtered
dimensions can be filtered either on the
filter shelf or in the quick filter
when you drag the dimension to the
filter shelf a filter window will appear
these are the key tabs of the filter
window so how do these tabs function let
me explain each tab one by one
the first tab is the general tab which
helps you select the list of elements
you want to include in the filter
you can use one of the following options
to define the element list
select from list this option allows you
to select the elements you want to
include from the list
next is the custom value list in this
option you can use the search box to
directly locate the elements
and the last one is the use all option
that allows you to include all the
elements in the filter
now you understand how general tab
functions
yes i do
great let's move to the next tab the
wild card in the wildcard tab you can
match the names of elements by selecting
one of the following options
contains starts with ends with exactly
matches
next you have the condition tab with the
help of this tab you can specify a
filter condition
in this only the elements that satisfy
the condition will be included in the
view
to define a condition you can use the
none by field and by formula options
these tabs allow you to perform a lot of
functions what about the last tab
in the top tab you can specify a
condition to include the top n or bottom
n
elements to define a condition you can
use the none by field by formula options
thanks alex tableau really has some
amazing capabilities
let me now explain how you can apply
filter on measures before you begin with
that alex i have a quick question
does tableau allow me to filter on a
measure where an i can select to either
filter row level data or an aggregated
value of data
indeed it does
tableau allows you to filter at row
level data in which measure value is
calculated individually for every row in
the data set
no aggregation functions are used for
row level calculations
while in summary level calculation
measure value is calculated using an
aggregation function on the row level
data
aggregation functions are used for
summary level calculations
in tableau the data is automatically
aggregated by performing summation when
a measure is placed on a shelf when you
apply filter on a measure it allows you
to filter row level data select all
values
to filter summary level data select one
of the available aggregation functions
date filters are extremely common
date fields are a special kind of
dimension that tableau often handles
differently than standard categorical
data
so far we have learned how to perform
filtering and sorting on data
greg is planning to launch a new
branding policy for a line of furniture
that sells well
this demonstration will help you
understand how greg analyzes the
subcategories by creating bar charts and
applying appropriate filter to it
open tableau 9.0
from the home page connect to the saved
sample superstore data set
create a horizontal bar chart with
subcategory dimension and sales measure
drag the category dimension to the
filters shelf
filter only for the furniture category
drag the order date dimension to the
filters shelf
select filter field as years to filter
only for 2013
drag the sales measure to the filter's
shelf
filter for subcategories with sum of
sales greater than 30 thousand dollars
observe the change in bar chart after
applying filters
rename the sheet as filtering data
save the workbook as furniture
subcategories with sales more than
thirty thousand dollars in two thousand
thirteen
close the workbook
this completes the demonstration on
filtering data
the quick filter can get started for
existing filters as well as for
non-filtered fields
the filter dialog box includes these
filter modes
single values list
single value drop down single values
slider
multiple values list multiple values
drop down multiple values slider
wildcard match
the data can be selected from the given
list as well as can be searched using
the search icon present in the title
area of the quick filter
with the quick filter option you can
quickly add and modify filters
you just need to follow three simple
steps firstly activate a quick filter on
the region dimension
notice a smaller representation of the
filter dialog box opens as a new card
quickly select what to include in the
view
and you are done
now let us move to the second topic
sorting of data
sorting data is an integral part of data
analysis
sorted data is easier to analyze
sorting a data view refers to arranging
dimension members in a specified order
you might want to put a list of names in
alphabetical order compile a list from
highest to lowest or order rows by
colors or icons
sorting data helps you quickly visualize
and understand your data better organize
and find the data that you want and
ultimately enables you to make more
effective decisions
in tableau you can sort data in numerous
ways
sorting can be performed on axis
specific fields and manually
tableau supports computed sorting and
manual sorting
computed sorting uses programmatic rules
to sort the view such as sorting
alphabetically or from lowest to highest
manual sorting enables you to reorganize
the order of dimension in the table and
can only be implemented on distinct
fields with a distinct measure now that
you know that the data can be sorted in
different ways let's discuss each of
these in detail
sure i would like to know more about it
to sort on axis you can single click the
sort icon on the measure axis to sort
the bars in descending order or
double-click the sort icon on the
measure axis to sort the bars in
ascending order
the data can be automatically sorted
using the sort button on the axis to
give a better view of data
to sort on a specific field use the sort
menu option to sort by one or more
fields in a specified order then
select the data source order option to
sort data in the order of the data
source
the sort dialog box includes these
criteria
sort order displays the output in
ascending or descending order
sort by
sort either by data source order
alphabetic or by fields
to perform a manual sort use the sort
menu option to sort manually
then rearrange the order of dimension
members in a custom order based on your
business specifications
manual sort can be done in two ways
use sort toolbar button on the selected
item
locate and drag headers in the view
let us now move to the next topic
creating combined fields
combined fields are used to create a
cross product of members from different
dimensions
two or more dimensions can be combined
to create a cartesian product of
dimension members
the view includes all combinations of
each member of the dimensions
let's look at an example
a combined field has been created using
segment and region
when added to the view it displays all
combinations of segment and region
elements
creating groups and defining aliases are
some more features that tableau offers
let's understand each of these concepts
let's say you want to view data at
levels that are not already present in
the data source
in such situations groups are used to
combine dimension members to create a
higher level member
when a group is created a default name
is automatically formed using the
combined member's name
the new grouped field takes over the
dimension on rows or columns
for example a group can be created by
combining the sales for envelopes labels
and paper for analysis
now the question arises that can
alternate names be provided in this case
and the answer is yes you can
aliases will provide the flexibility for
renaming dimension members to help make
more sense in the current view
the good part is tableau does not change
the original data on changing an alias
in your view
you can change aliases at any time using
the edit aliases dialog box
there are some things you need to keep
in mind such as aliases can only be
defined for discrete dimensions and
dates these can be applied to dimensions
only and not to measures moreover the
method for creating aliases depends on
the type of data source you use
following is an illustration of defining
an alias for the east element of the
reason dimension
let us now move to the next topic
working with sets and combined sets
usually you have large sets of data that
you want to visualize in such a
condition you might find that limiting
the amount of information displayed to
an important subset of records helps you
work with and answer questions about the
data more effectively
sets are custom fields that define a
subset of dimension members
a set can be created for specific
dimension members in the view or it can
be based on a condition
computed sets are dynamic as the number
of members in the set can vary at
runtime based on the condition
furthermore you can also drag a set to
the filter shelf to quickly filter the
view to display only the members of the
sets
likewise you can also create a set by
combining existing sets all you need is
to specify the logical operator between
the two sets new sets can be formed by
combining the sets consisting of either
all the members from the sets only
shared members
members existing in one of the sets
the dimensions of the sets should be the
same in order to combine two sets
by now you have a brief idea on how to
create groups define aliases and create
sets and combined sets
greg is planning to launch an
advertising scheme for certain product
sub-categories that are related to each
other
this demonstration shows how greg
creates a visualization that displays
the aggregated profit ratio and
highlights the bottom five subcategories
by sales
this demo will give you an overview on
how to
create a group to combine dimension
members
create a computed set to include
dimension members automatically
open tableau 9.0
from the home page connect to the saved
sample superstore dataset
create a horizontal bar chart with
subcategory dimension and profit ratio
measure
tables and chairs to create a group
create a set on subcategory
name the set as bottom five
subcategories by sales
click the top tab
under buy field select bottom five
sub-categories by sales from the
drop-down
drag the bottom five subcategories by
sales set to the color shelf to the
marks card
rename the sheet as groups and sets
save the workbook as working with groups
and sets
close the workbook
this completes the demonstration on
working with groups and sets
now let us study how can we drill to
other levels in a hierarchy
jenny is required to present the
company's sales performance across
different regions states and cities in
an upcoming meeting she calls alex to
help her make this report in a quick and
efficient manner
hi alex i need you to create a report
for me to present the company's sales
performance across different regions
states and cities
sure jenny are there any specific points
that you want me to keep in mind yes i
want to use the same data source for the
detail and summary information
in other words i want to create a report
where all the data is contained within
the same report
can you suggest a way to do that
sure jenny for creating such reports
tableau offers the feature of hierarchy
where you can drill down to several
lower layers of detail
great please start working on this
report and share the final output with
me
i was just wondering can we drill to
other levels in a hierarchy yes we can
a hierarchy is a grouping of related
dimensions depicting direct parent-child
relationships between them
built-in hierarchies are not present in
relational databases but it can be
inherited from the relational databases
that have similar dimensions
it is useful in the following ways
it facilitates analyzing a high level
overview of your data and then drilling
down to lower levels of detail
what's amazing in that tableau separates
the data fields automatically into
hierarchies so you can easily break down
the view by year quarter month etc
moreover it also enables you to create
your own custom hierarchies
if you want to view your data at a lower
or higher level in the hierarchy then
drilling is what you're looking for for
instance you can drill up from date
through year or you can drill down from
year to date
that way drilling is one of the most
suitable ways to navigate hierarchies
various methods of drilling are
available in tableau it allows you to
drill using fields on shelves or drill
using headers let me show you how
drilling using headers can be referred
to as uneven drill as only desired
members are displayed rather than all
the members from the list
you can click a header value in the view
and select drill down or drill up from
the menu
let's say it is drilled down from year
level to quarter level you can expand or
collapse a dimension in the rows or
columns shelf to drill down or up
respectively
the plus and minus signs on the fields
that are placed on the shelves shows the
drill status
so that means the plus sign indicates
that it can be drilled down further
while the minus sign indicates that you
can drill up but cannot drill down
further
greg is required to present the
company's sales performance across
different regions states and cities he
is required to create a report such that
all the data is contained within the
same report
let's see how he does that
open tableau 9.0
from the home page connect to the saved
sample superstore dataset
create a hierarchy by dragging state
onto region
name the hierarchy as geography
in the geography hierarchy drag city
below state
create a report with region and sales
right-click west select keep only
drill down from region to state
right-click california select keep only
drill down from state to city
rename the sheet as sales analysis
save the workbook as company sales
performance
close the workbook
this completes the demonstration on
drill down report
now let us discuss another important
feature of tableau grand totals and
subtotals
totals facilitate the aggregation of
data in a view
you can compute grand totals and
subtotals for the data in a view
these totals can be applied only on grid
type visualizations
tableau does not compute subtotals and
grant totals as just an aggregation
instead subtotals and grand totals are
computed as a separate calculation of
the measure at a coarser level of
granularity totals facilitate the
aggregation of data in a view
you can compute grand totals and
subtotals for the data in a view
these totals can be applied only on grid
type visualizations
tableau does not compute subtotals and
grant totals as just an aggregation
instead subtotals and grand totals are
computed as a separate calculation of
the measure at a coarser level of
granularity
tableau computes subtotals and grand
totals as the original measure at a
higher level of aggregation
let us proceed with understanding how to
define aggregations other than the
predefined choices
tableau allows you to define
aggregations other than the predefined
choices such as summation and variance
you can change the aggregation function
by right-clicking a dimension in either
the rows or columns shelf or by
right-clicking a field in the data pane
here we have changed the aggregation
function to average
next we are going to study about tableau
bins which are useful to create a range
of data
bins are custom bandings of the values
of a measure based on a specific size
you can bin data only for relational
data sources it does not support this
feature for multi-dimensional data
sources
bins can be referred to as buckets of
values and can be created for numeric
dimensions there are two types that you
can create
fixed sized and variable sized
you can create a fixed sized bin by
specifying the size of each bin in the
create bins window
keep in mind that by default tableau
creates even sized bins based on the
size you specify
as you can see i have created fixed
sized bins on the discount measure of
size 10 each
to create a variable size bin create a
calculated field with an appropriate
script
you will learn about calculated fields
in detail in lesson 8
calculations for now just remember that
you need to create a calculated field to
create bins of variable size
look we have three bins on the discount
measure of variable sizes
now that you've gone through the need
and importance of organizing and
simplifying data let us have a quick
look at the key takeaways
filters enable you to narrow down the
data displayed in a view
sorting refers to the arrangement of
dimension members in a specified order
combined fields are used to create a
cross product of members from different
dimensions
a group is a combination of dimension
members that make up a higher level
category
aliases are alternate names for specific
values within a dimension
sets are custom fields that define a
subset of data based on some conditions
drilling helps you analyze the data in a
view at a lower or higher level in the
hierarchy
bins are custom bandings of measure
values they can be created either as
fixed sized or variable sized
time for some hands-on practice
let's now understand the below scenario
and work on it together
you are an owner of a store and want to
analyze the existing discount strategy
offered by your store
you wish to view the number of customers
who have been offered discounts between
zero percent and 10
10 and 20 percent and so on
create a histogram with discount bins
and count of discounts and answer the
following questions
how many customers were given discounts
between zero percent and ten percent
what is the total sale recorded when
customers were offered a discount
between twenty percent and thirty
percent
now wasn't that a great experience you
will be happy to know that we have two
more similar scenarios for you to
strengthen your understanding of
organizing and simplifying data
read the scenarios carefully and perform
the task on the tabo 9 tool downloaded
onto your device
you can evaluate your steps by referring
to the solution guide provided in the
download center
scenario one
you work in an e-commerce company's
division that deals with the dispatch
and delivery of shipments is facing
losses
you are required to identify the
customers who mostly tend to return
their orders
you need to focus on the list of
customers who have returned their orders
more than half the time
using the sample superstore excel sheet
you have to create an appropriate
visualization and answer the following
questions
how many customers do you have on your
list
what is the distinct order count for
customer hillary holden
which customer has the highest count of
order returns
scenario 2
you are a store manager of a leading
retail chain in the united states that
wants to launch a discount campaign to
promote the sales of related products
as a part of this campaign you need to
analyze the aggregated sales for
envelopes labels and papers
you are required to see the combined
sales of these products on a graph
create a bar chart showing the
accumulated sales for paper products and
answer the following questions
what is a total sale of paper products
what is the profit ratio for paper
products
this concludes the lesson organizing and
simplifying data let's begin
with our topic on mapping right now in
terms of maps we've already seen a lot
of examples we've already understood uh
how we can build on a basic map view in
tableau all right that tableau assigns
geographic roles uh in terms of fields
in the data we can customize the
appearance we can navigate and find
locations but let's go further ahead and
understand certain analysis on how we
can use math layers how we can make use
of wms such as map web map services so
if you remember earlier as well we
discussed on our web map services uh
that uh tableau provides so let's
understand uh so that at the end of this
particular topic we will be able to
understand how we can modify locations
within tableau
all right how we can import and modify
custom geocoding we can make use of
background images as well as maps uh how
we can describe the geocode locations
within tableau how we can explore the
geographic search and how we can perform
the pan room as well as the last one
labels radio selection all right so
let's understand now how we can use the
advanced mapping functions and how we
can analyze we already are aware of
building these basic uh maps so let's
understand further in terms of how we
can create these geographic roles how we
can modify them how we can modify
locations in tableau right now when we
add in when we uh uh
take in a particular location all right
there can be instances that tableau will
not be able to identify uh in our data
the location all right so in that case
it provides us and uh gives us a detail
of an unrecognized field okay so that's
when we can then manually set it in the
location where you can edit the location
all right and that's how you can provide
and specify that
uh since it's spelled wrong in our data
we can then specify you can see in this
example it's arizona while actually the
name of the location is arizona and
that's how we can then from the drop
down specify and
click on the unknown location name and
provide its editing all right so in in
terms of such cases all right uh what
tableau does is you can simply in the
map view as well you have the option
since it does not recognize an uh
unknown field then you can simply click
on uh the uh there is a special
indicator all right so back in our
environment
uh if you if you remember i mentioned
there are indicators that tableau
provides here at the corner here if
there is something incorrect about our
data all right and then in that case we
can uh based on that when you click on
that special value dialog box that will
open up uh it will open up the edit
location tab and that's how you can then
specify and mention about the location
all right so it will give you a unknown
error it will give you a special value
as unknown and that's how you can click
on those values and specify its location
so let's uh consider a scenario now we
have sales profit and quantity which is
an important aspect pretty much obvious
in terms of considering the measures of
the company's performance all right now
there are major fluctuations and uh
because of this they are it's hampering
the enterprise growth right so the ceo
of the american multinational retail
corporation he wants to analyze his
sales profit and quantity whether he
wants to improve the advertising
campaign in those places that are no
performing state all right now for this
he's going to require pretty obvious or
mac visualization that can display the
sales profit and the quantitative values
as well all right so let's begin and see
how we can make use of the analysis now
this is going to be a pretty interesting
feature that we're going to see so
let's begin let me take you to the
environment and see how we'll be able to
achieve this particular visualization
let me open up a new sheet here
and let's create a simple map so what
i'm going to do is we need it at a state
level directly double click now we're
already aware when you double click on a
geographic dimension or geographic rule
it'll automatically identify the and
generate the longitude and the latitude
for us and that's why it shows as
generated values here all right and
right now if you notice you can see a
different map view than that of or the
one which is specified by tableau the
default one that's because i've changed
it to a different map type so right here
in the map menu that you can see here in
tableau you have the option of uh
uh you can see the option wherein you
can go to the uh background maps all
right and this is where you have the
option of tableau or you want to set it
as the current one as a default all
right so you can change and have these
locations now right now uh making use of
a particular map layer and hence you're
not able to see this so any of you who
are trying to perform and get this kind
of a view that's only going to be
possible because i've used a map layer
which is inbuilt by tableau alright so
let me for now uh go to the map option
all right and
i'm going to keep this as no data layer
and this is the kind of view you should
have right i will discuss this shortly
give me some time and first let's
understand the basics and then i'm going
to come on to this layering now right
now we're just achieving uh the
the scenario that we just read in our
presentation slide deck all right now uh
since we've created the view next that
we're going to do is we're going to have
our sales and i'm going to drag in my
sales to the color shelf all right
and
my
uh so now it's changed my view from
symbols into an automatic view which is
the field map so again in this you have
options of a symbol map and a field map
so we were already aware of these
options the moment i added up sales to
the color section it's now you're using
a filled map option where i can define
the darker the color the higher the
sales the lighter the color the lower
the sales all right so i've dragged in
my sales to color let me add my profits
to the size
right so now if you notice this again
change back to symbol so the color is
determining the sales the size is
determining the profits all right let's
enable the data labels here for us it's
enabling us the labels for sales
and that's how we can see the size and
based on this he can identify all right
which map or which which state is having
the highest sales in profits all right
so the darker the color the bigger the
size so that means we can analyze that
we have california and we have new york
that are performing better in terms of
sales all right so that's how we can
achieve a statewide
sales
and profit view
so going back to our presentation that's
how we'll be able to achieve the sales
profit and the values in terms of a map
all right now let us proceed further in
understanding the other additional
topics as well so we saw that we could
also modify and create a map
in terms of importing as well now we can
also import also tableau automatically
recognizes and geocodes our javascript
data when we import uh at times it fails
in assigning the role now we have
discussed this in previous topics as
well so this is more like a recap where
in our data source then we can actually
import and assign the geographic field
in the data we can uh the these should
be in a csv file and that defines the
hierarchies and locations of our data so
that's how it automatically created the
hierarchy all right uh geocoding uh
alias uh in case if you're asking what
does geocoding mean then
it simply means that tableau is able to
uh perform a coding all right in terms
of assigning the geographic role so let
me take you to the environment and
explain what your coding needs in this
case all right so let me switch back to
the environment here all right and let
us now discuss on what our geocodings
and how tableau automatically assigns on
these roles right so back here in our
data source all right
you can see we have
the
state city postal code all right now
each of these are geocoded already it's
coded the data is coded as a geographic
field this is geocoding so this is what
tableau does it automatically identify
so even in the connected data as well as
the special fields
we mentioned and we discussed that
tableau automatically assigns a
geographic role it provides a role to
the field with the common locations such
as you can see the country the city the
state and the coastal and it's provided
coding for it that it's a geographic
scene it's a geographic role and hence
you can see the globe sign here right so
uh again in the drop down then in this
case you can have
the descriptions in details and back
again in our data as well all right you
can see that uh there is a geocoding
identified by tableau automatically so
in case when you click on the drop down
here you can see the geographic role
this is where you can provide the role
of what this particular field is playing
it's a postal code all right and what is
the role whether it's the postal code so
it's automatically identifying its role
all right and in terms of
the data type as well this is it's
taking in the defaults but this is the
geocoding
alright so it's automatically assigning
the role
and giving a globe icon and
automatically coding the information as
to what value is it associated whether
it's associated with a postal code
whether it's associated with a state so
hence when i double click it
automatically gave us the state values
so geocoded the values based on its
state latitude and longitude so let's
say on a new sheet this time instead of
state if i click double click on country
all right it's automatically creating
the latitude and longitude all right let
me just quickly again disable my map
layers here in this case
and let me make this as default so that
it does not taken so now in this case
it's geocoded at the level as you can
see we are now seeing the entire uh for
a country all right so it's geocoding
for the country and giving us just one
simple map that we have a country data
information only for us hence we can see
this one particular symbol and similarly
in terms of state then it picked up
specifically for united states for every
state belonging in it so that is what
geocoding is so taboo automatically
defines it and in case if it doesn't
then you also have the option where you
can import the files and you can then
specify and create a custom geocoding
also all right so you can then provide a
particular name so let's say
you have an excel file in that you will
need to then or custom specify
so you're taking in the geocodings are
by default but in terms of custom what
you then have to do is you can import an
excel let's say it's an excel file
all right so in that you will have to
specify
the
say country
as its name all right you will have to
specify the state
as well as the
latitude
and
longitude so this is where you can
provide your custom geocoding so if it's
in-built it takes in the input custom
coding but there are times when you want
to specify add your own roles add in a
specific uh geocoding which is
extending to the hierarchy or a new role
that's refined in tableau then you can
also use a custom geocoding and that's
how you can provide additional details
but for custom geocoding you will then
need to provide the latitude and
longitude back again in your
database and in terms of custom
geocoding remember that it needs to be a
dot csv file all right uh it's where it
should contain
the latitude and longitude
because you want to customize and
provided a custom coding all right and
these values the latitude and longitude
values these need to be in the form of
real numbers all right wherein they can
indicate
at least
one decimal point
one decimal place
so this is one of the criteria when you
want to have a custom geo forting
instead of taking in the inbuilt where
taboo is automatically creating these
generated fields all right so going back
to the presentation slides
uh it's happening taking the information
from a third party maps also gets used
you're in the inbuilt uh yes alias is
actually in this case uh generating if
you remember these special scenes that
we were talking about uh tableau works
with
certain special feeds like date uh like
your geographic field and your number of
records all right or number of records
which is present in uh the dimensions
these three special fees tableau
automatically based on your data uh it
takes in the inbuilt so if you if you
have uh your country and state and all
these details back in your data source
you will notice we do not have any
latitude and longitude
so it automatically does that it
automatically uses built-in and based on
the names the detail it assigns the role
and it provides the latitude and
longitude so let's see that's when you
want to uh it's a it's an amazing
feature provided by tableau but or you
do not want to make use of the inbuilt
feature that is taken that's how then
you can have your custom geocoding as
well provided in terms of specific
latitude and longitudes but for that
these were the requirements that we
spoke about
that then it needs to contain a csv file
with the latitude and longitude by
default and they need to be in a real
number at least with one decimal place
so that's the reason when we are working
with them it shows generated
how does the map layer is uh
the map layer get designed from where is
it taking uh yes we're gonna come on to
that topic so we have a map specific map
menu wherein it's taking right now at
this point of time it's taking the
tableau default map
and then we can specify certain web map
servers as well
or then we can also specify certain data
layers that are present in built-in
tableau so we're going to talk about
that and discuss this further ahead so
for now it's taking in the basic the
default that is
provided so this is the default symbol
and field map that is provided by
tableau
so i'm right now selecting this as
default
and that's when it's taking in a symbol
or a field
uh when you're talking of role it's
assigning a geographic role to our data
it is automatically identifying and
providing it a role so there are times
when it might not provide and that's
when we can then specify that all right
my postal code here means a postal code
let's say it assumed and took it a city
so based on the data it automatically
identifies the role it's playing for
that particular field
whether it's a country role whether it's
a latitude a longitude or state and so
on so in case if it's not identified it
correctly we still have the choice to
change these
so that is what we're talking about in
terms of those
all right so going back to the
presentation slide we can hence instead
of the uh inbuilt one we can make use of
custom geocodings as well and we can
modify so here in the example uh now we
uh you can see that we have german
postcodes and hence you need to provide
the latitude and longitude a csv file
containing decimal values dual numbers
and that's how it will then plot in our
data so we can make use of excel files
import german postal codes in tableau
and also make use of it so right now
default inbuilt because we have our data
based on uh us is how it's taking in the
data so when you want to have custom
geocoding then you need to provide its
latitude and longitude
so first up what exactly is data
blending
so data blending is a method for
combining data from multiple sources
data blending brings in additional
information from a secondary data source
and displays it with data from the
primary data source directly in the view
so it might be a little complicated to
understand so let us make it a little
simple
let's imagine that you have data some of
your data is present in your sql
database and some of your data is
present in excel database or excel
worksheet and some data is present in
your cloud say salesforce so your duty
is to combine all your data from
different sources that is sql worksheet
salesforce and work on it so you might
have a question here we already have
joints but joints and relations have
their own limitations or drawbacks so to
cover that up or overcome those issues
tableau has come up with data blending
now let us take a step further and
understand what exactly i meant by
joining and
relationships and data blending
so as we discussed before the data
blending is a method for combining data
from multiple sources data blending
brings in additional information from a
secondary data source and displays it
with data from the primary data source
directly in the view yeah this was the
definition you can take a screenshot of
this and you can keep it for further
reference
now as we discussed there are some
existing ways to combine your data such
as relationships joints etc etc and then
we have the data blending option
so first relationships so
why exactly we do not prefer
relationships in a few situations
relationships cannot be formed between
tables from data sources published to
tableau server or table online so
relationships can't be formed based on
calculated fields when you use data
blending you can create calculation
fields those are called as data blending
calculations now next thing is the joins
joins combine tables by adding more
columns of data across similar row
structures and this can cause data loss
or duplication so when you use joins and
create the relationship between multiple
data sources of multiple tables then
there is a chance that the data can be
duplicated so just imagine that you have
two different tables and the two
different tables have one common field
such as id so even a student id has id
and employee id has id if you use a join
then there are chances that you might
get ids of both employee and students so
that's a duplication right so to avoid
that you can go with a data blending
now data blending unlike relationships
or joints never truly combine the data
instead blends query each data source
independently the results are aggregated
to the appropriate level then the
results are presented visually together
in the view
that's the reason why we use data
blending
now up next
we have the data blending example now
this is where we get into the practical
mode we'll get back to our data first
we'll see what kind of data we're going
to use for this particular example and
what are we going to do with that data
in the table u
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
so this is the excel sheet which has the
car sales data set that we'll be using
today this is the one of the data sets
and we have another data set
let me yeah
so we have another data set which i
personally created so this is a little
similar to the cast data set so i've
created this data set a little bit
similar to the cost sales data set so
that we can use this in these scenarios
of data blending so that you can
understand the concept in a much better
way so we have the following columns the
manufacturer model resale value engine
size horsepower wheelbase fuel capacity
fuel efficiency annual sales and region
and when we come into the bike sales we
have the same kind of columns so we have
the manufacturer model engine size
horsepower fuel capacity fuel efficiency
annual sales and zone
so you can see that this zone and region
from the car sales data set are similar
but the name is different so there's a
reason i've created a different uh name
for this particular column so that while
we are working on tableau data blending
will be actually blending these two
columns as a custom blend
so this is why i've named this
particular column as zoom
and yeah
so far so good i think we are good with
the data set now we'll get back to
tableau and start working on these data
sets
yeah so now we are on table u let's uh
since we're working on excel uh let's
create the excel
and uh yeah here we got our excel files
first let's click in car
yeah there we go we have the car data
set over here
and if you see we have got some
additional columns which we don't need
so
the actual column we had was this when
when i downloaded the data set this was
the actual column which has uh sales in
actually we had the
16.919 which i multiplied here okay so i
had made some changes to the data set in
the excel file and i've hidden the
actual data set so we don't need this
one over here so we'll do the hide
option over here as well so that's gone
over here now let's kind of rename this
as annual sales
enter and we don't need this f column so
this particular f column was created for
a formula on x
into sales in 2000 so we don't need this
one as well we'll remove this height
and the resale value and another f1 here
we'll remove this
now engine size one
why don't we rename that as engine size
done
and
do we have any other extra things no
annual sales too yeah that's gone as
well
so the region manufacturer model annual
sales resale value engine size
another engine size okay this was a
problem
so uh when you look into the engine size
over here okay and here so when you look
at the engine size here this is the
actual engine size from the data sets
the original one so it is represented in
the form of liters so basically the car
engines are always represented in the
form of liters so 1.8 liter engine 3.5
liter engine
but when you come into bikes they
represent the engine size in the form of
cc's that is cubic centimeters so the
bikes have 650 cc engine 1030 or yeah
1340 cc engine yeah that's how we
represent the engine size and bikes so
to make things similar i have created
the engine size ncc in the form of cc
over here you can see that over here so
1.8 is equals to 100 or 1800 cubic
centimeters so we don't need this
particular column here so we'll
eliminate this or we'll hide this
so far so good we have horsepower engine
size resale value fuel capacity if your
efficiency region yeah everything is
fine now so now the next step is to add
the
second data set or the second data
source so you can do that by selecting
this particular icon over here and
select a new data source or or there is
another way
you can
enter into your worksheet
and
you don't have to enter into your
worksheet you can do that from here as
well you can select the data and
add new data source so these are the
various options you can select a new
data source from here or you can select
a new resource from here or if you're on
the sheet then you can go again to the
data section and you can select the data
source from here as well or you also
have a short key
so when you see it
so you have a short key here which says
control okay sorry so you can read it
right on the right hand side of this
particular
dialog box ctrl d
you can directly press ctrl d and add
your new data source as well so now
we'll add the new data source so since
another data set that you're working on
is also an excel file we'll select the
excel file
so that was bike sales and
yeah there you go we have our bike sales
data set right on my screen right now
so in here as well you can see some
axis or unnecessary
columns so we'll remove that as well so
we'll hide this we'll hide
this
we'll hide this as well
now we have engine size horsepower fuel
capacity efficiency okay we have our
annual sales here
so i've changed a few numbers in this
particular annual sales column these are
not accurate so i've created some random
numbers just so that they're different
from the car sales
so yeah so far so good we have this zone
over here the regions column from yeah
let me show you that
let's go to the
sheet yeah so when you see cars we have
region over here
okay
so when you get into cars we have the
region over here which has the north
south east west and similarly when you
get into bikes we have the zone which
has the north south east west etcetera
etcetera so we are
now going to create the
blending between the two data sets so we
have the data set over here which is the
bike and we have another data set over
here which is the car so to create a
blend
let's get into
data and you can see the edit blend
relationships
row in the dialog box or the option in
the dialog box so uh remember when you
just have one data source just imagine
that you only had a cars data set only
one data set or let us remove this
how how do you remove this
close so we just have one data set over
here which is the bike data set so now
when you click on datum you don't have
that option see it you don't have that
option edit blend relationships
but but when you get a different data
source
so we have car sales over here now let's
get back our
okay did we had the cars over there
sales bike we have we have the bike
sales over here now let's get back our
cars data set
yeah
okay sorry sorry we can we can make the
changes again not a problem so we'll
remove this
we'll rename it
on this note uh
let me tell you guys uh if you are
getting some errors or if you're getting
some uh you know kind of troubles while
you're learning
it's a sign that you're trying your best
so we have simply learn community which
has
the solutions to your problems so if you
have any problems while you're learning
then you can
directly you know post your query over
there and our team of experts will be
really happy to help you out with the
solutions
so we have our annual sales over here
and another annual sales which we don't
need so we'll hide that
we have the manufacturer model annual
sales resale value engine size
so i think we don't need this engine
size which isn't the latest
now we'll rename this
as engine size
great
yeah we're done so we'll get back to our
sheet now when you hover over to data
and
you can find the data relationship
option over here so this happens when
you have multiple sources only now let's
click that and you can see we have the
automatic option and the tableau has
automatically you know found a data
blend option for the columns which have
the same names so we have manufacturer
model and
manufacturer and model in both bikes and
cars
so we also have the same names for
annual sales engine fuel fuel efficiency
horsepower also so they are in the
measures section that's the reason the w
has ignored them so
and remember that we have regions in
[Music]
cars and zone and bikes but we can't
find that relationship over here because
they have different column names to get
a blend between those columns we can
always choose custom so when you choose
custom
okay
we don't have uh zone over here
you need to make some changes i guess
yeah we need to press add icon and from
add you can see the region
from
the cars data set and zone from bikes
data set
select ok and then you can find a blend
relationship between the region from
cars and zone from bikes
now we have the blend successfully
applied let's select ok and we are done
so let's begin with our operations so
currently we are in
bike sales data set
so if we start the operations on bike
sales data set
for an example let's choose
zone into columns and
annual cells into rows
so you can see a little tiny blue tick
over here so this particular little tiny
blue tick represents that this has now
become your primary data set or primary
data source because you're currently
working on that particular data set now
if you remove the zone and annual sales
and again if your shade is completely
empty and if you enter into the car's
data set and again choose regions and
regions on the columns again the same
thing drag the angle sales into rows
like i'm just showing you if there is
some operations happening with the
particular data set then you can find
the blue tick icon which says that
you're working on this particular data
set so that's how we see it
now
so this is how you find the um you know
sales happening in that particular
region
and
yeah we can create another sheet
and then we'll see
which model has the
biggest engine
now let's kind of sort it
so viper has the biggest engine dodge
wiper yeah a muscle car of america
now
let's create a different sheet now let's
get back into bikes data set
which is the most fuel efficient bike
uh row and model
so now
according to the data set what i created
multistrada 950 has the biggest mileage
that's great
okay it shouldn't give 50 maybe i think
i entered some wrong value
yeah sv 650
or we can actually take a manufacturer
over here and you know
so sv 650 belongs to
[Music]
let's sort it
where is this v650 yeah sv 650 belongs
to suzuki great
so sv650 has a good mileage next to
multistrada 950.
so this is how you can use sheets and
data from different data sets now moving
forward let's create some data blending
calculations for that let's create a new
sheet
now we have created a new sheet now
let's rename it as data blend
calculations
now we have successfully renamed our
sheet as data blending calculations
now
we are in car sales so let's drag the
manufacturer into columns
and sales annual sales of the
so we have the report of annual sales of
different car manufacturers over here
ford leading and we have porsche
subaru
suzuki hindi etc etc now let's get back
to bike sales and
drag these same annual sales from the
bytes data set into rows
so as you can see on my screen you have
the
annual sales for cars and bikes together
on one single screen so here we have
suzuki as well which is a bike maker and
ford etc etc are the car makers so other
than bikes we have another 28 nulls
which do not belong to the bike section
now our aim is to create a new
calculated field which is about the data
blending calculation
so you can see that a little icon over
here which represents the blend icon
and you can always select that to stop
the blending and you can
click on that to use it as a linking
field so that's how you can use the
blend icon now we are about to create a
new calculated field so you can right
click and create a calculated field or
you can always choose the icon over here
and create a catholic field so now we
have the calculated field over here
let's rename it as data blend
calculation now we have successfully
renamed our calculated field as data
blend calculation now we'll find the sum
of uh sales happening in cars and bikes
so for that we'll be using the summation
of
sales or annual sales
now we have the annual sales sum of
bikes now we'll add the cars one for
that i'll be selecting plus and sum of
annual sales of cars
so you can see that we have two sums
over here so we don't need that
second sum so we'll eliminate that
so we have another bracket over here
which we don't need so we'll eliminate
that as well so now the calculation
field is valid let's click apply and
okay
so now you can see a newly created
calculation field over here with the
icon equals to hashtag which says that's
as a calculated field now let's drag
this calculated field into the rows icon
and you can see the sum of uh
both sales happening in
uh this particular segment here which
shows you the sum of sales of both cars
and bikes now you can see that we have
28 nulls over here right so we should be
having all the you know when you're
calculating the sum of annual sales of
both the data sets and you should be
having something over here
so for that we need to make a little
addition over here that's a function
z and yeah
now after adding said then okay we lost
the sum so we need to add the sum again
and sum of annual sales
or
we can just stand it over here
okay this should be pretty good now we
need to add another zn over here
and another sum over here
close the bracket yeah this should be
good yeah the calculation is valid now
let's add apply
and okay now we have the annual sales
for both cars and bikes and suzuki
combined bmw combined as well
so that's how we do the w data blending
operations so with that let's get back
to the presentation mode again
now the next part in our tutorial today
is
the data blending versus joins so what
are the differences between data
blending and joins so this particular
short data table should explain you the
differences between them so in data
blending the data gets aggregated first
then the data gets combined but where in
joints the data will be
joined first or combined first then the
data is aggregated and the second
difference is when we use data blending
the data set is from different data
sources
but when you use joins you need to make
sure that the data is coming from a
single source
now when we come into the data blending
again you can only use left join
so you can consider data blending as an
advanced version of joins but only the
left join can be applied but when we
come into joints we have the different
types of joints like left joint right
joint etc etc right we have different
types of joints so that's how we have a
difference between joints and data
blending the fourth difference is data
can be available in different level of
granularity in data blending so the
level of granularity can be maintained
at a different level when you have or
different levels when you use their
blending but when you use joints all the
granularity of all the data should be
maintained at the same level and the
last difference between the both is data
blending sends separate query to each
data set and aggregates then performs
blending and the last difference between
the both is when you use data blending
the data blending sends separate query
to each data set then aggregates them
and finally performs data blending
operations but when you use joins the
queries will be sent to the data at a
row level
so with that let's enter into the next
segment where we will discuss about the
limitations of data blending
so the limitations of data blending are
as follows data blending compromises the
query execution speed and high
granularity so when you have the higher
rate of granularity on your data sets
then obviously the execution speed will
be compromised next
while sorting a calculated field that
uses blended data that field is not
listed in the sorted field drop down
dialog box and the last limitation is
cube data sources can be used only as a
primary data source to the blend data in
tableau and cannot be used as a
secondary data source so these were the
limitations of data blending in w so
let's understand and see how we can
perform sort now your sort refers to
arranging your dimension members in a
specified order whether you want to have
it as descending or whether you want to
have it as ascending all right
so you can perform your sort wherein you
can sort directly on the axis on a
particular field or you can do it
manually as well now what tablet
supports is it supports computed sorting
as well as manual sorting so i'm going
to show you both these options of how
you can sort based on your computed
sorting as well as manual slotting so
let me quickly show you the options in
terms of how you can sort on your data
all right so now we have region and
column and sales in my rows all right
now you will find the sort option you
can see the sort option already
available in your toolbar in terms of
whether you want to sort your data
either in an ascending or a descending
manner so this is a quick sort all right
you can have your data sorted as an
ascending or a descending manner and the
moment you've sorted on your data notice
on region and on sales you're able to
see the sorting sign right it's sorted
in it's performed a quick slot uh and
hence you're able to see the sorting
sign that has been enabled in terms of
our region and
uh says a quick sort that you can make
use of from the toolbar all right now
there is also a way that you can sort
your data manually as well so that was a
quick sort that you can perform all
right so you can allow a quick shorting
but in this case you also have the
option that you can perform a sorting
now when i move on to the axis here you
can see that i can use the sorting
option here as well and change the order
of sorting all right i can sort in a
descending and ascending manner so when
i hover over you can see that my data is
getting sorted let me clear the uh sorts
all uh together and then again show you
so that when we hover on to sales you
can see that we have the sorting that
comes up a floating sorting icon so one
is you can sort from the toolbar the
other is a floating sort icon appears
when you hover on to the axis and you
can sort your data accordingly
all right so that is another way of
doing it and in terms of let's say we
want to manually sort our data as well
so what you can do is then we can simply
use the dates and we can do a computed
sorting so in this case let's say uh in
the drop down you have the option here
that says sort in the drop down panel
region you can click on that this opens
up the computed sorting of the order
that you want in terms of region whether
you want it as ascending or descending
whether you want to sort it based on the
data source order which is present in
your data source the alphabetic order
all right it's going to take in the
alphabet or whether you want to use it
sorting based on a particular field so i
want to sort it let's say based on sales
aggregation so how do i want to sort my
region and i can also perform a manual
sort where i can choose that instead of
my central east south and west let's say
i want center i want west right on top
and i want east
west and
central i want east probably after south
so again i manually sort it as well
irrespective of it taking in the
ascending and descending based on the
alphabet or the data source order or the
field so i can manually sort my data
here as well so this is where i can
perform a manual sort where i can uh
specify the position of the manual bars
all right
what is the data source order uh
in your data source now if you're
connected to this particular excel file
right so the excel file in this case
here is our data source and however
region is in terms of our excel files we
are saying sorted based on that data
source order
all right so instead of the alphabet or
instead of the feel of the manual i'm
saying whatever so let's say if your
south is first in your data source and
your central is last then it's going to
take in that particular ordering and
it's going to sort it based on whatever
is first to last in the data source
excel
so that's how you can sort on your data
as we saw so that that was another way
this was to do with your computed
sorting so one was a quick one where you
can use the toolbar or the axis or then
you can click on the drop-down pill of
that particular field and based on that
you can perform your computed sorting as
well as the manual sorting all right now
this changed it to the level of sorting
because we used the manual one and we
made changes and that's how we
positioned our bars manually based on
the selections that we wanted let's have
a quick recap so we can sort on the axis
on a specific field or we can do it
manually as well as we saw tableau
supports computed where we could use the
toolbars or the axis or we could perform
a manual sort as well when we clicked on
a particular pill we had the option to
manually sort our fields also
so here it comes before sorting when
you've done it on the access as i said
you can hover over the particular axis a
floating icon appears and you can sort
your data all right in terms of a
specific page you can then click on the
drop down and open up a sort for that
particular field and decide whether you
want to what kind of sorting you want to
enable you want to sort as ascending or
descending what is the order that you
want to use for your sorting or whether
you want a manual slot the third option
available or for you all in the sorting
window
now that was about sorting
so in this particular topic we are going
to be discussing once we are done once
you've completed this particular lesson
you're going to be able to understand
how tableau works with date hierarchies
in terms of pivoting date parts on
shelves
how you can differentiate between a
discrete and a continuous date how you
can create and make use of custom dates
what are the dimensions on a fiscal here
and how you can filter on date
dimensions dynamically using your
relative date filtering
and also understand the working of date
hierarchy with cube
so that's in store for us for this
particular lesson so let me now move on
and begin with the first topic here now
if you remember previously we had
discussed that in terms of dates tableau
handles depending on the kind of
database data source that you're using
this relational or a cube data source it
handles and works with the date
differently depending on its data source
all right so
you can see it automatically separates
the date field into
multiple levels of time hierarchy as you
can see here
all right so uh in case when you have a
date it breaks down you can see from
your to quarter on to month to week and
day all right so it creates its own
level of hierarchy here that uh it can
make use of and separates the entire
field now this is in case when you're
using a file when you're using a
relational file all right so
at the end of this we would also discuss
that in case if it's a multi-dimensional
cube file then what happens so right now
we're talking about the basic excel
sample file and that's how we screen
that tableau automatically divides into
multiple levels of time hierarchy all
right so in this case you can see back
in on our
excel you will find that we have the
order date which is a single uh level
and column here that you can see all
right but the moment we pull in that
data so let me show that to you in the
repository as well the moment we pull in
this particular data order date all
right uh that's how you can see it
onto our sample superstore data
dimension here and it automatically
creates a hierarchy so we've seen this
earlier now that as soon as we add it up
we can drill and we can keep moving
ahead all right so let's understand
let's take up a scenario and discuss on
on how uh dates are dealt with so jason
michaels now he is the sales manager of
an apparel manufacturing company
now in uh quarter four the performance
uh he has a performance review meeting
which is on next week all right
and in that case he needs to present the
year over your sales report when he
wants to highlight how his new marketing
strategy that was introduced in this
particular year
has increased the sales considerably all
right and for that he needs to see the
sales report initially at or your level
and then additionally he should be able
to drill down to the sales performance
at a quarter and monthly level now let's
see uh assuming that we're jason
michaels here how are we going to
achieve this particular scenario all
right so let me switch on to my
so i'm going to move on to my tableau
environment here wherein i have already
added in the order sheet from the sample
file provided by tableau now to achieve
that particular scenario what we're
going to be doing is let's first build a
normal view where we can have the order
date and sum of sales all right where
and then we can proceed further where we
can achieve that achievable where uh as
jason michaels we will be able to see
the sales at an initial yearly level all
right and then we should be able to
drill down at uh wherein we can show the
sales performance
so now since we're talking about
wanting to see a yearly level we're
related to time that we want to see what
we're going to do is let's have our
sales and
order date selected
all right and based on this in the show
me option you can see it gives us the
option to create a line now uh that is
one of the best charts that you can make
use of in terms of analyzing something
which is time related which is time
based so whenever you want to analyze
something time related time based your
line chart your line graphs is what is
ideal in terms of choosing the kind of
view all right so here we have the your
order date so if you notice we already
have the order date and tableau has
automatically created the hierarchy the
level here for us and by default it's
taking in the highest level of the time
hierarchy here so it takes in the
uh level at a yearly level here for our
sales that we can see
now this is how jason will be able to
achieve his view where he can see these
sales at a yearly level for all the
years that are present in the data
course all right
now he should be able to drill down as
the uh you know requirement was that he
should be able to drill at every level
in terms of seeing the performance
because he had introduced a particular
plan a particular sales plan and he
wants to see whether that implementation
has been beneficial so he can simply
click on the plus sign here and that's
how now we've drilled down from your to
a quarter level so we're able to see the
sales here for every year divided at a
quarter level all right
and then finally
we can drill down even more further by
clicking on the plus sign which can
uh then in terms of uh drilling down to
a monthly level where in now we can see
that we're able to see the entire data
at a yearly quarterly and monthly
division year all right so it's january
february and march that you're able to
see which is the first quarter in 2011
and that's how you're able to see your
sales across time all right so that's
how jason can achieve this particular uh
scenario where he can see these sales
over time
uh the leap
has a question that says how do we get
the plus sign they leap in terms when
you're using the
uh relative relational data source which
is the sample data source the moment you
drag and drop your order date onto the
columns or any field it will
automatically give you the plus and
minus sign because uh what happens is
like i mentioned tableau basically
refers and it deals with date in a
special manner all right so if it's a
it's a relational source
it automatically creates a time
hierarchy now you can see we don't see
any hierarchy that is created here but
what it has done is it has identified
the role it has identified it is related
to date and time and that is the reason
it has automatically created these
levels of hierarchy for us
so in our data whatever other dates the
year or the quarter
based on that tableau has automatically
identified and created these hierarchies
for us
all right so you can directly the moment
you drag and drop a particular when you
drag and drop the order date or any date
related field coming in from a
relational source you can automatically
see the plus and minus sign
all right i hope that answers your
question
so that is how we have jason who will be
able to achieve where now he can have
the entire let's go back to the demo
let's go back and see so he wanted to
highlight how his new marketing strategy
was introduced in that year increase the
sales all right and he wanted the
initial report at your level and then
finally he should be able to drill it
down to quarter and month and that's
exactly how we could achieve the
scenario so first we created a view
which is yours and the sales and that's
how we can see that there has been a
considerable increase in terms of all
the sales that have been taking place
all right uh based on the
uh
introduction of
the basic uh program the marketing
strategy that he had introduced all
right so that's how uh one we've
achieved and seen how we can achieve the
scenario and moreover how tableau
handles the date in terms of when you're
using a relational data source
so talking about date and time it
handles the details it handles it in a
different way all right and moreover it
also now let's say we have uh uh in
terms of pivoting the date parts on the
shelf all right tableau also allows us
to pivot the date part where and we can
pivot the data granularity levels
between our days week month or quarter
all right where we want to gain a better
insight and we can pivot these dates by
simply placing these fields with
different levels on different shells
okay now how that is going to be
achieved i'm going to show that to you
also let me move on to the tableau
environment here let me add a new sheet
all right now
assume let's say that we have a line or
chart all right that is going to display
the your and uh the year for or the
sales all right so let me first create
that view let's have our order dates in
columns
let's have our sales in rows now in case
if you're not sure whether which
particular dimension or measure or which
particular field should be placed in
into the columns and rows to create this
view you can simply as i mentioned
earlier as well select multi-select the
fields that we require go to the show me
options and make your selections all
right so that way it'll automatically
place up the required fields onto the
columns and rows uh i'm doing this
manually here so that you can keep
getting used to the tool and get an idea
of how it's created now i'm going to
have uh you can see we have the your we
have the sum of tails now earlier we saw
that we achieved this particular level
by drilling onto the data now instead of
drilling i would also instead color
encode my marks the line here based on
quarter which will give me four lines on
the quarter bases at a yearly level all
right so that's another way that i can
achieve my drilling i can achieve it
based on a color coding using water in
this particular scenario so what we can
do is
uh i can simply click on the order date
and drag it on to the color shelf here
all right and it's now provided it based
on
sorry it's taken in the sum here uh
let's have the order date so you can
simply right click you can use the
control option
and based on the control option you can
drag this particular pill and add it up
to the color shelf here and this is how
then you can divide you can have it
based at the quarter
so you can now see it encoded the color
so you have a yearly level there are now
a color encoding which is happening at
the quarter level as well all right so
this is how you can separate the
particular view you can separate now you
have a color encoding for your all right
uh which is at a quarterly level that
you can see now the same thing let's say
you want to achieve and you want to have
your yours and your month and quarter
instead all right so you can simply
again pivot back your quarter all right
now you want to have your quarters as
well uh as well as after you want to
analyze and code it with a monthly level
uh in terms of every quarter of that
particular year you can simply pivot
your quarter from your colors mark onto
the rows all right
and you can then add in your
you can simply drill
have your month all right so this is
your monthly order date which you build
and then move this bill directly pivot
it from the roast onto the color shelf
all right so that's how you can keep
drilling and pivoting so we can now have
as you can see we are now having an
analysis of our sales which is happening
at a monthly level for every quarter for
its particular year
so again this is another way of
achieving this particular scenario also
all right
so that's
you can pivot date
uh in tableau wherein uh first we saw
that the same way we could achieve where
we could have we could create uh the
view let me just take off the product
names and have it back to our original
view all right
so
uh initially we had created
our view with sales
and
so let me have my sales back again in
the row
and
the drilling all right
so you can see that your it is
separating each of it drilling down at
every your level for every month now the
same view all right in terms of drilling
is what we understood that tableau
allows drilling but for it to give it a
better look a better enhancement in
terms of analyzing as well we can simply
then pivot whatever we had added in so
all our years quarter and month we
pivoted them and added them so we
pivoted our quarter to rows and our
month to colors and that's how it's all
in band view and it's easier the view is
much more better in terms of analyzing
it all right so that's how we can pivot
our data and make our data look even
more useful even more meaningful
okay
so let's go back to our presentation
slide here and
so that's how we can make use of the
pivoting and make our views enhance our
views and make it better
so we will get started by understanding
the proper definition of the parameter
and w
so what exactly are parameters in w
so parameter will allow you to provide a
value to pass into table u parameters
allow you to produce scenarios or
options that are not available in your
data or create these values to put it
into your visualization after creation
end users can control the input to see
the results of the parameters effect
so this is a little complex to
understand so let me just break it down
to a simpler version so parameters are
completely similar to filters so when
you apply a filter just imagine that you
wanted to find the sales of top 10 sub
category items so which are is it phones
is it furniture is it something else so
which are the top 10 items which are
finding me the most profitable sales so
you'll apply that filter to that
particular sheet so what if you wanted
to apply the same filter to 10 sheets
yeah by brute force method you can do
that and you can apply that to the 10
sheets but what if you had hundreds of
sheets
right so in that scenario you might
prefer using parameters because once you
set the parameter you can use that
particular parameter for all the sheets
in your visualization and even you can
use these parameters in your dashboards
as well
so i think this was a little simpler to
understand now what are the use cases
that we will be discussing today in
parameters
so there are multiple parameters that
you can use in your day-to-day w usage
so we'll learn the most frequently used
parameters we're gonna use the top end
parameters date field parameter dynamic
measures dynamic dimensions dynamic
measures and dimensions reference lines
and some sets so i hope so far so good
now let's begin with our practical
session so let's get back to w so we'll
be using the superstore data set we have
dates and etcetera etcetera columns
which we need for the parameters to be
applied so we'll go with that
so you can see that i've already worked
on some sheets which include the
parameters such as state parameter
dynamic measures dynamic dimensions
dynamic measures and dimensions
et cetera et cetera
so don't worry i'll save this book for
your future reference we'll be creating
new sheets and we'll be applying new
parameters for a better understanding in
a practical way
so for now let's create a new sheet
so you can see the icon by clicking that
you can just enter into the new sheet
now for our reference let let's rename
it
so we'll rename it as
top
and so we'll be beginning with the top
end parameters so we'll rename it as
stopping for now
enter
yeah
so for top 10
let's drag
sales into rows
and
subcategory from dimensions to columns
now we have a bar chart on our screen
let's kind of twist it or
change the orientation yeah
now we want to find the top 10 or top
five uh
items which are giving us a top sale so
let's kind of order it in descending
to do so or to know the top 10 items
which are given as the maximum sales
will apply filters onto it so to apply a
filter let's drag the subcategory into
filters
and you can see a drop down menu or a
dialog box where we can find the option
called top so here we can specify the
top ideas or top items or top categories
whatever it is which are giving us the
top sales
so we'll be selecting by field and
inside that we have a top 10.
now okay we are not going to create a
parameter right away
yeah we have to create a parameter right
away
now just select
a new name for your parameter
now let's select
top n
parameter
hyphen or let's place the number in the
starting for our better identification
okay
now let's select list
now we have
if you remember we had the minimum and
maximum values is 1 200 in the previous
dialog box now let's select that to 10
and here
five
or seven
now let's select uh
oh let's do it 15
and 5. now let's rename them
display as
top
now display the 10 as
top 10 and the 5 as
top 5.
now the parameter is created you can see
the
number second top end parameter on my
parameters
section over here in the bottom left
corner
now the aggregation is sum by default
now let's select apply and okay
now let us right click the parameter and
select the show parameter icon
and here we have the top 15. now let's
try to select top 10. now you can see
that the sheet has changed the data now
we just have the top 10
sub category items which are providing
us the maximum number of sales
now if we kind of select label and show
marked labels then we have the numbers
right you can see the numbers which are
providing us maximum sales over here
now let's kind of select f5
yeah so that's how the top end
parameters works in real time now let's
continue with the next type of parameter
in our list which happens to be the date
field parameter
for that let's create a new sheet now
let's rename it as date sheet
for our reference
now we have the date sheet over here
now to create a date parameter we need a
date so we have the order date over here
let's drag that to
rows
now let's select
profit
and let's drop it down to here now we
have the profit on a particular dates
over here
now to create a date parameter let's
select the icon over here and we have a
create parameter option
now
let's create a parameter
now let's rename it as
second hyphen date parameter
i'm renaming it as second hyphen because
we have already worked on this
particular sheet and if you have seen
this particular parameter section we
have a date parameter already existing
in my sheet so for that i'm renaming it
as
second date parameter for the reference
now we might have a doubt about
selecting the data type for the dates
i'll go with string over here
now let's select the list and add the
values now for a date we have year
as well as quarter
next we'll have months
we'll have a week and we'll also have a
day
so that's our parameter which is number
two date parameter let's select okay so
once we have created the date parameter
the next step is to create a calculated
field
so this particular calculation field
will help us with the calculation of
days quarters months weeks and years now
let's rename this as well rename it as
to
date
calculation
yep
now in this particular tray we'll be
writing the formula
you can see that we already have a date
calculation over here let's try to see
the formula over there
so here we are we have the date
parameter
and year quarter month weekend daily
and we have the order date parameter
over here or the date and this
particular hyphen queue is used for
dividing the year into quarters
now we're going to use the same formula
now let's create a new calculated field
now let's select case
and remember the date parameter we
created in the parameter section you
need to drag that in
so that's dragged now let's paste the
formula
and
end
so there you go we have the
parameter dragged into the calculation
field and we have the calculation for
year quarter month weekend day and we
have the calculation as valid
notification over here now let's just
select okay
now they go in
in the measure segment or
here
yeah there you go in the dimension
segment we have the date calculation
field available
okay now we have the sales and year-wise
data over here let's change the type of
graph to bar graph
let's change the orientation
yeah
now let's select the label option to
provide us the details of sales
there you go you have the sales now
let's select the date parameter
show parameter option and we have the
year by sales number let's select that
to quarter
so the parameters is shown on the right
hand column so you can see the sales are
according to year now when you select
quarter you have the quarters when you
select month you have month wise sales
and when you have week week-wise sales
and finally the day by sales
so you can see that on the 18th of march
2014 we have the maximum amount of sales
so that's how you do it now moving ahead
we have the dynamic measures and dynamic
dimensions once we are done with the
dynamic measures and dimensions we'll
also execute dynamic measures and
dimensions together then we'll continue
with reference lines and sets let's get
back to w so what exactly are dynamic
dimensions so you can see that on the
left hand column we have so many
dimensions over here so we'll be
creating a filter and we'll be passing
all the dimensions or the number of
dimensions what we want on our filter to
be
so we'll pass those number of dimensions
into the filter and for the same we'll
be creating a parameter and we'll be
running all the values of dimensions
through that parameter now let's go
ahead and create a new parameter let's
select the icon create a parameter
and now we are in the new workbook to
avoid confusion so we'll rename this as
dynamic
dimensions
parameter
we'll select the data type as string
current value
and list and inside the list
let's write in the category shift mode
and segment
let's select okay and you can see that
we have the new parameter over here
which says dynamic dimensions parameter
now once the uh
parameter is created the next step is to
create a calculation field let's select
the calculated field option
and inside this let's rename this
calculation as
dynamic
dimension
calculation field
and inside the tree let's write in the
formula
now let's write in case
and let's drag the newly created
parameter
and now
let's select one
category
then
from dimensions
followed by that one
ship mode
then
from dimensions
followed by that
when
segment
then
segment from dimensions
now and
yeah the calculation is valid let's
apply
okay
so you can see that we have a newly
created dynamic dimension calculation in
the dimensions section
now we have the newly created dimension
calculation here we'll drag that to
columns
now let's drag sales
to rows
now let's drag the category to columns
so there you go we have the different
categories furniture office technology
now we have the parameter displayed on
the right hand side now let's select
according to the ship mode so according
to the ship mode we have the first class
second class
same day standard class etc etc and
these are the categories happening in
that particular fields and if you select
the category or parameter by segment we
have these results consumer corporate
and office now this is how the dynamic
dimension parameter works now let's get
into the dynamic measure parameter
for that let's create a new sheet
we are in the new sheet now
now dynamic measures are completely same
to dynamic dimensions the only thing
changing here is instead of dimensions
we'll be dealing with measures
now we'll follow the same steps again
first create a
parameter
let's rename this as
dynamic
measures parameter
and in the list we'll be using
sales profit and quantity
let's select okay and our parameter is
done now let's create a calculated field
similar to dynamic dimensions
let's rename this
calculation is dynamic
measures calculation
and inside the tray let's type in case
let's drag the measures parameter
there you go
now
when
we have used sales profit and quantity
so sales
then
fails
when
profit
then
when
quantity
then
[Music]
quantity
and
yeah the calculation field is valid
apply and okay
now let's make use of show parameter
options so that we can see the parameter
on the right hand corner
now let's select the
category from dimensions
and the newly created dynamic measures
calculation onto rows
so we have the
bar chart over here
now let's select profit
so you can see the profit
by
category wise and you can select the
label so that we can have a clear
picture of the numbers
now if we select the quantity we have
the details according to the quantity
now to just make things look a little
better we can drop the category off and
make use of sub category to have a
better visualization on the
sub categories which are bringing us
maximum sales you can rearrange them in
descending order and we can see
binders are giving us maximum profit uh
in the number of quantity in the profit
yeah copiers and in sales we have phones
so that's how we use dynamic measures in
real now the next part is both dynamic
measures and dynamic dimensions together
for that all you need to do is just
select the calculations from dynamic
measures and drop it down to rows and
dynamic measure dimension calculations
onto columns we're using both the
calculations together and now let's kind
of use the option of show parameter
where we can see the dynamic dimension
parameter and dynamic measure parameter
together now when you select category
and sales
quantity
now we have both dimensions and measures
here
now let's select the label option so
that we can have a detailed
appearance on numbers now we have the
segments over here consumer corporate
and office when we select sales we have
the sales number when we select profit
we have the profit number when we have
the quantity we have the quantity number
so that's how the dynamic dimensions and
dynamic measures are used in real time
so the next parameter that we'll be
dealing with is the reference lines
now we are back on tableau let's create
a new sheet
now for reference line let's select
the order date
and drop it down to columns and now
let's select
sales
from
measures and drop it down to rows now
let's make a change to here we'll
we'll check that today
and we have a line over here
we need the sales and continuous day
format yeah so this is how it looks like
now let's create a new parameter
let's rename this as
date parameter
let's select the data type as date and
current value
and let's select the date as
so according to data set we have the
dates between 2013 to 2018 so select
anything between 2013 to 14
let's select 2014 yeah
now let's select okay
so now we have the newly created date
parameter over here let's select the
show parameter icon now let's get back
to analytics and try to use a line so
we'll use the reference line let's
select table
let's select the type of line
and color
okay
so you can see a reference line over
here which is got created
now let's get back to data once and uh
date parameter let's edit it once
i think we forgot something important
it's fine here
yeah let's recreate the line again let's
use the reference line table
and here
we created a date parameter we need to
select this i think i forgot that
okay now let's select the type of line
let's select a medium thick line and
dotted line let's select the color as
pink
yeah that should be it let's select okay
now let's select the show parameter
option when we have the date parameter
option over here let's kind of change
the date and once we change the date you
can see there is a shift in the line
so that's how we use the
reference line in real time we have the
date parameter over here this is how we
use it now let's move to the next option
or next parameter in the list that is
the set parameter for that let's create
a new sheet
now let's drag the sales to columns
and sub categories to rows
now select subcategory and
yeah let's select subcategory from
dimensions right click and let's use the
create option and from there we'll be
creating a set
let's rename the set uh the sub category
set is perfect let's navigate to top and
inside that let's select by field and
let's select
the top and parameter
we are in the sub category we have
created a new parameter which we had in
the earlier sheet
so again
let's navigate to top and
let's rename this
now by field
by top end parameter
select ok
now you can see that we have a new set
over here
so now let's select the show parameter
option
and now let's drag the set
into color so that we have different
colors
so that's how you use set in real time
in parameter calculations in tableau so
now let's discuss the differences
between
parameters and tableau filters
so these are the few differences between
w parameters and tableau filters so w
parameters are used for static data and
w filters are used for dynamic data so
parameters are implemented to entire
workbook whereas filters are implemented
to only specific sheets so this is what
we discussed in the earlier part so
using parameters cannot select multiple
values but using filters can select
multiple values at a time and parameters
use calculated fields while filters do
not use calculated fields and finally
parameters support multiple data types
whereas filters do not support multiple
data types
so lod expression stands for level of
detail expressions in w
the lod expressions will allow you to
compute values at data source level and
visualization level however lod
expressions give you even more control
on the level of granularity that you
want to compute
they can be performed at more granular
level that is we use include lod
expression there a less granular level
where the exclude lod expression will be
handy and finally and entirely
independent level that is the fixed lod
expression so in this tutorial i'll
explain you the types of lod expressions
you can use in w as well as when to use
them and how to format them i will also
use an example to demonstrate how to
create simple lod expressions in tableau
now in this image you can understand
that
the aggregation and granularity levels
are inversely proportional that means as
the level of aggregation or as the level
of ordering in data increases the
granularity level gradually decreases so
this particular example will help you
understand the inverse proportional
relation between the aggregation and
granularity
now let's move into the next part where
we will understand the two types of lod
expressions in w so basically there are
two types of lod expressions in tableau
the first one is the row level lod
expression and the second one is the
view level lod expression
so in w expressions referring to
unaggregated data source columns and are
computed for each row in the underlying
table are the row level expressions so
in row level expressions the
dimensionality of the expression is
considered to be at the row level only
now the second type of lod expression
that is the view level lod expression so
by contrast which is the opposite to row
level the expressions referring to
aggregated data source columns are
computed in the dimensionality defined
by the dimensions in the view in the
view level lod expressions the
dimensionality of the expressions is
confined to the view level only now the
next part is about the syntax of lod
expressions in w
so as you can see on my screen we have a
sample syntax to be followed for the
level of detail expressions in w so we
will be following the same kind of
syntax in our real-time examples now
moving ahead we have the types of lod
expressions in w so basically as
discussed in the definition we have
three different types of
lod expressions in w so the first one is
the include level of detail expressions
in tableau the second one is the exclude
level of detail expressions in tableau
and finally the last one that is the
fixed level of detail expressions in w
don't worry we will understand each one
of them in a bit more detail along with
a practical example for a better
understanding
so the first one the include level of
detail expression
the include level of detail expressions
compute values using the specified
dimensions in the addition to whatever
dimensions are in the view
include level of detail expressions can
be useful when you want to calculate at
a fine level of detail in the database
and then re-aggregate and show at a
course level of detail in your view
fields based on include level of detail
expressions will change as you add or
remove dimensions from the view now
let's get back to tableau and try to
execute a simple example for include
level of detail expression
now we are back on tableau and we are
going to use the sample data set in the
table which is the superstore data set
now to create lod expressions in tableau
we have some steps so the first step is
to set up a visualization first so we
need to use the data from the dimensions
and measures and we need to create a
visualization on the sheet and once the
visualization on the sheet is ready then
we are going to create the lod
expression so for that we are going to
use the analysis button on the toolbar
and then we are going to create a
calculated field and inside the
calculated field we are going to create
our expression for lod that is the level
of detail so once the calculated field
is set up or the level of detail
expression is set up the third step is
to use the level of detail expression in
the visualization that is we'll be
getting the newly created level of
detail expression field in this
particular dimensions or measures and
we'll be dragging that into the rows or
columns or we'll be dragging that into
the details tool tips
text size color etc etc basically we'll
be using that particular new field which
got generated using the level of detail
expression and will be creating the new
visualization using that particular lod
now we have a brief idea how to create
an lod
now let's begin with the first type of
lod expression that is the include type
of lod expression now let's try to
rename this sheet
i'll rename it as include lod
so before getting started i would like
to tell you guys that we will be using
color size label detail so only these
four boxes or only these four shells
will be affecting the level of detail
visualization in real time and the tool
tip and filter pages etc etc will not be
affecting that much
now let's begin with the first one
now as the first step we are going to
create a visualization on the screen
first
so for that let's drag the
region
into columns
now let's drag the sum of sales into
columns
so now we have a bar chart visualization
on my screen which tells about the
number of sales happening in different
different regions so if we have an
example that is central which is near to
500k and east is around
678k
and similarly south and similarly west
so basically we have created the first
step that is create a virtualization on
this sheet
now the second step to create the new
calculated field that is the lod
expression for that will be moving to
the analysis button on the menu bar
click that and
you can see in the drop down menu we
have the create calculated field option
select that
now let's rename this
now let's rename this as sales per
customer
let's select the region where we have to
write our expression so for that we'll
use the include option
next we have the customer
we'll select the customer name or even
we can select the customer id let's go
with the customer id
then
let's select the sum
or
sales
so we have our lod expression ready
okay this shows that the calculation has
some errors
yeah this should be resolved
and let's go with customer name and
let's select ok
yeah i think we forgot to mention the
flower bracket at the end
let's try that yeah now the expression
is proper
so the best part of tableau is if there
is an error in your expression tabula
will not allow you to continue with that
it will show a warning over here that's
the best part so now let's consider the
id back again
yeah this should be fine
now let's select okay so that we have
the new uh field that is sales per
customer in our dimensions part
no no the measures part
yeah we have the new field in the
measures bar that is the sales for
customer now the next step is to use
this particular field
and generate the level of details
now we have the newly created field over
here
so that is basically the third part we
are going to do right now
now we are going to drag this and place
it into the rows
so we have two different bar charts now
the sales per customer and another
bar chart which is of sales now we are
going to select the sales per customer
and right click on it
now we have the drop down menu and
inside that we are going to select the
measure so we have the sum measure right
now as default now we are going to
change that into average
now we have the average sales per
customer according to regions so the
average sales per customer is 796.9
units
and that is in the central region next
we have the east region south and west
so that's how we use the include level
of detail expressions in table now we
are done with one example based on
include level of detail expression let's
try to execute another example
now we have the sheet 2 let's try to
rename it let's rename it include
lod
hyphen 2
now in this particular second lod
expressions we are going to
calculate the sum of sales on per state
basis
now let's move to the analysis button on
the menu bar
let's try to
select the create calculated field
option
now
let's try to write in the expression
name
average
sales
per state
now inside the
tray let's try to add the expression
include
state
now sum of sales
now let's try to close the flower
bracket
yeah now we have the valid expression
let's just select okay so that we find
the average sales per state option or
the newly created field in the measures
section
now let's drag the category into columns
and
the newly created average sales per
state into rows
and we have the level of detail
visualization on the screen right now
so the furniture is about 742 units
and the next one is the office which is
719 000 units and the last one is the 8
36 000 units
so this is the average sales happening
in particular categories so remember we
have three different categories in our
sales
superstore data set which is the
furniture office and technologies so
these are the
average sales happening
now with this we have the calculation
placed on rows shelf and it is
aggregated as an average but we still
have to find the sales happening by
state so with that we have the
calculation placed on the row shelf and
it is aggregated as an average so the
resulting visualization averages sum of
sales and by state across categories
now let's drag the segment option into
the columns
so when the segment is added to column
shelf and the calculation is moved to
label the lod expression results update
now you can see how the average sum of
sales per state varies across categories
and segments now we have all the bus in
one particular color let's try to change
it by dragging the
category into color so we have different
colors for different categories
now let's try to drag the average sales
per state into color so that we have
different colors
again
so this is how it works
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description
to know more
now with that let's move into the next
type of lod expressions that is the
exclude lod expressions in w
so the exclude level of detail
expressions declare dimensions to omit
from the view level of detail
exclude level of detail expressions are
useful for percent of total or
difference from overall average
scenarios
they are comparable to such features as
totals and reference lines exclude level
of detail expressions cannot be used in
row level expressions where there are no
dimensions to omit but it can be used to
modify either a view level calculation
or anything between that is you can use
an exclude calculation to remove
dimensions from some other level of
detail expressions so to understand
exclude level of detail expressions in
tableau in a much more detailed way
let's get back to w and try to execute
some examples
now we are back on to tableau let's
create the exclude level of detail
expression example
so i'll be renaming the sheet exclude
lod
now we have created a new sheet and
rename that as exclude lod now this
particular sheet will be used to
calculate the level of details
which excludes the region from a
calculation of sum of sales now for that
let's try to create a new
calculated field for that let's select
the analysis select create calculated
field now let's rename this as exclude
region
now let's select okay
okay we didn't write the expression over
there
now
let's edit it and in the tray let's
write the expression
let's select exclude
and in that let's select region
then
let's write in this sum of
sales
let's close the flower bracket
now let's select okay
now we have the new field over here
which is the exclude region now we'll be
using this particular field to create a
new visualization on the screen
now let's drag the region
to columns
let's drag the sum of sales
now let's track the order
date to rows
now let's select the month
let's kind of change this chart to bar
chart
now this is more likely
good to view
now let's drag the
newly created field that is exclude
region onto color
so that we can have different colors
now this particular step will help us to
view the total sales by month without
the regional component
so this is how the exclude level of
detail expressions will be used in real
time
now we can actually make a little change
to this by selecting this one and right
click it or we can go to colors directly
and right click the colors
and select the edit colors and inside
this we're gonna select
kind of
orange to blue
orange to blue diverging
so that we can have a good level of
visualization
now let's move on to the next type of
ello d expressions in tableau which
happens to be the fixed level of detail
expressions
so the fixed level of detail expressions
compute a value using the specified
dimensions without reference to the
dimensions in the view
now let's get back to tableau and try to
execute an example based on fixed level
of detail expressions in w
now we are back on tableau let's create
a new sheet and rename that sheet as
fixed lod
let's type an enter
yeah
now let's get back to the analysis menu
let's create a calculated field
let's rename this as sales by region
so we have the sales by region over here
now let's get back to the tray and try
to add in our
expression
so we shall be using a fixed expression
over here
fixed
and
now let's type in region
then
sum of sales
let's close the flow bracket now the
expression is valid so we have the sales
by region lod which is the fixed lod
let's select ok and you can see the
newly created field on the measures
section
let's drag the region onto rows and then
let's drag the state into the region of
rows
so now we have a text table
now the view level of the detail is
region plus state but because fixed
level of detail expressions do not
consider view level of detail the
calculation only uses the dimension
reference in the calculation which in
this case is region so because of this
you can see that the values of the
individual states in each region are
identical
if the include keyword has been used in
the level of detail expression instead
of fixed the values would have been a
little different for each state biggest
w would add the dimension in the
expression that is the region with any
additional dimensions in the view state
when determining values for the
expression
now with this let's get back to the
presentation again
so the next segment in this particular
today for our discussion is the tables
versus lod expressions
so now we'll be discussing the
differences between the tables and lod
expressions so the first one is filters
filters involved in table calculate
behave like height and filters involved
in lod calculations behave like exclude
the next difference is
table calculations are generated as
query results whereas the lod
expressions are generated as a part of
query to the underlying data source the
third difference is stable calculations
are capable to generate either equal or
less granule than the set lod or level
of detail but whereas on the lod
expressions case the level of detail
expressions can generate results
independent of the set level of detail
the fourth difference between the both
is
table calculations are used as
aggregated measures whereas the level of
detail expressions can be used in other
constructs the final differences between
the table and lod expressions as the
dimensions that control the operations
of a table are separate from the
calculation syntax whereas in the lod
expressions dimensions that control the
operations of an lod are embedded into
the expression itself
now with that let's continue with the
next part of this particular tutorial
where we will be discussing the
limitations of lod expressions in
tableau
so following are the limitations of lod
expressions in tableau so the first one
is lod expressions behave unreliable
views when floating values are involved
so lod expressions that reference
floating point measures tend to behave
in an unreliable fashion when used in a
view that requires a comparison of the
values in the expression
the next one is lod expressions will not
be shown in the data source
so the lod expressions will not be
available in the data source page when
you are using them in real time followed
by that the next limitation is you
should always keep in mind when
referencing a parameter in a
dimensionality declaration
always use the parameter name and not
the parameter value
followed by that the next limitation of
lod expressions in tableau is with data
blending the linking field from the
primary data source must be in the view
before you can use an lod expression
from the secondary data source today we
will be building dashboards from start
to finish first about world population
then health next we'll build a dashboard
about economy and finally we'll build a
dashboard about business ease i would
recommend getting access to the data set
before you start this tutorial so you
can build along with me if you would
like access to this data set please
comment below and we'll get you access
so first we're going to build a
dashboard that revolves around
population so we're going to build
a map based on country so i'm going to
double click on country and it's going
to map out all the countries and then on
our marks i'm going to change it to map
so it's a filled in map and we want this
to be colored by population total
and we can see
who contributes the most to population
we're going to label it with population
as well
but you can see that it's labeling it
the total population and what we want to
label it is
how much it contributes to population by
percentage so let's add a table
calculation and we're going to have it
do percent of total
based on country
okay so now we can see which countries
contribute what percent
let's also bring the country name onto
the label
and
let's put it on top so country names on
top now it's getting a little bit of
crowded in here so
we're going to un click show marks label
and we're just going to show the ones
that
we want to see specifically so we can
right click on china here hover on mark
label and click always show
and on india
since these are our two biggest
contributors
we can see that this one's a little bit
darker than the others in that area
and here
here and that's just a manual way to
choose which ones have indicators labels
and which ones do not
and we're going to put a note here so
we're going to annotate
an
area that explains that
china and india
contribute the most to world population
just calling out
this section of the visualization
and let's name this sheet
so here we have our visualization and
when you hover you can see both the
total population and its percent
contribution and the country name
our next visualization for this
dashboard is going to be
population over time
so
let's bring on our time element but one
trick for bringing on a time element if
we just drag it on so year with the
calendar mark here if we just drag it on
it'll default
to
a discrete version so let's take it back
off
and then we could edit it there but one
thing you could do is if you on
a windows machine you right click on it
and drag it on then it will pop up
with the dialog box that allows you to
select what kind of
date value you want to use in the first
place so we're going to use year here
and now we have instead of discrete we
have a continuous axis
and we're going to bring on
population total
and we can see that over time
one thing you can do when the value is
up so high
in your axis is you can uncheck this box
that says include zero and it will
not always include zero on your axis but
this can be misleading so you can see
that it looks like population growth is
something really dramatic by increasing
that slope of the y
whereas it really wasn't quite as
dramatic as it seems so as long as it's
communicated
well and you're not doing it to
mislead your users
you just need to keep in mind that this
includes zero can change what your graph
is saying so we're going to
not include the zero at this time
just so that we can focus in on our data
a little bit
now we're going to add our forecast so
we're gonna click on forecast and drag
it on
and it adds the forecast to our
visualization right there and now we can
right click here
and see forecast result is
actual and forecast
so you can see that the forecast picks
up
here in 2012 and pushes out what it
thinks it'll be in 2013 as well you can
change how far out that forecast goes by
right clicking on the line and clicking
forecast option
and we can change this is automatically
the next two years but we could change
it so that it's the next 10 years and it
will go out into the future
out to 2022
you can change prediction intervals or
if you don't want to show them you don't
have to show them and this is just kind
of
a visual guide for those prediction
intervals
okay and then you can also
have your trend lines show
where it shows your trend line following
out from where your population growth is
and also the trend line for your
forecast right there
and we'll call this
world population
trend
excellent and we're going to make one
more visualization for this and it's
going to be a pie chart so the pie chart
is also going to be based off of
population
so we're going to click on population
and we're going to control click on
country and come over to show me and
click your pie chart
great so i'm going to make this
the entire view so we can see the pie
chart better
and this is getting really crazy in here
and so i have changed my mind and
instead of country i'm going to drag
region over top of country and now we
see something a little bit more
manageable so we can see that here's
asia
and it makes up
the biggest piece of the pie and then
here is everybody else so right now
each of these is population total
and we could keep it that way or we
could
do what we did last time
and change it to percent of total
so that on hover we can see
the population
and
the percentage of population that it
contributes
so for this pie chart we're just going
to
show asia versus everybody else so we
need to make a group and what we'll do
is
select all of these
and we're going to right click and click
group
so now we have all those things we
selected and we have other let's edit
our group right click edit group
we're going to
rename this group
asia because
that's all that's in there and we're
going to rename this group
rest of the world
okay
so now we have our group we can drag it
onto label and we can see asia and rest
of the world and now see how it's
breaking it up into those different
sections that's because we still have
region on
our
detail right here so we pull region off
now let's just split asia rest of the
world
we can change our colors
make it a little bit more
visually interesting
now we can still see our percentages
and now let's rename it and then we'll
put it all together on a dashboard
great so let's make our dashboard we
have this new dashboard button down here
and you can choose what sizes you want
so we have a fixed size where you just
select the width and height we have
automatic which will just fill your
screen
and
we have a range which has a minimum size
and a maximum size
some of the
good things about fixed is that once you
have it you can have it always look that
way so no matter where they're looking
at it you know that it's going to be
laid out the way that you expected
however if somebody's looking out on a
screen that is bigger or smaller than
yours then it doesn't fill up the screen
or it will fill the screen too much and
they'll have to scroll up and down and
left and right
if you have automatic then it will fit
the screen that it's displayed on
however
the things that you've placed might get
squished too close together
and then the range gives you a minimum
size and a maximum size meaning if the
screen is too big
it still won't fill up the screen but it
can get closer and then as they get
smaller and smaller screens
you at least know that it will never
make it get smaller than this particular
size so there are some benefits to that
as well where you still have a little
bit of control of what it will look like
at the end
great let's bring on our worksheets
and you can see that where you hover
it fills up that space and that's where
it's going to show up you can also
adjust the lines in between different
visualizations for things that need more
space or less space
another important thing to recognize is
that when you click on a visualization
like this one up here it will tell you
how it's viewing that visualization
within that space so if you click
standard then it will do a standard fit
versus if you have
entire view where it will
make it fit into inside the box over
here we could have fit width
or fit height
on some of the visualizations it doesn't
make as much of a difference however
when you have a visualization that maybe
has a lot of text in it and they need to
be able to scroll you'll want to have it
fit width but you don't want it to fit
height because then it will shove all of
that information
into the box and not allow you to scroll
up and down
so if you saw as we dragged these on it
took
these
legends and added it to the left here
we can modify that
and make them floating
and drag them next to the visualizations
that they
are relevant to
and
this particular one
has a couple of things wrong with it we
might not want the title of this to be
region group
so we could come in and we could edit
the title and then
maybe just call it region
however i don't think we need this
legend at all because it's very clearly
marked on the visualization there so you
could also just remove it from the
dashboard
and this one
is telling you how big of a circle
it would need to be before it gets to
that population number so
it belongs to this circle as well but
again
is unnecessary potentially because we
have our two population numbers
showing up right as we hover
so we'll remove that as well so at this
point we have a visualization or three
visualizations all on the same page
which is the basics of a dashboard
however we might want to be able to
interact with them a little bit more
than just hovering
and so this is where we should look into
adding filters so we have information
over time we have information by country
and we have some information by region
here
one of the quickest things you can do to
add functionality to the dashboard is by
clicking this uses filter button so if
we click this that means whatever
country we click on here
will filter the other visualization
and then you can unselect it
to go back
now
that
uses filter button
actually creates an action here
filter one generated that it's made on
its own now you can see that when we
click on
china
it doesn't make a lot of sense to have
this pie chart update based on that
china click because it's just going to
show
duplicated information so it shows the
twenty percent or the twenty percent
here and the seventeen
billion
and then here it does the same thing
except for it shows a hundred percent
because it's filtered everything else
out of the chart so it now makes up one
hundred percent of the circle so that
doesn't make a lot of sense
so there are ways to
format your visualization or your
actions
modify your actions so that they only
affect the things that make sense so we
can come here and click edit
we're going to call this country
action
and we want it to
use the population by country sheet and
then modify
only the trend
so now when we click on
china we see china's trend over time and
it doesn't affect our pie because that
doesn't make sense for it to affect our
pie
we might want to select on our pie
asia or rest of the world and have that
affect the other visualization so we can
click use this filter here and click
asia and now it zooms into asia on our
map and shows us just the asia world
population trend and here's rest of the
world and we can see that asia is grayed
out
and there's the rest of the world and
here's the rest of the world population
trend
we might also want to be able to use
this to filter to a certain year
so if we click use filter
then we click on
you can see these numbers are slightly
updating so this is 19
and we come here 19.5 percent
come down here and we can see that the
pi updates a little bit although it
hasn't been anything dramatic
you can kind of see it over time
so that's one way
to add filters to your visualization
another way
is to use actual filtering instead of
just actions so if we come back here to
our trend
we could take the year we're going to
control click and drag it onto filters
and now we have a year filter so we
could have it the actual year number so
just look at one year at a time
or a range of dates
so if we click range of dates that makes
this slider
from 2000 to 2012. so if we hit ok
we'll right click and we'll click show
filter we can see it here and as we drag
this
it updates
but kind of messes with our forecast
so let's not do a year filter
in this case
so we clicked remove filter there
but maybe we want a filter just on this
for the different years
so let's drag year on to the filters
we're just going to do the year number
next and here's all the years we're
going to let all of them be selected for
now
and then we're going to show the filter
and here's all of our years
and we can change the way that our quick
filter shows up
and we can make it like a drop down so
they can still select multiples but it's
a drop down or maybe we want this
visualization to be just one year at a
time so we can choose single value in a
list and it lists out all the years or
in a drop down
and we want it to be 2012
and
then we want this to show up on our
dashboard so we come to the dashboard
and we click more options here hover
over filters and we can see the filters
available and we can click year of year
and now our formatting hasn't passed on
so that's one thing to remember that
formatting it just on the workbook
doesn't necessarily mean that the
formatting will pass over to the
dashboard so i tend to not do any
formatting on the workbooks and just
format it on the dashboards because the
dashboards are what i publish
so we're in a single value drop down
we're going to
[Music]
add it we're going to move it to the top
so now how we do that
let's talk a little bit about what each
of these sections are
come here to layout
and you can see we have this layout here
item hierarchy so tiled is the whole
screen and inside of that we have a
horizontal
container
and inside this horizontal container
we have another horizontal container and
when you click on something in this view
it shows you where it exists
so we can see this horizontal container
is outlined now and then we change it to
vertical and it outlines this now a
horizontal container allows things to be
side by side
and a vertical container allows things
to be a one on top of the other and so
in our vertical container we see all
this extra space for extra things to be
on top of each other but if we wanted to
have it at the top
we would maybe want things to be able to
be side by side so if we go back to the
dashboard and we grab horizontal and
drag it to the top
it adds a horizontal container up here
and now you can see everything that's
floating kind of stays in the place that
it was
even though all the other things shifted
that's one of the disadvantages of
floating is that you're kind of just
manually choosing
where it will stand
using your x and y position
and it's not dynamic
so let's give us a little bit less space
up here
we can add a text box into
our horizontal container
and we will say
population dashboard
we can format it
now we have our title up here and then
we can add our filter
we're going to drag it to be on
inside of our horizontal container but
on the
side here
you can give it more or less space
let's bring
our legends down to places where they
make sense again
perfect
and so now
we have this
that will affect this
only
and show you just 2012
2011 2010. so we don't want it to affect
the trend because we want the trend to
show
all of time and just looking at one year
for this trend that is only at a yearly
part and forecasts into the future
doesn't make any sense but we maybe
wanted to also affect this worksheet so
that these two are in sync
and so the dashboard is basically for
2012 except for the trend which shows
you the past in the future so one way
that you can do that is clicking apply
to worksheets here
and you can choose selected worksheets
and it will show you all the worksheets
in this visualization
or in this dashboard and you can click
show all worksheets in workbook and then
if there were other worksheets it would
show them
so we wanted to do asia versus rest of
the world and population contribution by
country
okay and that's another way we can
change what year they show so it's only
going to show one year at a time
unless we select all
and then this visualization isn't
affected by it
if we don't want
to
click on a country and have it
make the change if we instead want to
have a filter for country we can do that
by taking country and dragging it onto
filters we'll have it show all for now
and then when we go back to our
dashboard and we come to this
visualization we can go filters and add
country
and it's just added it side by side
where we had our other filters so that's
a nice
feature of tableau where it can kind of
guess where you might want things we're
going to do multiple value drop down
and right now
it only affects that visualization and
we can just look at one country at a
time
and we might not want it to affect this
visualization because it doesn't do us
any good to just look at one region in a
pie chart
but maybe we wanted to affect the world
population trend so we can do the same
thing we did before
and we wanted to affect these two
we'll click ok
and so now
we could look at
all these countries
and that would update both these
visualizations
another thing i like to do
on a filter is customize and click show
apply button and this means we can make
all these changes in here
see i've selected none however these
visualizations aren't updating and then
i wanted to look at turkey so i found
turkey and then i hit apply and that's
when they update
perfect so now we have a dashboard
complete with filters and
actions
we also have a title on our dashboard we
can give it a little bit less space and
some legends
we have titles on each of these pieces
however if we didn't want a title here
we can click hide title and it will just
show our visualization there and this is
dashboard number one
here's what it looks like in full screen
mode full screen mode is a good
opportunity for you to test it to see
what it will look like to the end user i
press escape and get back out
and it doesn't give you these highlights
when you hover over things that are
dashboard formatting related
you can see that all those extra lines
went away
and it just gives you the opportunity to
test out your dashboard in a more real
way
and see how they will use it
instead of giving you the dashboard
editing options
next we're going to make a dashboard
revolving around health information
so first we're going to make
a map
about birth rates so we're going to call
it
birth rate
rank
and to make a map we're going to double
click on country
and
we're going to change it to a map type
so we have a filled map here and then
we're going to bring birth rate on to
color
so let's define our colors a little bit
by clicking on this color part of the
marks card we'll click edit colors and
we're going to change it
to
red and gold
and the idea here is that the red is for
a higher birth rate which is
more associated with countries that have
poor health so we'll hit apply
and now we have our
higher birth rate countries highlighted
in red next we're going to create
a class so we're going to duplicate
birth rate
and let's edit that field
we're going to call it birth rate class
and so we're going to say that anything
that is in the top 50 countries
with the highest birth rate is
categorized as having
an alarming birth rate so we will
first do the average
birth rate
and then we're going to
do a rank
on that
do you see sometimes
when you're auto completing your
statements
it will replace
one of these functions that you have
with the one that you pressed tab for so
if i type if or i start to type if and
then i come here and click on if it
replaced my rank with if so keep an eye
out for that if you're like where did my
thing go it's because i was typing it
right next to it so if i put a space and
then i start to type if and i click if
it will not delete rank so we're going
to say if
the rank of average is
less than or equal to
50 so if it's in the top 50
then
alarming
birth rate
else if
and we can take this again
is greater than 50
then
normal or 3.
always make sure you put on the end also
we didn't necessarily have to have this
else if statement
so if we had just done else normal birth
rate that would have covered all of our
bases
so with these if statements just make
sure that you're always getting all the
different options
that you want but in this case
we defined both however we didn't have
to define the second calculation because
if it is not in the top 50 then it's
obviously in the bottom the rest
so we're going to hit ok
and then we're gonna put birth rate
class onto label
and it's gone around and labeled
everything
and i am seeing alarming birth rate on
so let's see what the problem is
so if we open this back up by right
clicking and clicking edit you can see
it says results are computed a long
table across
so we're going to click default table
calculation here and instead of compute
using automatic we're going to change it
to compute using
country we'll hit ok
and hit apply
and that didn't seem to fix it so this
is the first place i would look if it's
not doing what you would expect so
we'll put it back to automatic okay
the second place i would look is inside
of the table calculation that is created
so when we defined rank here we put a
table calculation on it so when we right
click here we get edit table calculation
and we're going to choose that we want
to do the rate based on
the specific dimension of country
so now we can see
using the logic
the calculation assistance that
we no longer have just alarming birth
rate we have normal birth rate and
alarming birth rate on our screen so we
can close this
and
we are done here but one thing you could
do
is
when we have allow labels to overlap
other marks selected then it will make
sure that
every label shows up but it gets super
crazy in there so there are some times
where the labels may overlap a little
bit and so you'll want to select this
option in our case we don't want that
and now we have a visualization
showing
birth rate map
based on rank our next visualization
is going to be about
average life expectancy
male versus female
so we're going to do
a chart across time so we're going to
click year and bring it on to columns
and we're going to change it to
this
year
in the continuous section so now we have
an axis
and
we're going to
double click on female life expectancy
up there we go double click on female
expectancy and then double click on male
life expectancy so what that did was
made us two charts one on top of the
other but we don't want that so we'll
take this off and we're going to drag
male life expectancy right onto this
axis for the female life expectancy
and what this has done is made what's
called a blended axis chart so it's not
a dual axis chart where we have another
axis over here
for the second visualization this one is
a blended axis chart so they necessarily
use the same axis and they necessarily
have the same kinds of marks so we'll
take a look and see what the difference
is there so if i were to change this to
a bar chart we would have
bar chart for both of them and i can't
define one separately from the other
change it back to a line chart
and they're both a line chart
now if we go back to
when we just had female life expectancy
and we drag
male on next to it and we have two
charts
now we can change it to a dual axis and
we have one on top of the other however
our axes don't line up we can see at the
top here is 15k and over here it's 14k
so we're going to synchronize the axis
and you can see
one on top of the other
and
we have two marks cards so we could have
this one be a bar chart and that would
be a line chart
so that's some of the differences of
those two we're going to do a blended
access chart so i'm going to take mail
and drag it here
and we have our blended access chart and
now you can see the our scale here
is really strange so what it's doing is
it's adding up all of the life
expectancies for all the different
countries instead of averaging it so
we're going to change that by right
clicking on the measure down in this
measure values card hovering over
measure sum and we're going to change it
to average
since i only changed one of them and
they share the same axes it's really
spread out now and it almost looks like
a straight line down there and then
let's change the other
and it should get everything a little
bit more
in sync there we go so now we can see
the average life expectancy over time
which for both of them seems to be going
up
however
it seems to be higher
for females
now let's take a look at our analytics
and let's
drag on forecast
so it's forecasted out the next two
years for both line
and we'll bring on trend
onto linear
and let's change it
to a square so now we see
each individual point for the life
expectancy for females and males and we
can see what they're expected to be in
the future
and our trends
and our next visualization
is going to be a heat map
about
multiple different
measures so we'll just call it a heat
map for now
and for our heat map we're going to look
at the different countries so we'll
bring country onto rows and we're going
to look at
their
birth rate
so i just double clicked on birth rate
and brought it on we're going to look at
their health expenditure percentage on
gdp so how much they spend on
gdp
so when i double clicked on it it did
what we did before where we have a
measures value card and so now whenever
we put measures on here that determines
what goes here because we have our
measure names on columns so every
measure in here their name is going to
define the name of the column and the
values
define
what's in the text right here
great we're also going to bring on
infant mortality rate
and
the life expectancy for females
okay
so now it has
changed these to not have decimal points
after them which is not as helpful so
we're going to
format those
and you can format it field by field so
for birth rate
we definitely want to have
decimals afterwards as a matter of fact
the birth rate is a percentage so
instead of doing a number standard we'll
just go to percentage
and now we don't need to have those
decimals afterwards we can just look at
the birth rate as a rate
and
for
percent of gdp for health expenditures
we can come click there and do the same
thing
and for infant mortality rate
okay
and to make this make a little bit more
sense we again need to change it from a
sum
to an average
and for some of these
we could
change it from a sum to an average right
inside of
the
for all of these we could change it from
a sum to an average in the default
properties
under aggregation
so it will automatically average it
whenever we bring it out
default is sum
but if we make it automatically average
then we won't have to do that again for
any other visualizations
i won't do that at this time because i
get a little bit confused sometimes when
i don't have my sum on there by default
because that's what i'm so used to
seeing by default great so we now have
a matrix
by country and by our different metrics
here and so we can
take our measure values
and drag it onto color
and we'll make our marks from automatic
to square
and it will make our heat map
now what happens with a heat map
is it colors darkly
the higher the number it is in this case
and
right now it's doing it for the whole
area so one percent is obviously much
much smaller than 82 but if we wanted to
be able to look at birth rate
independently from life expectancy we
can right click on the measure values on
the color and click use separate legends
and so now we have a legend
for each one of these let's change the
colors on those legends so that we can
see them separately a little bit more
clearly
so we'll change the colors by coming
over here to each of the legends
and we'll leave one the same
but we'll change this one
and if we click edit colors you can see
our different palettes
you can see some of them just have one
color others have one color to another
color we used the
red gold before
so now you can see that one is changed
we could use
another one that goes from
green to blue
great
you can also define your own
so you can make a custom one that could
go from
light to dark and then you can choose
what color you want as your dark color
so we could pick
a lighter blue
and then we see that last one
and now with these separate color
palettes you can quickly see the
difference with birth rate and
spending on health
and that is our heat map
with
separate legends
so let's build this all into a dashboard
now
we're going to call it our health
dashboard
and for simplicity we're going to make
it automatic so it fills our screen
and then we're going to first bring on
our map
we're going to bring on our health
related map with birth rates
then we're going to bring on our
heat map
and we'll bring on our life expectancy
lines
now as we brought on all of our charts
it brought in our legends here
and we're going to move our legends up
to the top so let's add a horizontal
container
and then let's put
our legends
into the horizontal container
and um let's put these ones in order so
life expectancy
oh
so birth rate is going to be over here
great now
one thing we can do is make these
smaller
well that's actually just making that
one bigger huh okay
so it would make them smaller
by making something else bigger or by
adding in a blank space
which would then
help you adjust the size
by taking up the space that you're not
using
another thing to pay attention to is
this fixed width
so once you start to drag the size on
something it no longer is dynamic
so if we unfix that width
so that it's only taking up whatever
space is left oh and that one is not
fixed with
and then we can edit the width on this
to be
even bigger
then it will squish things over to where
we would like them to be so
that's one of the ways you can add space
or make things the size you would like
them to be
now let's take a look at filters oh
before we take a look at filters i want
to look at this map one more time
because i think that it would be useful
for our colors to be
a little bit more
distinct
so
one quick way to navigate to your
worksheet from your dashboard is to
click this go to sheet button
and while we're here i'm going to click
on color
edit colors and we did red and gold and
we're going to change it from
this sequence to a stepped color
and we're going to change it to three
colors so it's going to either be
this color this color this color and
when i hit ok
you can kind of see it's a little bit
more dramatic
in our differences and it's put
everything into the three categories we
defined so let's go back to our
dashboard
and we can see the difference there
and now we're going to take a look at
our filters so we want to be able to
filter by country
so let's bring country onto filters
now we're going to allow it to use all
and we're going to
here you can click apply to worksheets
and you can click selected worksheets
and it's going to pop up with all the
worksheets
in the whole workbook
and so one disadvantage of doing it on
the worksheet is that you can see all of
the worksheets in the workbook and you
have to differentiate between which ones
are on the dashboard and which ones
aren't and these are the three on this
dashboard so we're going to hit ok
and we're also going to do it by year so
when we drag the year onto filters
we're going to
allow them to
choose years so we're going to do
the distinct number of years we'll click
use all
okay
and we're going to apply to the
worksheets
this one with the birth rate and the
average life expectancy male versus
female we're not going to filter down
our line chart by year
because we want to be able to see it
over time and if we filter down the time
then we don't get as much context so
we'll hit ok
let's go back to our dashboard
if i click on more options here and
hover over filters you can see that year
filter and that country filter
you should also be able to see both of
those filters on the heat map
because i told it to apply to that one
as well so here's the country oh
i made a mistake let's go back to this
visualization
and apply to worksheets
selected worksheets
see i wanted it to be on the birth rate
and the heat map not the line chart and
i clicked the wrong one
so that was a good test
so when we go here to the heat map
and click down
you can see now
we get the year of year as well so we'll
click year of year let's put it over
here
and we're going to make it
a multiple values drop down and we'll
bring it over
to the middle
and let's also
get the countries filter
great so now that we have these in here
we don't need this to be so big so let's
edit the width
and make it
even smaller
great and let's change our country
to be
a single value drop down so you can pick
one at a time and let's also change it
or this year of year since we can select
multiples let's change it so that
on customize that you show the apply
button
so here since they can only select one
we don't have the apply button because
it will just automatically apply
and here since they can select multiples
we'll let them unselect all and pick
their years
and then hit apply and then you'll see
the changes
and you can see that even though i've
selected only 2011 and 2012 you still
see all the years on this line chart as
expected
and there
is our health dashboard
our next dashboard is going to have to
do with economy
our first sheet is going to be another
map that is going to have to do with
overall gdp
and
as we usually begin with maps by double
clicking on country
and changing it to a map mark type
and this time we're going to bring on
gdp onto color
and change it to average
and we can edit the colors
let's this time do
a custom diverging so you get to pick
both colors
and let's pick
a little bit lighter
hmm
okay red for there and then we want to
do maybe like a deeper
green
and that way
you can see who has the highest gdp
which is green
we hit apply
okay
and then it will
eventually get lighter and lighter until
it goes to gray which then it will lead
to green
okay
and next we're going to make
scatter plot
which we will call
gdp versus gdp per capita
so
gdp or gross domestic product versus
gross domestic product per capita or per
person
and to make a scatter plot
you have one
measure on one axis and then another
measure which is going to be
gdp per capita which we will now create
on the other axis
so let's start with gdp and we'll hit
duplicate
and let's edit that and we're going to
call it
gdp
per capita
and we're going to take
some
of gdp
and divided by the sum
of the total
population
population total
what is my error
opening parenthesis
there we go
and then we have gdp per capita so let's
what this will do is sum up the gdp
across whatever measures we have in
place go across whatever dimensions we
have in place and then sum up the
population for those same dimensions and
then divide it instead of dividing it
per row
and then
doing an aggregation on it
okay
so now we're going to bring on gdp per
capita on the rows
and we have the sum of gdp and the gdp
per capita and to make it more than just
one
little mark on our scatter plot we will
drag on country to detail and now we
have one mark per country
and you can see some countries have
a high gdp per capita
and some countries have a high gdp
overall but not as high of a gdp per
capita
and so on we have some middle of the
road people here so we can change this
from automatic
to circles and now they're
dots like you might see on scatter plot
and
you can
drag region
onto
color
and now we can see our different regions
and see we see a lot of reds here
and
um it's quick to see
what region things belong in also you
can click to highlight and you can see
all of the americas highlighted in
context
the next visualization we're going to
make
is going to be
showing how much countries spend on
health care
as a part of their gdp so
we're going to rename it
to be gdp on healthcare
and we're going to look at each of our
countries
and we're going to make a bar chart
that shows
the health expense gdp
and we're going to change this to
average
and we're also going to show
the health expense per capita
over here it shows how much is spent per
person on health
and this
is showing how much
is spent on health
based on gdp
click at the top and click sort and it's
sorting by this first one
and you can see which countries spend
the most of their gdp on health
we can again bring region under color
so we can see the different
regions
highlighted
and
let's bring on labels so
for our different marks cards
we're going to want to control click
this
and drag it onto the labels and we can
see that it's a percentage but it's
coming up as a number so
we can right click and click
format right there
and
we're going to change the number to
percentage
maybe just do one decimal place
and then for this one
we're going to control
and drag
that onto labels
and maybe we'll change this one to
currency
however if you don't want to change it
to currency
since we aren't sure
necessarily what currency this data set
is in
it's worth checking out
what currency it is in
so for now we'll just have it as a
number
and now we're going to
customize our tool tip
so we're going to go to the overall
marks card
and we'll click on tool tip and we want
it to tell us the country in the top so
a race region
and we're going to
erase country label and center country
and then we're going to put
this
country spends
this percentage
on
healthcare
and if you want to preview it you can
hover or click here on preview and it
will show you an example marshall island
spends 2.1 on healthcare we'll hit enter
and then when we hover
it tells you the country and it has our
custom tool tip on both visualizations
or on both of the different axes
so
let's build our dashboard
we'll bring on our map
we'll bring on our
healthcare
visualization
and our gdp versus gdp per capita
and we'll move our legends to the top
again
by adding a horizontal container to the
top
and bringing them up here
one thing we can do also
is to give this more space
we can have it go all the way to the top
and these legends are just side by side
just above the map and the jdp per
capita
scatter type plot
an interesting thing you can do in
tableau is you can see this outlier of
the united states is making it difficult
to see the rest of the information or to
visualize if there's any trend there
so you could right click on it and click
exclude
and then it will exclude it from your
data set very quickly
and then you'll just click this back
button to get it back
great now let's take a look at filters
we are going to do a single filter
so let's go to this visualization and
we'll bring on country
we'll click use all
okay now we're going to apply it to
worksheets so i showed you how we can
apply it to worksheets here
you can also apply to worksheets once
it's on the dashboard so if we come here
and look at filters we can see the
countries on the filters for this
visualization
but if we come down here
and look at filters
we still see country because it's in the
details of the information so
either way when we add country
since i added it from this visualization
it only affects this visualization
okay
but we want it to affect all on the
worksheet
so we're going to apply to worksheets
and we can click selected worksheets and
we can click all on dashboard
okay
let's bring this over here we're going
to allow them to see all at once and be
able to scroll and select the ones they
want and now
when we select different ones it affects
all three worksheets
we're also going to add an action
for a url action add action go to url
and when we click on a country on the
overall gdp map we want it to take us to
the wikipedia page that talks about the
economy for that country
so that is
this url and it's going to say wikipedia
for economy of
and we're going to add our country to
the end
so we hit okay
we have it running on menu so let's
change it to run on select and as soon
as you click it it will take you there
okay so now let's try it and we can
click on
canada
and it will take us to the wikipedia
page for the economy of canada
great we click on brazil
same thing
so if we unselect on brazil then it will
make our map highlighted normally again
we can also use this one to filter the
other visualizations
and so we could click use this filter
here and then when we click on france
it will filter these two other
visualizations to france
you can see that when we filter this
visualization
to a particular country
so if we look at
germany
germany wasn't green before on our map
but now it is that happens because our
scale has changed just for the ones
selected
so if we control click france and
germany and switzerland
and austria we now have a scale that
reflects only these countries and the
biggest is going to be the darkest green
or the highest gdp is the darkest green
and the lowest is the lightest pink
and there is our economy dashboard you
can see that we have some nulls on these
visualizations that occurs when we don't
have all of the data
for every point
you can ignore those and they won't show
up on the final visualization
when you publish it to server or you can
deal with those by clicking on them and
filtering that data out or showing that
data at the default position which is
showing the null values at zero our
final dashboard is going to be about the
ease of doing business in a country so
our first visualization is going to be a
bar chart which we will call days to
start
business
so how many days it takes to start a
business is important to know when
you're trying to start a business in a
country and also can be an indicator of
how easy it will be to do business in
that country so
let's make a bar chart that includes
every country and then we're going to
bring on days to start a
and we will sort it smallest to biggest
and we have some days
or some countries that don't have
any days so let's filter out those
countries
and we're going to
filter it to only those that have a good
market
we're going to make a calculated field
we're going to define business friendly
market
well
we're going to define our market based
on how easy it is to start a business
and how many days it takes so
if it takes less than 25 days to start a
business we'll consider that a good
market and so we're going to do
if
the days to start a business is less
than or equal to 25
then
elsif
space to start a business
is
greater than
then
business
might or might not
work
doing less than or equal to 25 or
greater than 25
allows us to be able to define these two
different markets so we'll hit
apply there
and we're going to filter it
just to a good market
and we're going to look at
just one year
look at 2012.
our most recent year
and we're going to color it based on
region
and we can see
which regions tend to have
the shorter days to start a business
and we're going to
move on and build our next visualization
which is also a bar chart
which we will call ease of business
so we have this ease of business field
and we can bring on the country and we
can bring on ease of business
and we want to
make it a measure so the ease of
business is at this point looking at it
like it's
a string
and we can change that in our default
properties and convert it to a measure
or use up here and change it to a
measure
when we try to change it to a measure
here it wants to treat it like a string
so it wants to take the minimum or the
maximum
but if we here convert it to a measure
then it also automatically made it a
count
so the first thing to do
would be to change the data type to a
number
and now
we can change it to a measure and
aggregate it so we could do
like the sum of ease of business
in our use case we're actually going to
do the
average of ease of business
and then we want to have the smallest on
the top
we do have some that don't have ease of
business ratings
so we're going to filter that data out
and again we want the year to be 2012
but how we're going to do that is by
coming to this visualization
and by applying this particular year of
2012 so we'll do it on select workbooks
and select ease of business okay
and now this one also has
the year of 2012 there
and
we're going to
segment this by creating another header
we're going to call that
business
friendly
and we're going to say
that if the ease of business
is
so i guess this is a nice thing to know
so if if we start typing in what we want
to see then we can select it from a list
here but you can also interact outside
of this box so you could just grab ease
of business and drag it into the dialog
box here and that's really nice so we're
going to say if it is greater than or
equal to 1
and less than or equal to
then
we're going to say it has the most
business
friendly
regulations
give us a little more room to look at
okay and this statement won't work
because it's saying and what is less
than or equal to three so you have to
have ease of business in both places
and then this should say then and not
the
great so now we're just getting an error
because we don't have an end
so if that's all we wanted to do then
that's what we would do but then we'll
just do another else if
and it's already taken this
if statement goes through
one condition at a time so it's already
classified everything that's between
these two numbers and so
now we can just say
if ease of business
is
less than or equal to 10
then
we'll call it very
very business friendly regulations
we'll keep going
else if ease of business is
less than or equal to 50
then
we're going to call it
moderate
and we're just going to say moderate
business
regulations
copy that for later use
less than equal to 150
then
strict
so
the reason that this doesn't grab
everything that is less than or equal to
150 is because
these sections 1 to 3 and then 3 or well
4 to 10
and then 11 to 50 have all been
classified up to this point so it's just
getting everything else
and we're going to finally
say else everything else
is going to be called
not preferred
for
business
and see if we get any errors calculation
is valid let's see if this works as we
expect so we'll hit apply and we'll
bring business friendly onto our rows
and now it categorizes everything
based on what we said so
we want to define what order these go in
so we're going to click sort
and we want the
most business friendly at the top
then we want moderate then strict then
not preferred okay
so we have our top three that are the
most business friendly and then we've
got four through ten which are very then
we've got our moderate
are strict
and are
not preferred
so let's bring region again onto color
and we can see which regions are the
most business friendly
and we have our year of 2012 there
and now we're going to make this even
more useful by adding the business tax
rate onto the label
so that you can see that business
friendly
is like singapore but they have a pretty
high tax rate of 27 whereas if you get
down to some of these
that are not preferred
some of them have really low tax rates
so let's make sure that we're getting
okay the right tax rate
so
you can see that
27 is definitely not the highest tax
rate that we have for business
but you can also see that there are
places that have
even lower tax rates
like saudi arabia
and we have
eight percent here
it looks like we don't ever go to
that second decimal place so let's
quickly
format this
oh
business tax rate is also text
so if we could convert
our data type to
decimal
and then we will
format it
to be
a percentage
and we just need the one decimal place
okay
now let's make
some annotations so we could come and
click here
on this mark
and then we can annotate that mark which
will make this dialog box and it's
already filled in here
and so we could
use some of this information so i'm
going to copy that
and i'll put some hard returns there
so we're going to say
that this country
is the most
business friendly
but has a
business tax rate
of and let's grab the tax rate
and then we'll erase this
and we'll hit okay
and i've made a typo
so singapore is the most business friend
is not what i meant to say
so i can click edit
business friendly
but has a tax rate of and you can move
this around
draws the line to singapore which is the
mark
that we wanted to annotate so that is an
annotation on a mark if we wanted to
just make an annotation for the area
then we could
point out that
more business friendly
countries
often have
high
business taxes
i could change that size make everything
fit
now we have this
second note
where our user can come in and see some
more information about what's being
presented here
great and now we're going to make one
more visualization
and it's going to be
about phone and internet usage
because you may want to know about the
phone and internet trends
when you're looking to start a business
so we're going to do this one over time
so it does not need to have that year
filter on it
and we're doing our continuous our
access
and we're going to
look at mobile phone usage so i double
clicked it it shows mobile phone usage
over time
and we're going to change it to average
so that it's averaging it across the
countries
and then we're going to bring on
internet usage so we'll bring it on side
by side so we have two visualizations
and we're going to
also make that average
now we might not want these to share an
axis because they are measured a little
bit differently
and so we can make it a dual axis
but allow them to keep their independent
axes
or you can synchronize the axes
and see them at their
rates however
the uses is just a little bit
of a different measurement we can have
one of them be
a bar chart and the other one be a line
let's have this one be the bar chart
okay and then the line is in the front
you can also change which one's in the
front by
coming and clicking
on the axis itself
and you can click move marks to front
and that move for that one to the front
okay and now it's made each of these
wide and there's like a star point and
end point on the axis for the bar and
that comes here under size
where they're all fixed
or you could have it be manual where we
can define the size of the bars so we're
going to make those bars like this
now we can see them going up over time
we can also change the width of the line
itself
make it thicker or thinner
and
we can change the colors here
so let's change it to
orange
since red might apply that it's bad
in some cultures
and now we can see our internet usage
and our phone usage over time and how
it's trending
and so this will all come together on
our new dashboard
which is about
ease of business
you can see that i have a sheet called
these as a business and a dashboard that
i've called ease of business but it
won't let you
create a dashboard with the same name
as your worksheet so
ease of business dashboard
let's have it fit the screen
and
we're going to bring on our
days to start business
visual our ease of business visual
and our
phone and internet visual
let's
put our legends at the top again
so we'll make
our horizontal
container
and we'll bring our region legend into
there and then our
measure names for internet versus
mobile phone
and we have a filter that already is
pre-applied to two of the visualizations
called year of year
and it's selected 2012 and if we select
it's only changing this one it's
filtering out all the information for
this visualization and changing this one
to
2011.
so let's see why that's happening if we
go to this visualization
and click the go to sheet
we can see year of 2012 is here let's
click show filter
and if we change the filter
to 2011. okay it's not showing up here
and the only filter i can see that could
be removing it is this averages of
business
that is removing anything that is null
so if i pull that off you can see that
we don't seem to have any information
for 2011 for ease of business
and the more years i select i'm not
seeing any
ease of business information
so
we're going to want to set this
to
2012 only because that seems to be the
only information that is useful for this
visualization
so
let's go back until we're back to the
state
we were in
when we started
okay so here we are
now we're going to want to remove this
filter
and we're going to give it its own
that only selects 2012
that is not connected to the other
filter
so now when we change your view it only
changes this visualization
sometimes that's useful to note
sometimes it's useful to put
let's do a single value
drop down sometimes it's useful to put
this
right next to the visualization it
affects
so if we could change it to floating
and just put it like
here
that makes it clear that
it's just changing this chart
so that people don't get confused
another thing that we can do that we
should do on all of our visualizations
is
change the titles so that they're more
business or user friendly
great
and
so we have our filter
and let's use this as a filter
and that way we can click on new zealand
and we can see it's the most business
friendly regulations and we can see its
internet
and phone usage over time
we can click on
a lot of different countries to see
those changes
you can see that
some countries have a steeper
change so some of them have
adopted phone and internet usage and
have stayed pretty similar whereas other
ones have only
really adopted it in the last couple of
years
also if we wanted to filter to just one
country we could do what we did before
and create a country filter
here's another way to go to the sheet
you can click this down arrow and click
go to sheet or you can come over here
you can see that it's highlighting a
visualization over here or a sheet and
whatever sheet i click on is highlighted
over here
and there's this little pop out arrow
here that also takes you to the sheet
now we can bring country
on
use them all
go back to our dashboard
we'll go to filters and select country
we'll make it a multiple value drop down
we're going to add the apply button and
now we're going to make it apply to all
the visualizations by
clicking apply to workbooks selected
worksheets all on dashboard okay
now we can see that if we just want to
look at afghanistan
okay
we can see
how many days it takes to start a
business there it's not preferred for
business and it's internet and phone
usage over time
and those are our
four dashboards so as a review we have
made
a dashboard on population
we made one about health we made one
that had to do with our economy
and one that had to do with our ease of
doing business
so today we'll be dealing with the
tableau project so the first data set
that we will be using for the tableau
project is based on covet 19 data
followed by that we'll have another
project based on the airline data and
finally the third project will be based
on space missions data
now let's begin with our first project
so in this first project we'll be
dealing with the covert 19 data set and
using that data set will be getting some
insights so what are those insights
those are what are the total number of
confirmed cases in different nations
what are the total number of recovered
cases in different nations so we'll be
using the map chart for these and we'll
be finding out the insights about how
are the cases going on in the current
situation or in the current date or year
followed by that we'll also look into
the insights of the confirmed and
recovered cases in india as well
followed by that we'll enter into the
next query where we'll find out the
trend line of covert 19 in the
international level like how it started
how is it going on
and moving forward we'll create a group
of indian states and we'll find out the
covert heads there and then we will
discuss about the death rates so highest
death rates at international level and
the least death rates in the
international level then we'll enter
into the next segment where we'll find
out the variation in covert 19 cases
around the world and then finally we'll
discuss the future of covert 19 in the
international level basically we'll
create a trend line which will give us
the forecast levels of the cover 19 like
is it going to increase or is it going
to decrease or what's going to happen in
the near future so i hope i made myself
clear with the queries or the insights
that we are going to take from the
coordinating data set using table u so
without further ado let's get started
with the w
so we are on tableau right now so we'll
be using an excel data file
so we'll be using the covert 19 data
file
so this particular data set is available
on kaggle and if you don't find it there
don't worry we'll be attaching that
particular data set in the description
box below you can use that as well now
let's just select open to get connected
with that particular data
so you can see that we just got
connected with that data and
there will be some
[Music]
minute errors in the data or there will
be some problem with the data which the
table you might identify and when it
identifies something messy with the data
it will show you an option
maybe you might want to use the data
interpreter so i prefer using that
so whenever i see that particular option
on the left hand side i better use it
for
the safer side for being for being on
safe aside with the data and let's also
select these
not a problem
yeah
so the data got clean now you can see
that over here so to do that you can
also check the
review results so when you click that
review results option then you'll get
into this particular excel document
which will help you with the changes
made to that data set so you can see
that the orange color one says the data
is interpreted as column headers or
field name and the green box suggests
you that data is interpreted as values
in your data source
and now you can see that
there you go
so now we'll get back to w now you can
see that uh the data has been
interpreted successfully by the w and
everything is
uh as expected by the table every every
data element in the data set is as
expected by the table and it's really
fine now now we'll check the columns
what we have in our data set right over
here
so we have the serial numbers
observation dates province state and the
country or region last update and
confirmed death recovered so basically
these three columns will be telling us
the confirmed cases in that particular
region country or state and the deaths
happen in that region country of state
and recovery rate and the last update
when was the last test done the latest
tested done and in which region and
what's the observation date what's the
observation results on that particular
date and the serial numbers etc etc
so we have the uh clear understanding of
a data set now let's get started with
the first sheet what we have over here
so according to our first query we had
to find out the total number of
confirmed cases in different nations
so for that we might want to select the
country or region and then
the confirmed from measures so for that
we'll be selecting the map chart for
this so that we have the data shown in a
more appealing format
so now we have the blue color of map on
our screen right now where the darkest
color shows the maximum number of
cases confirmed and the lighter ones
represent the lower number of cases
confirmed
now let's let's make this look a little
more interesting so for that we can
select the edit color options and inside
that let's select the
red to green
dye version
yeah this is it red to green white
divergent and
as you can see the colors are a little
opposite right now so we want the
greener one in the lower side
and
the red colored one on the higher side
this should be good so let's select okay
and apply
and okay
so you can see that the red color now
represents the highest number of cases
and a lighter red one here you can see
the a little touch of red which shows
that the india's got some
good amount of cases as well
and in the brazil and et cetera et
cetera so even russia
has a little light green so this shows
it it also has some good amount of cases
not not completely green though
yeah so this is how it looks now let's
rename the sheet
as confirmed cases
at the international level
now according to our second query
we are supposed to find the total number
of recovered cases in different nations
so now let's create a new sheet for that
now for that we'll be selecting the
country or region
and then we'll be selecting the
recovered and
hover over to the show me icon
and let's select the map for that
now you can see that we have a lot of
recovery happening in india so according
to the stats we get to hear that the
virus which we have in india is a little
you know kind of harmful than
comparatively what we had in china and
other states of the world or the other
nations of the world
so yeah we have a good recovery rate in
india
now let's rename the sheet as recovery
recovered cases
international level
so i'm naming these sheets separately
because we'll be using these sheets to
create a dashboard at the end
now let's get into the third query what
we have right now is find the total
number of confirmed cases in india and
what are the total number of recovered
cases in india so for that
let's create a new sheet and
let's select country or region and
confirmed
now we'll be selecting the
text table
and we have the complete data set right
now we have all the nations over here so
what we are looking for is just india
so for that now we'll drag the country
or region into filters
and inside this
you can see we have an option of
selecting india
now let's search for india
g h i
so we have india over here let's select
apply and okay so we have the total
number of cases in india now
we can drag the state of province into
rose
at all members
so in india we have all the states and
so all the states have their own
confirmed cases so this is the total
confirm state or confirm count in india
let's rename the sheet
confirmed
cases
in india
similarly let's find the recovery cases
let's create a new sheet for that
rename it as recovery
cases in india
so now let's select the country region
recovery
and then
let's close the show me icon and
now let's drag the contribution to
filters then
none select india
apply okay and
let's drag the state of province here
add all numbers
yeah so you have the
text chart here which represents the
total number of recovered cases in india
according to the state wise
now
yeah this looks okay but we can make it
look a little more appealing so that
it's it's more
you know visible and understandable
readable so we can make that happen so
let's make a duplicate of this
and recovery cases as well
now i would like to change the confirm
cases in india into a pie chart
which looks a little bit more readable
and understandable let's select the
entire view so that we have
a bigger pie chart and a little bit
understandable or readable let's
increase the
size a little bit and let's select the
label
and select the show mark label so that
we have all the
numbers over here we can even select the
province of state and drag it into
detail so we have the state's name as
well or
should we tag it into
label
yeah now the recovered enter label again
yeah there you go we have this state and
we have the confirm number over here
so this is how we can make the data look
a bit more appealing and understandable
so we can see that maharashtra has a
larger number of confirmed cases
it's the biggest state of india
so maybe yeah that's true and
now we'll get back to the duplicate
sheet of recovery cases in india and now
let's make it look a bit more appealing
by changing the way the data looks so
for this we can select the packed bubble
option
now we can see the
bubbles which show the
recovery states happening in the indian
states or the recovery cases
so
you can see that everything is looking
in
blue color
but difficult to understand so for that
let's drag the province or state into
color so that we can have different
colors for
different states
yeah now this is good we have the
country name and state name this is fine
now we can make it a bit more readable
by dragging the recovered icon into
or the recovered
bill into the label so we have the count
of recoveries happening in that
particular state and that particular
country now it's a bit more readable now
we have
maharashtra at the leading place we have
a good recovery in maharashtra
yeah that's fine now let's get back to
the presentation mode and see our
next
query so can we forecast a trendline of
covert 19 here so how it started how is
it going on
so we can do that let's get back to w
again
so let's create a new sheet we have the
new sheet over here let's rename that as
trend line
yeah the sheet got renamed now let's
select the observation data from the
dimensions since you're making a
trendline so let's keep it observation
date or you can even select the
last update let's go with the last
update now let's select the confirmed
fill from
measures
let's select a line chart
or
[Music]
we can do that from here as well
okay so we're not getting the line chart
so there might be some problem
with the date format over here
so
we have to change the data type of
so i think this might be something with
the
date
yeah let's select the date pill and
change the data type
to date or date and time from string so
you can see we had a string first
so now it's changed to
date and time now we'll be getting a
proper trend line so now we have
according to the year so we can make it
according to quarter
and
even even
even in the form of months and so if you
see this a little bit readable you can
keep it that way or you can even change
to days
so
yeah i think there is some problem with
dating time value
so let's keep it in the form of months
it's it's more readable in one screen so
yeah it's good
let's remove this so we have the month
update
now let's go to analytics to create a
trend line and you can select the
trendline and drag it over here
and select the linear option so you can
see here
we have the trend line over here which
reads the r squared and p values and
confirmed and we have a formula for that
so basically tabula creates a formula to
create a trendline so which is 5.280
exponent to the power of eight into
month of last update so pretty pretty
pretty complex formula yet
understandable
so this is how you create a trendline
so according to the trends we have
january february the quartus q1q to q3
q4
and this is the first month of january
so here it is
so in in january we find one
okay this is in billions maybe yeah
maybe even trillions who knows but but
based on the data we have in the last
year
we have a decrement of the confirmed
cases in january so it's basically
indicating that
corona yes basically are slowly
decreasing that's a good sign
now
now let's try to find out the trend line
for india
let's duplicate this
so for that let's drag the country into
filters
we have the filter option
and
let's select all
no no no not all
we might want to select
the
indian icon
yeah
let's select apply
okay
so now we have the trend line for india
let's kind of rename it
yeah
even even you can see a gradual drop of
corona in india as well so the number
has decreased in india as well
in the earlier year we had a lot of
cases
above
30 crores now we have nearly 20 crores
that's a good sign in india as well
now let's get back to the presentation
mode and try to select the next query
so according to the next query uh can we
group indian states and find covert 19
hits yeah we can do that
now let's get back to tableau for that
let's create a new sheet and
let's rename it as grouped
so the sheet got renamed now we're going
to select the country or region
or province
now for that
you can see the create option over here
now inside that let's select the group
now
we have to create a group of
indian nations
so select
andaman and ecobar hold control select
andhra pradesh
now let's select a couple of
states we know which are in india
arunachal pradesh
assam
don't forget to hold the control key for
this
or else the options might vanish
we have bihar
we have chandigarh
we have chapter
we have dadar and nagar haveli daiyou
diamond
we have delhi
yeah we are going to just select a
couple of uh
states
uh just to show how um group can be done
so fetching all the states in this
particular column would be a little
difficult or we might even miss a few
we have gujarat
we have haryana
we have islamabad
jammu and kashmir
we have karnataka
we have kerala
the dark touched weep
we have madhya pradesh
maharashtra
nagaland
we have punjab
we have rajasthan
we have tamil nadu
we have telangana
we have the pradesh
[Music]
we have west bengal
and
let's rename the group as
indian
states group
let's select apply and okay
so uh after selecting the apply option
and clicking ok so we can have a new
pill in the dimensions section that
happens to be indian states group
so what we're gonna do is drag that pill
into detail option so that we can have
the results on our screen
so there you go the states what we
selected are right over here all the
jammu kashmir ladakh
and punjab maharashtra gujarat et cetera
et cetera
and our lakshadweep and the andaman and
nicobar islands
right so we have all the states of india
right on our screen
okay
let's expand it a little bit
scrolling on tableau is a little bit
difficult
i don't know how to select the default
option for the screen
yes um
we can see
these states
i don't know where this crawler is at
yeah we can always undo what we did in
tableau so that's the best part
now let's drag the state spell again so
that we can have a perfect map in the
screen right now
yeah
i would like to not to mess with it
again it's it's pretty good right now
let's keep it as it is now let's quickly
get back to our presentation and check
out our next query
so find the highest death rates at
international level so we
we are basically going to find which
nation or the country has the highest
death rates and which is the country
with the least amount of death rates so
which is the safest country
now let's get back to w now we're not
going to mess with this particular sheet
let's create a new sheet
let's rename the sheet as highest death
rates
international
i n t l
let's enter
so the
shade got renamed successfully let's
drag in
country
and let's drag and confirm cases
so we have a map over here so w
basically
uh kind of selected the
map as default
we can drag the depths and
now we can actually change this to
a text shot
now let's drag the measure names into
rows
so we have a little bit more
you know sorted kind of data so you can
see we have the confirm cases over here
and
that trades here now if we kind of sort
it
in the descending order
yeah so the
order is being changed now so we have uh
so we have our charts processed by
tableau for a better visual so our chart
got rearranged or
ordered in the descending order so
with that we have the highest
you know uh debts and confirmed cases in
u.s so we can even do that using a
parameter where you can create
the
top 10 or top five nations with highest
confidence values
so for that you can
drag
both
or no you need to create a parameter
i think it's not required over here
let's continue with
the next
sheet or you can just simply duplicate
this
since the dataset is a little huge it
takes a little bit of time
now let's rename this
yeah
now let's rename this sheet
it's still taking a little bit of time
yeah now i think we can rename it
least death rates so now for that we're
gonna
rearrange it in the descending order
i'm an ascending order
so yeah after sorting and changing some
layouts we have the
least number of cases or death rates in
the country called makkah where we have
least number of deaths and least number
of confident cases
so with that let's move into the
presentation mode again
and in the presentation mode we have our
next query that says can we find the
variation in code 19 cases around the
world
so for that let's create a new sheet
again
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
so after changing some
arrangements or by making an ascending
arrangement and changing the layout
or the orientation and everything we
have our final result which states that
we have the least number of debts and
confirmations of covert 19 in the
country of afghanistan
so yeah so we have the predictable
sorted arranged data over here on the
screen now let's get back to the
presentation mode and in the
presentation mode the next query that we
have to deal with is can we find the
variation in copy 19 cases around the
world yeah we can do that so let's get
back to w and create a new sheet
let's rename the sheet as a variation
of
c one nine
yeah it's done
so to find out the variation of covert
19 we might want to use the boxes and
viscous chart let's select the country
region pill from dimensions and
confirm from measures let's arrow to the
show me tab and select the box and
whisker plot
yeah so you can see that we just have
one box of whisker over here when you
see something like this happening on
your sheet then directly head over to
analytics and
uncheck the aggregate measures so
we have
this kind of visualization
maybe we forgot something so we've got
the country origin to be placed in
columns
so when you place it in the column
section then you find out all the
countries and the variation of copy 19
in their region
now let's um
sort it in the descending order so that
we can find out
the maximum variation which is happening
in france so of course there are less
number of confirmed cases but there is a
lot of variation which states that
they have something wrong
with the climatic conditions or the
weather conditions there
yeah we have a larger
confirmations in our larger cases in u.s
but there is
some
some data which shows that france is
leading in some variation yeah so um
since we're calculating the variation of
the confirmation of covert 19 presents
we have france in the first place where
it shows that there is a lot of
variation in the confirmed cases in
france rather than us
yeah
that's how we can find the variation of
presence of covert 19 in a particular
country
so with that let's move into the next
query so the next query is can we
forecast the sheet of future and
reference of code 19 presence yes we can
do that let's get back to w
for that let's create a new sheet and
rename it as forecast
of
co
with 19
presents
so the sheet got renamed successfully
now we'll select the observation date
from the
dimensions and
confirm fill from measures
so we'll use them drag it to columns and
the confirm from
yeah
now we're gonna change this okay there
is something wrong with the observation
date for that
let's select the observation fill and
change the data type to
date
yeah
so far so good
now let's select this to
day
oh we can change that to
here
now let's select four cat option yeah
so
this is how it's gonna be
so in the year of 2020 we had the
confirmed cases around this number which
is seven sixty seven zero five three
four six four so which is nearly
seventy six thousand three hundred and
seventy
lack and
in the 2021 the number got a little
decreased
which is 17 130 lakh cases and in the
end of 2022 which is the forecast we can
see there is a little
more drop so it's a good sign that the
covert nineteen is getting decreased so
this is the forecast of the code 19
presence in india
so we can change the path
to
a stepped one
the line is okay the line is pretty good
no worries on that
so basically we finished the queries on
our presentation mode
so yeah if we get back to the
presentation mode so all the queries on
the covet 19 data are finished
now let's create a dashboard
yeah we have the dashboard right now so
we can change the layout of dashboard
let me increase the width
to
1320 and decrease the height to 70
or 760. so we have the entire screen
right now
now let's drag in the confirmed cases of
international level and
the recovery cases of the international
level
yeah now we have it
okay or
let's keep it in the top and that in the
bottom
the trend line of code in the
international level
and the highest death rates
in the international level
it takes a little time
it's still taking a little bit more time
i don't know what's wrong
okay
it should be done in some time
let's wait
it's basically taking a lot of time
because we have a lot of data in that
particular sheet
let's kind of change that a little
now
let's change the sheet
or we can just remove this from the
dashboard and select the least depth
rate or the top 10 least death rates so
we have sheet right over here we have
the top 10 ones only here
yeah this is good
so this is how we can have the dashboard
and now let's create another dashboard
for indian results
so again let's uh change the
dimensions of the screen
yeah it's pretty good now let's take the
confirm cases in india
and drop it over here and recovery cases
in india and drop it over there
and
trend lines in india over here
indian states
in the forecast
somewhere over here
and if we get back to the dashboard one
we can even add the forecast data or the
variation data
somewhere over here
and we can always change the height
so that it's a bit more visible
so we can rename the dashboard
c 1 9
international
dashboard
and this one has
c
1 9
indian
dashboard
yeah so with that we have finished the
first project based on the covert 19
data set now we'll continue with the
next data set that is the airline data
set
so now we are in the second project and
the second project is about the airline
data set and in this particular data set
we're going to take the insights which
are as follows
what are the total number of flights
which are taking off in a day from the
san francisco airport and followed by
that we have the next query which reads
out find the busiest day of san
francisco airport
we'll be finding out the top five
busiest days in the san francisco
airport and followed by that we'll also
find what are the total number of
flights per day in a month
then we'll find out what are the top 10
busiest flight routes then we'll find
out what are the top 10 longest flight
routes from san francisco airport then
we have to represent the flights flying
outside the san francisco
towards different parts of the world
using a map chart
so these are the queries that we'll be
executing in our second project without
further ado let's get back to the w so
now we are back on the w dashboard so
let's select our data set for today
so our data set is somewhere here
yeah this is the air travel data set we
were looking for
now we got our air travel data set
loaded onto w
so remember i said about the
interpreter i'll select that
and
show ali
okay let let the query execute
yeah so the interpreter query got
executed now the data has been cleaned
you can review the results by clicking
on review results option over here
we have another query executed now
basically this query will take us to the
microsoft excel sheet
where our cleaned data is readily
available for us
there you go you can see that the red
colored data is the
data that is interpreted as column
headers or field names the green color
one is the data interpreted as a values
in your data source
so it looks something like this so we
have our data fine over here just
looking fine
now when you come into the root column
you have san francisco to the other
parts of the world for example we have
los angeles here etc etc but we don't
have a separate field for origin and a
destination so what we'll be doing is
we'll be splitting this particular
column
uh right over here
so let's navigate to the last column
which will show us the root
so you can right click this
and select the option of slit which will
basically split it into two halves which
will give us the
from destination or
the origin of the
airplane and
two
or the destination of the plane so from
two or the origin destination fields we
have right now over here you can see
that
um so far so good so let's quickly begin
with our worksheet
now we are on the worksheet right now so
what was our first query so our first
query was to find the total number of
flights in a day
so for that
we have a simple step so basically we'll
have
a particular number of rows right for
the data set what we've selected we will
have some thousands of data sets so each
and every row is actually a flight
so what we will do is just create a
calculated field and just name it as
number of rows
okay since we are trying to calculate
the total number of flights let's um you
know kind of
uh not name it as rows instead we'll
name it as flights
and inside the calculated field just
write one and it should be done
so you can see the number of slides just
over here just hover down the text and
we'll have the number over here so this
is the total number of flights per
day which takes off from the san
francisco airport
let's kind of increase the text size so
that it's a bit more visible
yeah that should be it
uh let's rename the sheet
from here i would i
i would do the renaming from here
because it's a little simple
total number of lights
yeah that should be it now let's get on
to the presentation mode again now let's
uh you know execute the second query
find the busiest day at san francisco
airport
so to execute the second query uh let's
just simply duplicate the sheet
and rename the sheet as um
busiest
okay
we can actually schedules of
flights
or no not schedules of flights
number of lights
or
[Music]
we can rename this as
flights taking off
so when we get the count of flights
taking off then we can actually find the
date which was really busy like
the date with the maximum amount of uh
you know flights taking off that would
be the
busiest day so the data type is date by
default that's great now let's drag it
to columns
now the sum
of numbers at this place
analysis let's uncheck this to get a map
let's make it by month
or
day
okay
we don't need this
we all need this as well
now we have a chart over here let's
change it
to
scatter plot maybe
yeah so we have the chart no worries on
the scatter plot thing it's it's really
a scatter plot and don't know what is on
that so right now we need to find out
the busiest days so for that we might
want to drag the date into filter and uh
let's select the individual dates select
next and inside the top we have the oh
yeah we need to select by field and now
we have the top 10
number of lights on yeah we need we need
the top 10 flies
so
let's select apply we needed top one but
uh why not top then you will select top
10 for that now we have the scatter plot
on my sheet right now
so let's kind of uh arrange it in the
descending order this shows the
highest number of lights or
okay
we
need
to change this value to sum
yeah it is some
so uh yeah i got to know where we made a
mystic so inside analysis we were
supposed to aggregate the measures so
that we can get the sum of
number of lights now we have the total
number of flights now let's quickly uh
arrange this
now we have the
three thousand one hundred sixty six
three thousand
two hundred
thousand two ninety five
yeah so three thousand two ninety five
happens to be our
you know busiest day in the year 2020
that is the sixth march which had the
maximum number of flights taking off
so
we can actually make a set of these
the set of these which happens to be in
the march so much happens to be the
busiest month for san francisco airport
so with that we have finished the second
query now let's create a new sheet for
our third query let's get back to the
presentation
and the third query reads that what are
the total number of flights per day in a
month so for that let's get back to w
let's try to
rename it
total
flights
in a month
done
so for that let's select date and drag
it to columns and
let's make it to
month
let's remove this
let's remove this as well now let's
check it to
day
and now number of lights
so automatically we have a line chart
and we have the flights taking off from
march 1st to march 31st which happens to
be the busiest
month for san francisco airport now
let's just take the show mark label so
that we have the number of lights taking
off every day
so as we got the result in the previous
sheet 290 or 300 3
295 flights on the date of
sixth march or is the third march maybe
yeah that happened sixth march that
happened to be the busiest day of san
francisco airport
now
let's get back to the presentation and
check the fourth query so the fourth
query reads what are the top 10 busiest
flight routes
for that let's get back to w again
let's rename the newly created sheet
busiest
routes
now the
sheet has been replaced or renamed
now to find out the top busiest routes
we need a calculated field to remove the
effects of san francisco airport first
so clinton create a calculated field
and we can name it as
busiest route busy
and now inside the calculated field we
need an if condition
then
if
route 1 split 1 is equals to
sfo
then
route
split 2.
else route one
and
yeah the calculation is valid let's
apply and okay
now we have the newly created calculated
we feel somewhere here now we'll drag
that into rows and now we'll drag the
number of flights to columns
so there we go we have the
bar chart over here let's um you know
rearrange it in descending order so that
we get the
you know descending order now we needed
the top 10 or top busiest routes for
that let's drag busy into filters
select top and by field we have top 10
let's just select apply and ok
and we have the top busiest routes from
san francisco airport or sfo
now let's get back to the presentation
mode and in the presentation mode the
next query is which are the top longest
flight rules from sfo
so to find out the
longest routes we'll create a new sheet
and rename it as
our
busiest no not busiest longest longest
routes
yeah
the sheet is renamed and you can see
that we have geometry coordinates 0 0 0
1 1 0 and 1 1. so these z okay not 0 1 1
and 1 0 coordinates basically provide
the origin information and 0 0 and 0 1
provide the destination information so
we'll be creating a calculated field for
that now
let's create a calculated field
so let's rename the calculated field as
origin
and inside the origin will make use of
make point
and inside make point we'll write
geometry
coordinates 1 one and
geometry coordinates
we'll need the geometric coordinates one
one and geometric coordinates one zero
separated by comma
and done so we have the origin now let's
create another for destination
we are creating a calculated field
destination
and inside destination we are going to
use the same
make point and
geo
metric coordinates
0 0 comma geometric coordinates 0 1
and select apply ok
now the origin and destination are
created now we need to create another
calculated field for distance
so we'll write it as distance and inside
that we'll use the distance function
and we'll write origin
comma
destination
and will represent
the distance who using kilometers
and select apply
okay
now we have the newly created distance
measure in the measure section now we'll
drag the busy into columns and
distance into
rows
okay uh we made something
oh there's no problem we can actually
change the orientation
and now let's rearrange it in the form
of descending order
now we have the um
distance sorted in the descending order
but there is a small change we have to
change the sum
to
average
once you change that you want to arrange
it again now we have the blr bangalore
as the farthest airport from sfo yeah
now we might want to drag the
lazy into fill this again
now we have the top 10
apply
okay so we have the top 10 longest
routes from sfo
so with that we have
finished our fifth query let's get back
to presentation mode and the sixth query
represent the flights flying outside sfo
towards different parts of the world
yeah that can be done let's get back to
tableau again
now for the sixth query let's create a
new sheet let's name it as
map
flights from sfo
okay so for that let's select the
latitude and longitude and select a map
[Music]
so we have the map right here
now let's change that to map
yeah it's in the map section by default
let's create a calculated field
called
lines so we are basically using lines to
represent the flights taking off from
sfo so i'll name it as line
or we can
name it as flights line
okay and inside the calculated field
let's type in
[Music]
make line and
so inside the field let's make use of
make line function and inside that let's
write an origin
and separated by comma destination
and the calculation is valid apply ok
now we have the newly created flight
line over here
now we'll drag that flight line to
detail
now once we drag that
flight line to the
detail we have the lines or flights
taking off from sfo to different parts
of the world now we can make it look a
bit more appealing or more informative
by
dragging
the roots are
yeah
into detail
so we have the details of roots
and we can even drag the distance into
detail so
when we
hover over to the line we'll have the
root and the distance as well
yeah so that's how it is done now we're
basically done with all the queries now
let's create a dashboard
so now let's um you know kind of arrange
the dashboard size convenient to our
monitor so i'll increase it to
1320 width and decrease the height to
760 so that's the proper size what i was
looking for
now
we'll drag the
details
into the sheet
longest routes
we have the flights taking off busiest
routes longest routes
and
total flights
into here
now it looks more readable fine so we
have the busiest routes we have the
longest route we have the
flights taking off and the month of
march the busiest month was the march
and the busiest day was 6th of march i
don't know what was so special on that
day if you know it please let me know in
the comment section below
and yeah so totally we created a
dashboard now let's rename the dashboard
as
sfo flight data dashboard
and we are done so we're done with the
second project now let's get back to our
presentation and let's check the last
project that happens to be the space
missions data set
so now we are in the third project which
is based on space missions data set so
using this particular data set we're
going to get some insights which are
based on the queries on my screen right
now so we're going to find out what are
the average temperature details of the
launch sites what are the average wind
speed details of the launch sites what
are the average humidity details of the
launch sites so we need all these to uh
you know before launching a satellite or
a rocket into space everything needs to
be in ideal condition so followed by
that we have what are the different
varieties of launch vehicles used by
different companies so there are a lot
many companies you are from government
sector where you're from private sector
for example
uh usa military satellites belong to
government and uh private satellites
like um spacex yeah and few others next
we have what is the mission status of
the company so we have a list of
satellites launched already right so we
need the mission status of that
particular
uh satellite is it a successful launch
or was there some failure record or
something like that next at the last
query we have the track records of
launch sites
so what are the track records so what
are the successful launches what are the
failure launches what are the satellites
launched by different companies etc etc
we'll have a complete track record of
that of all the launch sites which are
available in our data set
now without further ado let's get back
to tableau and start the project
so we are on tableau now we're going to
extract the data set so the data set we
need is the space missions data set you
can get this in the kaggle or you can
even have the access to this data set
from the description box below select
open to open the data
so yeah the data got successfully loaded
again use the interpreter and it's a
good habit of using the interpreters to
clean your data and make everything
understandable or look understandable
show aliases everything is fine
so we're good to go with the data set
what we have in our
tableau right now
now with that let's get back to the
first sheet
now let's check the first query that we
have in our presentation what are the
average temperature details of launch
sites
so for that let's
create a new sheet yeah it's created
rename it as avg
temperatures
or
launch site
temperatures
so now we need the
launch site and select the temperature
and hold over to the show me tab and
let's let the bubbles chart
so now you can see the temperature is in
the sum but we don't need the sum here
we need to change that to average now we
have the average temperatures of the
launch sites now let's kind of select
label show marks here
so we can
do one more thing we can drag the
temperature onto the
label now
we have the temperature here now let's
again change the measure to average now
we have the average temperatures of the
launch sites final nights
yeah that's pretty well
now
let's get back to the presentation and
the next query is what are the average
wind speed details of the launch sites
let's get back to tableau again
let's create a new sheet
launch
site
wind speeds
now let's drag the launch site into
columns
and wind speed from measures into rows
and
you can see automatically we have a bar
chart but to make it a little bit more
readable let's select the
boxes and viscous chart yeah you know
what to do now go to analysis uncheck
the aggregate measures options
and let's drag the
launch site again onto columns now we
have the different
box and whiskers for different sites
so
let's kind of arrange it
yeah so the wind speeds at uh kennedy
space center are here 20 miles and 23 at
vandenberg
and marshall at nine
yeah so this is the wind speeds at
different launch sites
now let's get back to the presentation
mode and now we have to find the
humidity details of launch sites
so let's get back to tablet and we are
back on tableau let's rename it um
launch site
now let's select the repeat now let's
select the launch site and humidity
then
a pie chart
the pie chart is really small so we can
select the entire view
now we have the sum of humidity but we
need the average humidity
and now let's um drag humidity onto
label
and launch site to label
now we have the detailed humidity
now we need to select the
measure to average again
and here to average again
yeah so we have the humidity percentage
of launch sites
on the pie chart over here so with that
we are done now let's get back to
presentation again now our fourth query
which states that what are the different
varieties of launch vehicles used by
different companies for that let's get
back to tableau
now let's create a new sheet
launch vehicle
details
yeah
now this query is pretty straightforward
select company and
vehicle type and we should be done
so there we go we have the company name
and vehicles used for the launching of
satellites process
now let's get back to the presentation
mode let's select the next query what is
the mission status of companies now
let's get back to tableau
let's create a new sheet and rename it
as mission status
now we are back on tableau now let's
select the company
drag that to columns and
mission status to columns and
we'll select one
parameter from
measures so that we can get a
good
bar chart side by side bar chart
and now we can
drag the company to color so that we can
have different colors for different
companies
so
we have the mission details so
spacex found a maximum success in the
recent days and little failures and
yeah
boeing fun good success as well and some
failures so these are the mission status
of different companies and different
satellites as well
so we have even u.s air force here faced
some satellites here
some failures and some satellites it's
okay
so now let's get back to presentation
mode
now the sixth query is track records of
lunch sites
okay we had the payload as some so we
change it to count distinct count
so now we have a better observation of
failures and successes over here so as
we discussed in the sixth query now we
need to find the track records of launch
sites
now let's create a new sheet rename it
as track records
and
now let's drag the company to columns
mission status to columns again and now
let's drag the
launch site yeah
i think we might want to drag the
mission status to rose
yeah
let's create click on
text
now let's drag the space mission scan to
color
and space mission counter labels
now let's use this one yeah
now we have the
state stats or the track records of
different space centers or launch sites
and we have the failures and success
rates over here
yeah so basically we have done the last
sheet or last query executed now let's
create a new dashboard
as we always do change the resolution
according to the
monitor we have so i'm gonna use
1030p
and height as 760.
now let's drag the
sheets
so we have the launch temperatures
launch wind speeds and launch site
humidity
at one place
now the launch vehicles used
mission status
and
the track records
so we'll kind of
drag it here
and this one over here
this little bit over here
so now we can actually you know
select
the track records of cape carnival we
have the site temperature we have the
site humidity we have the site wind
speed
and the track records of that particular
site and launch vehicles launched
mission status everything on one single
dashboard
so that's how you make use of dashboards
in real time today we'll be going over
answers to common interview questions
for tableau positions first question is
what are the data types supported in
tableau we have string date date and
time numerical boolean so true or false
and geographical in tableau you can tell
what kind of data type you have so when
you're on the data source tab you can
see that this is numerical and this is
string here we have a date we don't have
any date times here that would have the
little clock icon and we also have
geographical these are set by default
and you can change them by clicking on
the icon
and say we wanted row id to allow text
so we'll change it to string and you can
see the icon changes there
the next question has to do with how
will you understand dimensions and
measures so a key thing to remember is
that dimensions are qualitative and
measures are quantitative and if you can
remember those particular words it helps
convey what the interviewer is looking
for so
dimensions are qualitative and you can
use them to categorize your data so for
example you can categorize your data by
what country it comes from and measures
are quantitative and can be aggregated
so you can do a sum of sales or you can
do the average profit did you know that
tableau automatically assigns each field
a data type and a role and that
automatically aggregates your measures
using sum but you can change what the
default aggregation is question three
what do you understand by discrete and
continuous in tableau so we have
discrete values and continuous values
discrete is represented as blue and
continuous is represented as green so
let's look in tableau when we go to our
worksheet
you can see that all the dimensions are
automatically blue
and all of the measures are green
however you can have a continuous
dimension and you can have a discrete
measure
so we have discrete dimensions which is
a blue dimension but also continuous
dimensions and data is a good example of
that let's take a look so we pull on
order date we right now have year
and it's making categories
instead of a continuous axis so it's
making a finite list there but we can
change it
to be
you can see now it's marked as
continuous here and it's green and we
change it to be an axis
instead of different categories
it would be a continuous axis
so you can also have discrete measures
which are blue measures and continuous
measures in the green so for example
let's say we had a visualization that
had
the region
and
sales
and profit but instead of having an axis
for profit maybe we just wanted to have
a number for the profit listed right
next to
the region and then we could have the
sales visualization so what we could do
is change it to a discrete
value and put it next to region and now
it's part of the labels and that's an
example of having a discrete
measure
did you know that continuous is infinite
and discrete is finite those are some
key words that you could use also to
describe the difference between
continuous and discrete and also just
remember that discrete is blue and
continuous is green the next question
number four is what are filters and name
the different filters in tableau so
filters are a way to restrict the data
that allows you to only see the data
that you want to see in your workbook or
dashboard and there are these different
types of filters and they also have a
specific order so if you can remember
the different filters that's helpful but
also if you can remember what order they
apply in that'll get you some definite
bonus points in your interview we have
extract filters that filter the data as
it extracts and it will affect how big
your extract is we also have data source
filters here which will filter the data
out of the data source however the
extract will still be the same size so
let's take a look at this handy
visualization
that tableau has on their website we
have the order of operations and in blue
we have our filters
so extracts is first and it filters down
your extract to just what you've
selected and we have data source filters
that will apply to the entire data
source so any visualization that uses
that data source will have these filters
we also have context filters which are
next which come before
some of these level of details that's
the major difference is that it applies
before some of these sets and
conditional values and then you will do
dimensions and then measures so any
filters that happen on dimensions happen
before any measure filters the last type
of filter we have is a table calculation
filter which happens after all of the
rest of them and basically just applies
to
your visualization just the one
visualization question number five there
are three customer segments in the
superstore data set what percent of the
total profits is associated with the
corporate segment perfect so in some
tableau interviews you may be asked to
build a visualization for our examples
here we'll be using the superstore data
set and if you don't have access to the
superstore data set just comment below
and somebody on the simply learn team
will help you get access to that also
this is a fun opportunity to pause the
video and then you can work on this on
your own and then come back and see if
what you did was the right thing or how
we did it differently also you can
comment below on what your answer is and
we'll see if we can all get the right
thing
so let's build this
three customer segments in the super
store data set what percent of the total
profits total profits is associated with
corporate segment great so we're going
to bring on our segments and we have
consumer corporate and home office and
let's bring on our
total profit so i just did that by
double clicking and now it's just
bringing on the sum for each of those by
default but we want to figure out what
percent of the total each of these are
so we can change this to be
a table calculation we can click add
table calculation or we can do a quick
table calculation
and find percent of total so let's go
back to our question we wanted to know
the percent of total profits associated
with the corporate segment and the
corporate segment has 32.12
of the total profits
and here's our solution with
32.12 percent so did you get it right
comment below if you got that what are
the different joins in tableau give an
example so in tableau
you can join your data so if we wanted
to look at orders and tie it to
people we can pull on people and it will
give you this visualization and you can
see all the different joints here and
we'll discuss those in just a second you
also have the opportunity to union
information which would be if we had
maybe two excel sheets that had orders
information
perhaps one of them had 2012 and one of
them had 2013 then you could take your
orders and pull it so you see that
pop-up drag table to union and that's
another way to add more data and so
those are all worth mentioning let's
take a look at the different kinds of
joins
we have our inner join which will only
give you the values
that have matches in both tables
our left join that will give you all the
values in the left table and its matches
in the right table
and then the right join which will give
you all the values in the right table
and its matches in the left table
the outer join also known as a full
outer join will give you all the values
in the left and the right table
and then as we discuss the union you can
see it's represented by a more vertical
join and what it does is it adds more
rows all the rest of these are about
adding more columns but this will add
more rows
in the same columns that you had before
if you have the opportunity to draw out
the answer to this question and make
these venn diagrams it's a really
helpful way for you to explain your
point and it really portrays that you
know what you're talking about what is
the difference between a join and
blending in tableau so i just showed you
how to make a join here and we are
joining
an excel sheet
to another excel sheet all within the
same connection to that excel file so
when you're joining data we'll look over
here at the joining side that's when
you're bringing two or more tables
within the same data source and that's
how you join it and so
we're all inside of a data source here
which when i go to sheet1 just has one
data source here called orders whatever
we wanted to call it and that is all
within one data source however let's say
we already had two different data
sources in tableau and we wanted to
bring together two of them so in this
case it's an oracle table and we brought
in an oracle table and we made a data
source and then also an excel table that
had a second data source and you can
blend it together to get your combined
data set so the major difference what
you're going to really want to take away
from this is that blending is from two
separate tableau data sources and that
joining is all within one data source
and it ends up just being one data
source in the end in blending each data
source contains its own set of
dimensions and measures and when you
join it will combine it into one set of
dimensions and measures so let's go back
to our example here let's bring on
people it is automatically said we're
going to join it on region and we're
going to do an inner join that's fine by
me
and so we come here
and now we have just one
set of dimension and measures under
orders however if we were to add a
second data source which we will it'll
be an excel file and it will be based
off of this rank example
we'll open that up and now when we go to
sheet 1 we have two data sources
and if we were to blend this data
together we would still see two separate
sets of data only we would be able to
pull in from this set some information
and we'd pull in from this set some
other information so that's a visual
difference between blending and
joining question number eight is what is
the difference between a live and an
extract so first we'll talk about live
and we'll say that your dashboard is
connected live to a database and so a
live connection will query that database
every time you open up the dashboard or
visualization so that you're getting the
most recent information each time and
it's useful for if you need information
that's a little bit more real time
however it can be slower especially if
your queries are complicated with an
extract it will run the query
beforehand and store the information on
tableau server or on your local machine
and so that it's faster to get to
however it is not real-time information
so if you had a refresh of your extract
that runs every day
in the morning and then during the day
somebody has made a change to your
database they won't see that change on
your dashboard until the next time the
refresh runs for your extract in tableau
you can set if you want the connection
to be live or extract when you first are
making your data source and this is a
tableau desktop in tableau
public you don't have that option did
you know that the reason that extracts
are faster is because tableau doesn't
need to access the database each time it
fills the visualization and did you know
that you can set up a refresh schedule
on tableau server in order to be able to
see your extracted data update
question nine what is a calculated field
and how will you create one so if we
look at our data set here
we have the opportunity to see the
difference between order date and ship
date so to create a calculated field
you click create calculated field with
this drop down arrow at the top or you
can right click in white space
create calculated field
then you give it a name
and we're going to call it
shipping delay
and we are going to do
[Music]
a date diff
so if you don't see this dialog box here
you can click this arrow
to see that
our date part is day the start date is
order date and the end date is ship date
so to remember how to create a
calculated field it's by clicking this
down arrow and clicking create
calculated field
and then writing your
query here
and a calculated field is an additional
field made up using the data that you
already have so
we've made a new field here and it has
the equal sign at the beginning that
might be worth mentioning how to tell if
it's a calculated field or if it was an
original field and then we can bring
shipping delay
here and we can see the number of days
that it took between the order date and
the ship date we could also
duplicate a calculated field so now we
have shipping delay copy
and we're going to call this
average shipping delay
and we're going to encapsulate it
inside an average function
and now if we take off the order id the
order date and the ship date
it's automatically summing up those days
but we can bring on our average shipping
delay
and you can see on average how many days
it took
and let's change
our number here to
include decimal places
so a calculated field is a new field
made from existing data
it can be used to create more robust
visualizations and it does not affect
the original data set for example we
made our average delay function here
using data from our original data set
question 10 how can you display top five
and last five sales in the same view
you can show top five and last five
sales for a same dimension by creating a
set
so let's take a look at doing that here
we have
our customers so let's bring on customer
name
and we're going to do it based on profit
so now that we've done it on profit we
can see these are our top five profit
and i've sorted it by profit
and
here's our bottom five
and we can create a set by coming and
clicking on the dimension that we want
the set to be based on we'll right click
there
and we will
come to create and click set
we're going to call this top customers
top buy field top five
five sum of profit and now we have a set
it makes a set section here
now we're going to make a second set
off of customer name
create set
bottom customers
bottom
5 by
sum of profit we'll hit ok and now we're
going to combine these two sets so i'm
going to control click and then we have
both of them selected and we're going to
click create combined set
top and bottom
customers
and we're going to have it include all
members of both sets
and now we can pull top and bottom
customers onto filters
and you can see our top five and our
bottom five so if we
control drag profit onto color
then it's colored by that as well so key
thing to remember is that you can use it
sets to create to show both the top and
the bottom in the same visualization and
that you can combine those sets
is there a difference between sets and
groups in tableau the answer to this is
yes
you can describe a group as being
simpler and using only one dimension to
determine the group whereas a set can be
more complex so you could say sets are
more complex and you can use conditions
to create the sets and you can also use
multiple dimensions and measures to
create the sets
for example here we create a group of
subcategory so we grab all of these
things together and can group it and
that will be
we'll have copiers and envelopes and
then we'll have one group of all of
these together
over here you could create a set that
looks at sales and profits to create its
set so the best way i can describe this
is by looking at what we did here and so
we were able to use dynamic
filtering here to create our sets
and where we'll look at the top five or
the bottom five and let's do the same
thing we did there but use a group so
for a group we could see that these
we've sorted it and we can say
one two three four five this is the top
five so we could create
a group that's this paper clip here and
now we have a group of the top five and
it's added that group it makes a new
group customer name group and it put it
on the color for us now let's go to the
bottom
and we're gonna go one two three four
five and we'll create our group
so now we have a top five group at
bottom five group so let's name them
that and we'll do that by clicking edit
alias
top customers
okay and we'll come here and we'll
rename that
bottom
customers
okay we'll put our top customers on top
and then let's hide all the others so
we'll click exclude there and now we
have a similar visualization as we had
before for our sets
top bottom however a key difference here
is that we had to go through and select
the top five and the bottom five so
let's say that
maybe
cindy or let's say henry goldwyn has
suddenly
had much more positive profit associated
with them if that changes he's gonna
still stay in our group this group is
just using these customer names to
determine who's in the group so the
group is henry sherrell luke grant and
cindy no matter
if their data changes so say tomorrow
all this data is different it's still
going to put these people into the group
however the sets as you saw before is
based off of the profit the sum of
profit and who has the top five and who
has the bottom five if raymond suddenly
has a lot less profit and falls out of
the group then the groups won't pick it
up but the sets will so that's one thing
to remember is that it could be based on
conditions and then you saw how we took
two sets and put them together into our
combined group you could also have a set
that is based off of two different
dimensions
or two different measures and that's how
you could put those two sets together
and get dynamic sets
so the major differences as we saw is
that a group is just based off of one
dimension
and a set can have conditions and be
based on off of other dimensions
also you need to know that groups cannot
be used in calculated fields but sets
can
question 12 what is a parameter in
tableau and give an example
a parameter is a dynamic value that a
customer could select
and you can use it to replace constant
values in calculations filters and
reference lines so for example here we
determined we wanted bottom five and top
five customers but let's give them some
options so we'll create a parameter
and we'll call it select
number of
top
bottom
customers
and we're going to
[Music]
let it be a range
with a minimum of five
and a maximum of
and a step size of five so we'll let
them go five at a time
okay
now if we click show parameter control
we can see our parameter control and you
can do 5 10 15 or 20. but since it's not
in any of our calculated fields or sets
or filters
then it's not making any difference so
let's put it inside of these
we'll edit our set and instead of top or
bottom five
we'll click bottom select number of top
bottom customers so now it's taking our
parameter and inserting it in
to our set there we'll do the same thing
with top customers
okay and now right now we see top five
bottom five if we change it now we see
top ten bottom ten fifteen and there's
our twenty
so it replaces a constant value and
allows the end user to select the value
question 13 what is the difference
between tree maps and heat maps
so let's first talk about what each of
these are
heat maps compare categories using size
and color i think the biggest thing
about heat maps is the color size is
somewhat optional so let's build this
visualization quickly
so
we have region
category
and subcategory
and we're making a heat map so
we want to bring profit onto color
and you can see we've got hotter and
colder in this case
for a heat map we might want to change
so in this case what it's doing is
hotter is negative but we could reverse
that and then hotter is positive and so
hotter maybe means this is where more
activity is
we can also double click on profit
we can also bring profit onto label
and we'll change this to
square and now it's marked at what
everything is so a heat map
will use color to draw your eye to the
places where there's heat or maybe
activity we could also use size in this
case so it's not just defined by color
necessarily maybe we want the size to be
defined by sales so we get things that
are bigger but they're blue which means
that they are bigger in sales but their
profit is negative
and it draws your eyes to technology so
machines in the south are doing a lot of
sales but they're not having positive
profit necessarily
also you can see some things that have
darker colors
but are smaller so high profit but not a
lot of sales so that is a heat map a
tree map is used to represent
hierarchical data now hierarchy is the
term you need to remember when you're
talking about the difference between a
tree map and a heat map
in the heat map
none of these boxes have to do with the
hierarchy with each other whereas with a
tree map you can see that this box has a
thick white line between it and the
other ones and that means that that
section are all connected so these are
all technology
and the bigger this section is that
means the bigger the let's see size is
based off of profit so this bigger
section means that technology has more
profit than furniture so let's build
this one when i build tree maps i like
to use our show me tool so here's tree
map and it says one or more dimensions
or one and one to two measures so we're
going to grab category and we're going
to control click subcategory and we're
going to control click profit and
sales and we'll click on our tree map
perfect and so the darker the color
that means the more sales there is and
that's pretty similar to our
heat map over here so the color
indicated
in this case it was profit so the color
indicates the difference and the size
indicates the difference and that's true
over here the color indicates a
difference and the size indicates a
difference however
there is a hierarchy to it over here you
can see
that there is um hierarchies because we
have furniture and then that puts that
all together under furniture
and then here's the subcategories
however if you were trying to compare
furniture to office supplies it's really
difficult to tell which one has more
sales but if we go over to sheet 7 that
has our tree map on it you can see
really quickly that office supplies has
much more
sales
than furniture in this case office
supplies has much more profit than
furniture biggest difference is that
tree maps have the hierarchy question
number 14 what is the difference between
twbx
and twb so these are all
tableau file formats and the twbx
contains all of the unnecessary
information to build the visualization
so it's called a packaged workbook
and it compresses it all together
however the twb just contains
instructions about how to interact with
the data source so when it's building a
visualization tableau will look at the
data source and then build the
visualization with an extract it
contains all of the information that you
need so all the data is wrapped up
inside of there and there's no
connection that has to be made between
tableau and the data source because it's
all right inside whereas with the twb it
has to connect to the data source or
else it doesn't have the data to build
the visualizations it just knows it has
the instructions of what to do with that
data so the biggest difference is twbx
has the data inside of it whereas a twb
only has the instructions question 15
explain the difference between tableau
worksheet dashboard story and workbook
perfect here's a breakdown and
explanation of each of those and in
tableau this entire thing that we've
been looking at all these sheets
is a workbook
however this sheet 7 is just one
worksheet all of them together is a
workbook and sheet 7 is a worksheet the
big difference between a worksheet and a
dashboard is that the worksheet is just
one
visualization and so it is only one set
of columns and rows here and a dashboard
could contain multiple visualizations so
if we wanted to see our heat map and our
tree map on the same page that would be
a dashboard and then a story
is somewhat similar
to a presentation mode and so you can
have different pages and so we could say
here is our
heat map and then we could make another
page and look at our
tree map
and then look at our heat map
and then we could duplicate that page
and we could
say let's focus on furniture
so we're going to highlight furniture
and then so if we were to go through
these one at a time
we would say here's our tree map and
then we would look at information there
and we would say here's our heat map and
then the next screen will say let's
focus on furniture and you can see that
it highlighted furniture for me when i
went to the next scene so a story
can show you things one at a time it's
like a presentation mode so the
differences are the workbook contains
the sheets and the dashboards of the
stories
the worksheet is a single view
dashboard is multiple views and a story
is a sequence a sequence is a good
keyword to remember when you're
describing a story and did you know that
the only place that you can access the
dimensions and the measures and custom
fields we've made is on a worksheet so
when you're looking at a dashboard
so on a worksheet we see dimensions and
measures when you're looking at a
dashboard you no longer see dimensions
and measures what you do see are all of
the worksheets similarly when you look
at a story you no longer see
any dimensions and measures but you do
see all the worksheets and the
dashboards
question 16 what do you understand by
blended axis with a blended axis you can
use two measures that share an axis and
that means they necessarily have the
same scale so let's build something with
a blended axis
so we can make a visualization that
looks at
sales
over time
we'll bring on order date
and
let's just
do order date by
month there we go
so we can see sales over time and say we
wanted to
also see profit
this is two visualizations that have two
different axes but if we wanted them to
have the same axes
and just the same marks card you see how
i made two different marks cards we
could bring on
measure values
and take off all the measures that we
don't
want we just want
when we take them off here it's creating
this filter here for measure names
and let's take off these two extra
visualizations and now we have a
visualization that has a blended axes
for sales over time
and profit over time and you can see
that they necessarily have the same axes
there is no second axes
what is the use of a dual axis and how
do you create one perfect so a dual
access allows you to compare measures
and you can have two different scales so
if we had this same visualization that
same information that we wanted to see
with
again profit and sales
over time
we'll do
okay great and we wanted them to have
the same axes we could right click on
the second pill
of the measures
and click dual axis and now you can see
that they do not
share the same axis and you can see
profit is much higher here right there
and so the use of this would be
sometimes you need things to have
different axes if you come here and you
click synchronize axes you end up
getting a pretty similar visualization
but you do get two separate marks cards
so a key thing to bring up if you are
asked the difference between a blended
axis and a dual axis chart
is
one that the blended axis uses the same
scale and a dual axis could have two
different scales and two a dual axis has
two marks cards so let's say we wanted
our profit
to not be a line chart but to be a bar
chart that gives you that option when
you go to
the blended axis we only have one mark's
card so we change it to bar everything
is bar
but back over here
we change it to
circles and we see the circles
so if we wanted to show sales by year
and profit ratio by year in the same
view that's where two different scales
could be handy let's build that
visualization
so we'll make a new chart
and we'll bring on sales
and
profit ratio
over time
that is profit i still did profit so
i'll drag profit ratio right over top of
profit there we go and you can see that
they can't use the same scale because
this is a percentage and so
uh if we had them on a blended axis 20
percent is really 0.2 and it would just
be so tiny
but if we wanted them on the same area
to act to apply to the same space here
we could dual access it that you can
still see useful information there but
otherwise this would just be in such a
tiny tiny space so our profit ratio
would just show up right here almost
like a straight line
question 18 what will the following
function return
left three comma tableau here's the
question again and here are the
potential answers tab
or eau error or none of the above so
just take a moment and see if you can
answer this question correctly go ahead
and pause the video and if you get the
answer you can comment below and then we
will discuss
we've taken some time to
answer this question
and let's go ahead and see what the
answer is the answer is it will return
an error that's because the syntax for
our left is that the string must go
first first you say left then you put
the string and then you put the number
so let's talk about what left does
it returns a specific number of
characters from the left and if you had
done it correctly the left is this side
so if you had done the string first and
you said you want three the result would
be t a b
there's also one called right
and that would come from the other end
and go eau so that's where these answers
came from question 19 how do you handle
null and other special values tableau is
unable to plot null values or zeros or
negative values on a logarithmic axis
and so it will display an indicator in
the lower right corner which looks like
this
telling you that is unable to draw those
two points
so when you click on the indicator you
can choose from the following first you
can choose to filter the data which will
exclude the null values from the
visualization or you can click show data
at the default position so we'll look at
both of these
so you click on your indicator and it
will say what do you want to do with
these two values if we click filter the
data then you can see that it has
filtered those that blank space and
drawn a line connecting
those dates in between even though there
is no point for the 29th or the 30th
it goes straight from the 28th to the
31st so what's happening on our
visualization is it's adding this filter
if we press the back button we see that
filter disappears if we come down and
select filter the data it adds a filter
here
that then
only includes non-null values
so those are all removed from our
visualization and up to this point you
can see that we have one point per day
the 21st the 22nd the 23rd 24th but then
when we get to the 28th we don't have a
29th or 30th and it just draws that line
to the 31st
assuming
that during that time period
that what we want is a straight line now
the other option would be
we could also make the assumption that
whenever there is a null value that
actually means zero sales have happened
during that time so that's when you
would click show data at default
position
and now it draws those two points
at the zero line
and when you hover it still shows sales
null
so then when you hover here you can see
the actual amount for sales during that
time
so if a null in your data means zero
then show a default position is good for
you and if it doesn't necessarily mean
zero
then you can
filter the data or you can leave it
disconnected like this
question 20 find the top product
subcategories by sales within each
delivery method which subcategory is
ranked number two for first class ship
mode if you'd like to pause the video
and work on this on your own and then
see if
what you did matches what we did then
you're welcome to now at this time and
comment below what your answer is
okay
so we want to know by subcategory
and by ship mode
which
subcategory ranks the highest for each
ship mode so in sales so if we take
sales
onto the visualization we can see that
by the ship mode
it's already split up and we could see
that
maybe this one for standard class it
would be chairs you can kind of look
through and kind of oh it's not chairs
chairs isn't number one because we have
this one it's phones so to make it
easier we're going to
change some of sales to a rank table
calculation so we're going to come here
and click add table calculation
and we're going to change the
calculation type to rank and it's going
to rank them
in order
of
sales so but we right now we can see
that it's highlighting that's called
calculation assistance helping us
understand
how it's ranking us so if i and select
calculation assistance then it gets rid
of it but you can see right now it's
ranking it
across the table so it says accessories
has most sales in standard class then
second class then first class then same
day
and that's not what we want to see we
want to see it up and down we want to
see for first class which subcategory
has the highest sales and second highest
sales so let's turn back on our
calculation assistance and we're going
to click table down
you can see now it's going up and down
within first class
what are all the subcategories ranked so
that's what we want now as soon as you
click things in the table calculation it
applies it over here so you don't have
an ok button
so you can just close that out
and you can see now we have a rank up
and down
for the subcategory so back to the
question was which subcategory is ranked
second for first class ship mode here's
first class let's find number two it's
chairs
question number 21
find the customer with the lowest
overall profit what is his slash her
profit ratio let's go ahead and build
this visualization
customer profit
and we're going to
bring all of our customers on
and then we're going to bring on profit
let's do it as a visualization so i'll
bring it on to columns
and then let's sort smallest to biggest
so cindy stewart
is the one who has our lowest profit
and now to figure out her profit ratio
we need to make a calculated field which
i've already made here
so in this calculated field we take the
sum of profit and divided by the sum of
sales we do this
so that it will sum up all of the profit
per row
so for cindy we want to take all of her
profit
over all of her transactions and divide
it by all of her sales instead of doing
it row by row profit divided by sales
profit divided by sales and then summing
that up at the end so
we'll take our profit ratio and put it
on the label
and we can see
what her profit ratio is and since it's
a ratio here i have it in a percent
if you don't have your profit ratio set
up as a percent it will look like this
negative 1.65 question number 22 what is
the rank function in tableau we got a
look at the rank function earlier when
we figured out our top product
subcategories by sales and what was
ranked number two so
i'm sure you're familiar with what
ranking is which is assigning something
a position like first place or second
place usually within a category and
usually based on a measure so
tableau
is able to rank in several different
ways where you can do
rank or rank dense rake modified or rank
unique and we'll take a look at these
individualization here and talk about
the difference but if you are asked
about
the rank function in tableau it's worth
bringing up that there are several
different ways to rank and going into a
little bit of detail on those different
ways will be helpful for you so
let's build off of this rank example
instead so we're going to bring on our
store and we've got store a b c d and e
and then we'll bring on our sales
and store a had ten dollars and he had
forty dollars
so
now let's create a calculated field
we're going to call it rank
we're going to do a rank calculated
field
based on sales
we're going to do a rank calculated
field based on sum of sales
perfect
okay
we'll double click on rank and we can
see first place is the one who had the
most sales and fifth place is the one
with the least sales now we had a tie
here at 20 and it gave them both third
place and then it skipped fourth place
and went to fifth place and that's how
the basic rank function works so if we
duplicate it
and we edit our copy
and we're gonna make this one
rank dense
you know what let's do rank modified
second
okay
and we bring on rank modified
let's have this happen in order so sum
of sales then rank then rank modified
now you can see
it's similar to rank first second but
then it skips third and goes to fourth
and then fifth so over here it gave them
buyer number
when there was a tie and over here it
gave them the lower number when there
was a tie
so if you could remember that
rank gives them the higher number and
rank modified gives them the lower
number that will be helpful
for your interview
now we're going to take a look at rank
dense
rank dense apply
and rank dense doesn't skip a number so
it goes one two three four and it
condenses
the ranking
without any skipping any numbers
and now let's
do our last one
which is going to be
rank unique
okay
and with rank unique it refuses to give
to
the same rank
and how it determines when there is a
tie is it will look at the dimension
that's in the visualization and do
whichever one comes first in ascii so it
goes 1 2 and these are a tie and since
capital b comes before
lowercase c
then it's doing b first then c
then a
so in your interview it would be really
impressive to talk about the different
versions of ranks
and how they all work
question 23 how can you embed a web page
in a dashboard so we're just going to
build this and then explain it so i have
here
my map by sales and we're going to build
a dashboard
we'll bring on first we'll change our
layout so i can fill up the screen
then let's bring on my map
and i've added the state name and the
sales on the map here
for
an embedded web page you can grab it
from the objects section the web page
and then you could put a url right
inside of here
and then that will embed that page
underneath
so if we wanted to do wikipedia or
something we can hit ok and it will take
you to wikipedia
but what we're going to do is make this
page dynamic based on what state you
select it'll look up that wikipedia page
for that state so you could maybe look
at some population data
we'll close that and we'll try again
we're going to bring on our web page
it's going to ask for a url but we're
just going to hit ok
and not provide it with a url
and then we'll use this dashboard action
and create a url action
that then contains our url
with our state
appended at the end which is how
wikipedia formats their url so we'll hit
okay
oh i forgot one more thing let's do it
on select instead of on menu so whenever
we select something it will run this
okay okay and now when we select texas
it brings up the texas wikipedia page
when we select nebraska
it'll change
so the major points to know on how to
embed a web page is you bring it in from
the objects section and then if they ask
how to make a dynamic you use dashboard
actions
and a url action
question 24 design a view to show
region-wide profit and sales
so one way you could do this is by
bringing on region and then bringing on
profit
and
sales
and that's a pretty simple view of
profit and sales by region however
one thing that interviewers may be
looking for when asking a question about
region
is your mapping capabilities in tableau
so
what we could do
is
region is not a geographic location so
it takes a little bit of creativity but
if you bring on state by double clicking
it and it maps out the states
you can
make it a map here and it fills it in
and then you can bring region onto color
and that splits it up by region
and then if you bring on profit
and sales on the labels
and let's also bring on the state onto
labels
and then you can look at your profit and
sales inside of their regions inside of
their states
and so
that is another view where you could
look at
profit and sales by region and it's a
little bit more
takes advantage of some of the mapping
capabilities in tableau it may be what
your interviewer is looking for so you
could discuss multiple ways to look at
it but here is one way that we could
recommend it question 25 how can you
optimize the performance of a dashboard
there are multiple ways to optimize the
performance of the dashboard some of the
things that you might mention is that
you could exclude any fields you're not
using from your visualization just keep
them off or you can use extract filters
and if you recall extract filters will
remove out rows of data from the extract
and so only focus on the data that you
need another thing you can do is try and
limit the amount of filters that you use
and when you do use filters avoid using
quick filters and you can use action
filters and parameter filters instead
filters cause your queries in the
database to be a little bit more complex
and can keep them from running as
efficiently as they could use min and
max instead of average because average
functions require more processing time
than min max also you can try to use
boolean and numerical calculations
because computers do better with
integers and booleans than they do with
strings
so quick things to remember is keep your
data simple
use fewer filters and when you do use
filters use parameters or actions avoid
using average use min and max and avoid
using strings by using booleans and
numerical calculations
question 26 which visualization will be
used in the given scenarios here we have
three scenarios of opportunities that
you might want to visualize and there is
no perfectly exact answer for these but
there are some visualizations that tend
better for certain types of data however
there sometimes could be
different ways to visualize it and it
doesn't mean that these are the very
best ways however if you want to take a
moment go ahead and pause the video and
go through
and figure out what your three answers
are and comment below and we can discuss
what we think the best ways are
so first we want to show aggregated
sales totals across a range of product
categories and subcategories we want to
show the duration of events or
activities and we want to show quarter
wise profit growth so to show aggregated
sales totals across a range of products
subcategories and categories you could
use a tree map the reason we bring up a
tree map here is that they are known for
allowing you to show a visualization
using hierarchies so let's take a look
at that we're going to show aggregated
sales totals across the range of product
categories and subcategories so if we
come here and make a sheet
and we want to see sales across control
click
category and subcategory and then we
click a tree map what happens
it's showing
it based on size and color and so it
shows the size the bigger the size the
more sales and the darker the color the
more sales and the reason we choose a
tree map over just a normal heat map is
that
it makes a category here so we can
compare this box that has all the
technology in it see how all of these
are technology to this box that has all
of the office supplies and you can
quickly see the
technology has more than office supplies
but you can also see that phones has
more than art and it breaks it up as a
hierarchy and breaks it up based on your
sum of sales and question two is show
duration or events a duration of events
or activities and you would use a gantt
chart gun charts are used to show
duration
and each of these lines
is a duration so it's like it's got a
start date and end date basically and it
shows you how long everything takes and
the last one is to show
profit growth and you can use a
waterfall chart and that looks like
this where you can see how the profit
changes across every period and if it's
going up or down and each one of these
show you how much up or how much down
they go but as we said there are
potentially other answers to this
question so
if you have any questions about why we
didn't say this chart or that chart go
ahead and comment below and we can start
a discussion question 27 what would you
do if some countries or provinces or any
geographical entity is missing and
displaying a null when you use map view
so when you start to map the
geographical fields that you have
sometimes tableau is unable to map them
because their locations are unknown or
ambiguous meaning a lot of states have a
city called springfield and it won't
know where to draw that city so for
example let's look at
here so we've taken city as our detail
and it's drawn a lot of cities however
it's got a lot of unknown values here so
if this question comes up you've got to
remember these three things
you can edit locations filter the data
or show data at default position
edit locations allows you to correct the
locations
by putting in their unique names we'll
show you an example of this filter the
data means just keep them off of the
view and show day that default position
means show it at zero zero on the map
so edit locations
here we can say here's all of these
cities that seem to exist
in multiple locations and we could say
well we know what state they're in as
well and that should help you answer the
question so you could choose a field
that will define the state so here we're
saying the state is from the state field
and we hit okay
and then they can draw the rest of those
cities
sometimes you want to keep them off
perhaps maybe they spelled city names
wrong and you just want to exclude those
and the last one is show data default
position
which is 0 0
28 what is a level of detail expression
a level of detail expression or an lod
expression is maybe the way they will
present it to you and lod stands for
level of detail so obviously it helps
you get to the level of detail that you
want in your visualization but it also
is used to run complex queries at the
data source level instead of all in the
tableau interface
so we're going to take a look at an
example here which is adding a dimension
to an already
calculated aggregate field
in our case we're going to exclude a
dimension from a calculated field so
here we have
a visualization that i built and right
now it's just looking at sales by
category and subcategory but say we
wanted to look at the total sales for
furniture
and not break it up by the subcategory
so if we take off subcategory
then we get the total sales for
furniture but if we want a side by side
and so that you could see the total
sales for furniture and you can see
it broken up by subcategory you can use
a level of detail calculation
this i already made the field for it
i've called it exclude subcategory so
that's right here
right now it just contains sales
but we're going to use the level of
detail calculation exclude
and we're going to tell it what to
exclude which is subcategory and then
we're going to do
some
of sales so that it will sum it up for
us
and once i apply these changes it should
change it here
and our labels
perfect so now we can see that it's
ignoring the fact that this is chairs
and this is table so this is bookcases
it's just doing the total for furniture
and just ignoring these because we told
it to exclude so level of detail helps
you to be able to define the level that
you want to in your visualization
regardless of what else exists on your
visualization
it also moves some of the logic from
inside of tableau to the actual database
and there are three level of detail
calculations this will be an important
thing to bring up in interviews they
might give you brownie points when you
can remember all three of the level of
detail calculations which are
we looked at exclude
but we have
exclude
include
and
fixed
so include excluder pretty easy to
remember and just always remember fixed
as well question 29 how do you calculate
daily profit measure using level of
detail here's another opportunity for
you to pause the video and take a look
at calculating a daily profit measure
using level of detail we are going to
get started
profitable level of detail so we want to
have a daily profit measure
and i already made a place for it profit
per day
and we want to look at the profit for a
day regardless of what else is on the
visualization so we're going to use a
fixed
instead of an include or an exclude
which will only take into account
whatever you put in for include or
exclude fixed we'll take into account
everything it will ignore everything
else on the visualization and only look
at what's in your list here so we're
going to fix it by day
and you have to put a colon
and we're going to do a sum of profit
for each of those days
and close it off so now we have our
profit per day and we'll hit ok and now
we're going to make a kpi
which for our purposes if profit for a
day is greater than 2000 then that day
is highly profitable if it's less than
zero then it's unprofitable otherwise it
is profitable so we're going to go if
our profit per day
is greater than two thousand
then
we're going to call it highly profitable
elsift
we're going to do less than or equal to
zero
then
profitable
else
otherwise it is profitable
i always have to end with an end
great
okay
so now we're going to make
some visualizations and it's going to
look at it by year
now it all fits in one view
we
can rotate these labels to make it
easier to see and we're going to bring
on
order id
but now it's showing like a lot of
orders and so we actually wanted to be
used as a measure and we're going to do
account distinct
great so now we can see how many orders
we're on each day
and so that's helpful for us to see how
many orders are on this day each day but
we want to see
the orders on each day that are highly
profitable versus unprofitable versus
just profitable so we're going to use
our level of detail and break it up in a
different section
so we have highly profitable profitable
and unprofitable let's also bring this
on to our color
highly profitable profitable and
profitable and now we can see
that the profitable ones are going up
unprofitable ones seem to be going down
in 2015 and that's nice but they are
going up and highly profitable is not
very many
oh in this case we did area charts
instead of just line charts to make that
change you change it from automatic to
area and that helps you see some of that
spatially as well comment below if you
were able to make this visualization on
your own
question 30 how can you schedule a
workbook in tableau after publishing it
so when you publish a workbook in
tableau if you've used an extract you're
going to need to refresh that extract so
in tableau when you create a tableau
data source and it's an extract version
of the data source it will no longer
update if the data from your database
updates so somebody's made some changes
to your database or your excel file and
you want to see that in your tableau
visualization well you're not going to
see it but you can see it if you make a
refresh so you do that on tableau server
and you can remember that you have to
get all the way to your data source so
you can go to your data sources or to
your workbooks
and then
you look at the data source on your
workbook and you go actions extract
refresh and then you select schedule a
refresh so that looks like this you can
press these three dots next to it and
click refresh extracts or you can go to
actions and then here you click schedule
a refresh instead of refresh now and
then oftentimes in tableau you'll have
several different options you can choose
daily at seven a.m or every four hours
if an interviewer is asking you
about how to schedule a refresh it might
be worthwhile bringing up the fact that
you only need to schedule a refresh
if you are
using an extract on your data source and
then that will help them know that you
know the difference between live and
extracts if they didn't ever ask that
question so with that we have come to an
end of this w expert full course if you
have any queries regarding the topics
covered in the session or if you need
the data sets or the code used in this
particular tutorial then please feel
free to write us down in the comment
section below and our team of experts
will be happy to resolve all your
queries until next time thank you stay
safe and keep learning
you